MORNING WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY. IT IS
MAY FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY. TO
START I LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
STOP THAT HAVE MADE OUR RETURN
TO THE CAPITAL TO HEAR THE
BILL'S POSSIBLE THIS INCLUDES
STAFF FROM THE ASSEMBLY RULES
THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE DATACENTER WHO PUT
IN COUNTLESS HOURS PROCURING
AND CONFIGURING THE NEW
EQUIPMENT AND TECHNOLOGY. WERE
ABLE TO USE TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTICIPATION
AND I'LL HEARINGS. TO THAT END
I WILL NOW SURE A FEW NOTES
ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF OUR
HEARING TODAY. REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION TO HELP PRESERVE
THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE.
AND ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS
TO THE DISCUSSION. DUE TO THE
CURRENT STATE HOLE ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. THAT BEING SAID WE
WILL ABIDE BY TYPICAL COMMITTEE
PROCEDURES. AND HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TO IN OPPOSITION TESTIFYING
FOR TWO MINUTES EACH. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM TODAY EN
ROUTE FORTY TWO OH TWO WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING. IN THIS SPACE
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE ELEVEN
MEMBERS. A MINIMAL CONTINGENT
OF STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACING.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL EVER THOSE HERE TODAY
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC AND THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I WOULD ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING WILL RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. NOW FOR DIAL
IN WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH
TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY PRIVACY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING END PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING. HIS OR HER BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING AND
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MEETING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE TO
SOUND DISTORTION. YOU CAN ALSO
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO TWO ZERO
ZERO IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE. AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP
OUT. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONIES. THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT NOT THAT'S TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL THERE'S RESPECTFUL OF
THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH CONCERNS AT
WE ALL FACE. AT THIS TIME LET'S
ESTABLISH QUORUM BEFORE WE ARE
GONE SO MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR ME.
HERE. YOUR DEAR YEAH YEAH
LAWLER. GALLAGHER. YEAH RIGHT%
YEAH WE ARE QUORUM. NOW TURNING
TO THE BILLS BEFORE US TODAY IN
RESPONSE TO THE CONSTRAINTS
CIRCLE THAT NINETEENTH CRISIS
IS PLACED ON THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THE COMMITTEE ELECTED
TO FOCUS ATTENTION DISCUSSION
ON BILLS THAT ADDRESS ONLY THE
MOST URGENT ISSUES AND ISSUES
THAT ARE CRITICAL FOR AN
EFFICIENT RECOVERY. LIMITING
THE AMOUNT OF BILLS THAT WILL
BE HEARD WAS A DIFFICULT
DECISION AND ONE THAT I DO NOT
TAKE LIGHTLY. MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE PROPOSED MEANINGFUL
LEGISLATION ADDRESSING DIVERSE
ISSUES WITHIN THE PRIVACY
SPACE. MANY OF WHICH I BELIEVE
WILL ULTIMATELY BE IN THE LONG
TERM BEST INTEREST OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT AS LEGISLATORS WE
HOW IS SERIOUS AND SOBER. UP
DUTY TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
SAFETY AND PRIVACY INTEREST OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE MOST AT
RISK TODAY. IN TWENTY TWENTY.
THE CRISIS BEFORE US HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO CHANGE THE PRIVACY
LANDSCAPE FOR DECADES TO COME.
AND I'LL RESPONSE WAS SERVE AS
PRESIDENT FOR LEGISLATORS LAW
AFTER WE HAVE LEFT THIS
BUILDING. SIMPLY PUT IT IS
IMPORTANT WE GET THIS RIGHT TO
THAT END I ASKED MY COLLEAGUES
WOULD BILLS IN A PRIVACY
COMMITTEE TO SUBMIT STATEMENT.
OF CRITICALITY ARGUING WHY
THEIR BILLS SHOULD MOVE FORWARD
THIS YEAR IN LIGHT OF THE COLD
AT NINETEEN CRISIS. I'M
GRATEFUL TO MY FELLOW MEMBERS
WHO ROSE TO THE OCCASION AND-
LIKE TRUE LEADERS TABLE A
NUMBER OF YOUR BILLS LEAVING
ONLY THEMOST URGENT MATTERS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY. AS
WE STRIVE TO PROVE PREVENT
TREAT AND CONTROL COVERT
NINETEEN WE MUST ALSO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN. PROTECTING
PRIVACY IN PROMOTING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. AS SUCH I STAND READY
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO
CLOSELY ANALYZE BOTH. EMERGING
TO OUR LEGISLATION AND PRIVATE
AND GOVERNMENT PRACTICES TO
ENSURE THAT CIVIC. LIBERTY LIT
CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE NOT
COMPROMISED AND ALL FIGHT TO
CONTROL THE PANDEMIC. I FEEL A
DUTY TO FOSTER AN ENVIRONMENT
TO ENSURE THAT BOTH
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
CIVIL LIBERTY. AND HISTORY OF
INNOVATION REMAIN INTACT.
TOGETHER WE CAN GRILL. DURING
THIS CRISIS IN A MANNER TO FALL
AT THE THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TO BE ADAPTIVE RESPONSIVE
AND FLEXIBLE TO THE NEEDS OF
THE STATE AS A WHOLE. I'M SO
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN TO
OUR FIRST AUTHOR- ONE AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY NINE THIS GONZALEZ I
LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO. COME ON
UP TO PRESENT YOUR BILL. JUST A
QUICK REMINDER FOR THOSE
WISHING TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION BY PHONE.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO CALL IN NOW.
THE BEGINNING OF THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS TESTIMONY TO
AVOID ANY DELAYS. THE PHONE
NUMBER AGAIN IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN SO WITH THAT DOW
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ OF PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THIS BILL WITH
BROAD THE IDEA WAS BROUGHT TO
YOU BY LOCAL RESTAURANT AND
QUITE HONESTLY IT WAS BROUGHT
TO ME BEFORE HIS HAND AND WHAT
ABOUT THIS PANDEMIC IN
WHATEVER. RESTAURANT THE ISSUE
AT HAND WAS A NUMBER PRACTICES
THAT SEEM TO GO ON BETWEEN.
DELIVERY OUT AND RESTAURANTS.
SOME RESTAURANTS ARE VERY HAPPY
WITH THE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
DELIVERY AFTER SOMEONE HAD A
LOT OF WORK TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE. ACTUALLY
RESTAURANTS DON'T WANT DELIVERY
APPS TO DELIVER THEIR FOOD AND
THERE'S A VARIETY OF REASONS
FOR WHY. TAKE CONTROL THE
TEMPERATURE THE TIME PERIOD BY
WHICH THEIR FOOD GETS-
DELIVERED THEY THEY HAVE
CERTAIN STANDARDS THAT THEY
WANT MATT OR THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN DELIVERY DRIVERS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY EMPLOYEES OF THE
RESTAURANT. WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WAS THESE COMPANIES WERE
ADVERTISING AND DELIVERING FOOD
FROM RESTAURANTS THAT HAD NOT
GIVEN PERMISSION OR HAD NO
RELATIONSHIP IN FACT ASKED
THESE COMPANIES NOT TO DELIVER
THEIR FOOT. FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT RELY ON THEIR
CLIENTELE AND THE REPUTATION
THIS CREATED A PROBLEM. SO WE
START SPORTY WITH THE
RESTAURANTS WAYS IN WHICH WE
COULD DEAL WITH THE SITUATION
BECAUSE THERE WERE SOME.
RESULTS THAT THAT HAPPENED. AS
AS ARE THERE THERE WERE ACTIONS
THAT HAPPEN AS A RESULT OF
THESE DELIVERY DRIVERS POSTING
THEIR MENUS ONLINE. SOME OF
WHICH WERE THE DELIVERY
COMPANIES WOULD THEN GO BACK TO
THE RESTAURANT AFTER THEY HAD.
BASICALLY COOPTED PART OF THEIR
CLIENTELE AND SAY OKAY NOW
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY US FOR
THESE DELIVERIES. IN AT THE
RESTAURANT SAID NO. THEN THE
DELIVERY COMPANY WHO HAVE ALL
THE INFORMATION AND I JUST
WANNA GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE LET'S
SAY YOUR FAVORITE CHINESE
RESTAURANT IS DOWN THE STREET.
AND IT'S KINGS CHINESE
RESTAURANT AND EVERY FRIDAY
NIGHT YOU AND YOUR SPOUSE OR
MONGOLIAN BEEF EVERY FRIDAY
NIGHT YOUR TRADITION. HAPPENS
QUITE OFTEN. AND SO YOU CALL. A
COMPANY I DON'T WANT TO CALL
ANY OF THEM OUT TO HAVE IT
DELIVERED HOME FOR YOUR DATE
NINE. HAPPENS EVERY FRIDAY
NIGHT. WELL I'M BE NUTS TO YOU
THEY GET A SPAT WITH THE
RESTAURANT AT THE RESTAURANT
DOESN'T WANT TO PAY A
COMMISSION TO THEM AND SO
INSTEAD THE COMPANY BECAUSE
IT'S THE DELIVERY COMPANY THAT
NOW HAS ALL YOUR INFORMATION
YOUR LIKES WHEN YOU ORDER IT
HOW MUCH YOU ORDER SAYS. YOU
KNOW WHAT. WE'LL GIVE YOU THAT
SAME EXACT ORDER BUT FROM KINGS
CHINESE FOOD TO. SO THERE YOU
SEEN THE RESTAURANT TO TAKE
THEIR CUSTOMERS. AND THE
RESTAURANT HAS NO CONTROL OF
THIS SO WE STARTED SPORTING
WAYS IN WHICH THE RESTAURANTS
COULD HAVE MORE POWER TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR OWN
CLIENTS AND TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE ONLY LISTED ON THESE
PLATFORMS IF THEY HAVE AN
AGREEMENT. WE STARTED OFF WITH
A KIND OF SHARING OF
INFORMATION BILL NOW WE
UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT WOULD RUN
INTO SOME PROBLEMS ESPECIALLY
THIS COMMITTEE BUT PROBLEMS
THAT WE WANTED TO TRY TO GET
THROUGH WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
FIGURE THAT PIECE OUT SO WE
AGREED TO PULL THAT PIECE BACK
AND STILL CONTINUE TO TRY TO
WORK ON. WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE CAN CUSTOMERS HAVE THE
POWER TO SAY YES THE RESTAURANT
CAN HAVE MY INFORMATION. OR CAN
THEY OPT OUT OF THAT. BUT
BECAUSE OF OUR SHORTENED
SCHEDULE IN THE AMOUNT OF TIME
WE COULD WORK ON THIS BILL THAT
PIECE WE'VE TAKEN COMPLETELY
OUT AND NOW WE JUST HAVE THE
REQUIREMENTTHAT THERE BE A
CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIP. AND
ALL THIS SAYS IS BASICALLY THAT
FOR A DELIVERY PLATFORM TO PUT
UP THE MANUAL TO PUT THE LOGO
TO ACT LIKE THERE IS A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
RESTAURANT THE DELIVERY COMPANY
THAT THERE HAS TO BE A WRITTEN.
CONTRACT BETWEEN THE RESTAURANT
AND THE DELIVERY COMPANY THIS
WILL PREVENT THE RESTAURANTS
WHO DON'T WANT TO BE LISTED
FROM BEING LISTED IT'S SIMPLE
IT'S FAIR AND AS WE MOVE OUT OF
THIS PANDEMIC WHEN SO MANY
RESTAURANTS HAVE. RELIED IN
SOMETIMES TO THEIR KNOWLEDGE
SOMETIMES WITHOUT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE ON DELIVERY AND PICK
UP IT'S A WAY FOR THEM TO GAIN
SOME CONTROL ESPECIALLY SMALL
RESTAURANTS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
WITH OUR CUSTOMER AGAIN SO WITH
THAT- I ASKED I KNOW THAT
THAT'S WILL NEED WORK THE
ISSUES ADDRESSED IN. ANALYSIS
ARE ISSUES PRIMARILY- FOR THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE- AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT BECAUSE OF
COURSE AGAIN WERE UNDER KIND OF
UNUSUAL TIMES- THIS IS WHERE
THIS BILL IS NOW THE PRIVACY
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN STRIPPED IF
WE PUT ANYTHING THAT WHAT WOULD
RESULT IN KIND OF THE SHARING
OF INFORMATION IT WILL COME
BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE AND WE
WERE WE SAID WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMITTEE. BUT
FOR NOW IT'S JUST GOVERNING
THAT CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE ON A BILL THAT I THINK
MIGHT BE THE FIRST THE BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GREAT THE BILL'S
VINCE MOVED AND SECONDED LET'S
SELF FIRST TO GO TO OUR WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE MR MATSON OF
FROM CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION BY WAY OF
TELEPHONE. MISTER SUN NOW YOU
ARE YOU THERE. YES MISTER CHAIR
GOOD MORNING COULD MAKE YOU THE
MAP THAT WILL BE. GOOD MORNING
THE MOMENT THAT WOULD DOUBLE
YOUR RESTAURANTS THIS NATION.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONSULT BILL AB TWENTY
FORTY NINE AS YOU HEARD THE
BILL REQUIRED DELIVERY
PLATFORMS TO RECEIVE PERMISSION
FROM A RESTAURANT PRIOR TO
POSTING A RESTAURANT LOGO- MENU
ON THE PLATFORM. DOES MIGHT
STRIKE YOU AS COMMONSENSE
PRINCIPLE JUST GOOD BUSINESS
PRACTICE WE AGREE HOWEVER
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THE GROUND. IN MANY OF YOUR
DISTRICTS WITH REGARDS TO THE
DELIVERY AFTER THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY RESTAURANTS. ROBERTS
BUT IT'LL NO MEANS NEW IT'S
BEEN- INCREASING AT A RAPID
RATE OVER THE YEARS AND IT
CERTAINLY GOT MORE PRONOUNCED
DURING THE PUBLIC. HEALTH
CRISIS WITH WILL BE NINETEEN.
IT'S BEING EXAGGERATED. BUT IT
DEEPER WE FIND OURSELVES IN THE
CRISIS PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
RESTAURANTS ARE NOW LIMITED TO
ONLY OPERATING WILL TAKE OUT
AND DELIVERY. LIKE MANY NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THE EMERGENCE OF
TO DELIVERY PLATFORMS CREATED
IN DIRECT INSTRUCTION AND
STATEWIDE FOOD. SERVICE
COMMUNITY AND THAT DESTRUCTION
IS BECOME MORE PRONOUNCED AS
I'VE MENTIONED. THE TYPE
BUSINESS PRACTICE THAT THAT'S
ON THE WOMAN DEVELOP THIS IS
GOING. TO ADDRESS MAY HELP THE
FOOD DELIVERY ABSTRACT TRAFFIC
TO THEIR WEB PLATFORMS BUT HER
RESTAURANT THE CREATES
CONFUSION. IT HURTS OUR BRANDS
IT HURTS OUR INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS AND IT CERTAINLY
THE TRUCK STOP OR OPERATIONS.
THE SOME CASES RESTAURANT
THIRTY HAVE A DELIVERY SYSTEM
IN PLACE OPERATED BY THEIR OWN
EMPLOYEES. IF THEIR MENU AND
THEN LISTED ON AND I'M NOT
AUTHORIZED TO DELIVERY PLATFORM
pABOUT THE RESTAURANT AND THE
DELIVERY DRIVER WHO SHOWS UP.
THE CUSTOMER THE DRIVER IN THE
RESTAURANT AND UP LOSING
BECAUSE THE CUSTOMER DOES NOT
GET THEIR FOOD. SOMETIMES THE
DRIVER HE ATE AND THE
RESTAURANTS REPUTATION IS
DAMAGED IN THE IN THE MEANTIME.
ANOTHER IS WITH THIS GOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORMS MIGHT POST
AN OUTDATED MENU. FOR A LOCAL
AT THE RESTAURANT. THE CHANCES
ARE FOR CUSTOMERS ORDERING WITH
AN OUTDATED MENU OR OUTDATED
PRODUCT. FROM THE RESTAURANT
THE THIRD PARTY APPS WEBSITE.
THEN THERE'S GONNA BE ISSUES
WITH THEIR FOOD ORDER. THAT
LEADS TO CONFUSION BUT NOT JUST
CONFUSION AT LEAST THE ANGER AT
THE RESTAURANT IT IS VIEWED AS
THE RESTAURANTS FALL WHEN THE-
BALLPARK AFTER THE TO THE
RESTAURANT. AS WE ALL KNOW
RESTAURANTS ARE BASING ON
OF YOU SENIOR DISTRICT MORE
THAN EVER IF YOU RETURNED YOUR
DISTRICTS IN MID MARCH TO SERVE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS THAT
RESTAURANTS- AND UNBELIEVABLY
UNCHARTERED TERRITORY WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH- EPIDEMIC. WE'VE
ESTIMATED THAT MORE THAN ONE
MILLION RESTAURANT EMPLOYEES TO
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN LAID OFF- LOW
TO BEGINNING THE CORE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK IN MARCH.
IN THE MONTH OF APRIL ESTIMATED
REVENUE LOSSES FOR THE FOOD
SERVICE INDUSTRY IS OVER SIX
BILLION DOLLARS. AT THE SAME
TIME THE FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORMS ARE EXPERIENCING
UNPRECEDENTED GROWTH AS
CONSUMERS ARE REQUIRED STATE
HOMES THE MATTER PUBLIC HEALTH.
THAT'S WHY IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
NEVER TO ENSURE THE RESTAURANT-
DELIVERY PLATFORMS ARE
OPERATING IN PARTNERSHIP. IN A
WAY THAT BENEFITS THE CONSUMER
THE RESTAURANT THE FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORM. WHAT A
PLATFORM USES A RESTAURANT
LOWER MENU THAT APPLIES TO
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
ENTITIES NOT ALL FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORMS TAKING SUCH
AGGRESSIVE TACTICS TO GROW
THEIR BUSINESS. BY ON UP RIGHT
USE OF OUR PRODUCTS. I'M GOOD
DELIVERY CLASSROOMS ARE TRUE
PARTNERS WITH RESTAURANTS. WE
BELIEVE ALL FOOD TO PLATFORM TO
COMMIT PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL DELIVERY
PLATFORM USES THE RESTAURANT
LOGO THE MENU WITHOUT THE
PERMISSION THE BENEFIT TO THE
TO DELIVERY PLATFORM OUTWEIGHED
ANY POTENTIAL BENEFIT OF
EXPANDING RESTAURANTS CUSTOMER
BASE. THIS BILL HELPS RESTORE
THAT EQUITY BACKING OF THE
RELATIONSHIP. THE THAT. ARE IF
YOU WILL THE MIDDLE PERSON WITH
MILLIONS IF NOT BILLIONS
FUNDING IT LONG FRUSTRATED MANY
IN THE RESTAURANT COMMUNITY
WITH THESE TYPES OF PRACTICES.
PRACTICES THAT SOME PLATFORMS
TO DISMISSIVELY TERMS CLERICAL
ERRORS WHEN THEY HAVE
UNAUTHORIZED USE OF OUR
PRODUCTS ON THEIR WEBSITE.
WHILE OTHERS INCLUDING A SAN
FRANCISCO MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISOR HAVE TURNED THAT
PREDATORY DELIBERATE PRACTICE.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE THE SIMPLE STEPS. AND HELP
GET THE SKILLS OF EQUITY BACK
TOWARDS THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
RESTAURANT WHICH HAD TREMENDOUS
VALUE TO THE STATE'S OVERALL
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY. AND WE'RE
PROUD THAT THAT SIGNAL THE
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY BOASTS 60%
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT. OWNED BY
PEOPLE OF COLOR THE RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY AT LEAST PRIOR TO
COPE WITH NINETEEN WAS THE
LARGEST PRIVATE EMPLOYER IN THE
SATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND HAD
THE LARGEST GENERATION IF
THEY'LL LOCAL. OF STATE AND
LOCAL SALES TAX WHICH WE ALL
KNOW NOW ESPECIALLY COMMUNITIES
ARE GONNA DEPEND ON THE BILL
TAX DOLLARS MORE THAN EVER.
YOU'LL LIKELY HEAR PROPONENTS
THAT THE CURRENT BETTER ALLOWED
DRESSES THIS PROBLEM. IT'S BEEN
A HANDFUL OF RECENT LAWSUIT
CALIFORNIA ILLINOIS AND NEW
HAMPSHIRE BETWEEN RESTAURANT-
DELIVERY PLATFORMS OVER
COPYRIGHT INFRINGEMENT. OTHER
STATES DO ARE CONTEMPLATING
SIMILAR LEGISLATION THAT THIS
INTELLIGENCE PRESENTING TODAY
BANNING THE ON OFF RIGHT USED
RESTAURANT LOGO OR MANY.
FEDERAL COPYRIGHT LAW IS NOT
CLEAR AND WOULD NOT PROVIDE
ENOUGH PROTECTION THE
RESTAURANT. THAT WAS STATING
THAT FEDERAL OUT SOME INTIMATE
INTERMEDIARY STILL ACTIVE USER
MENU ANYWAY. THIS IS CERTAINLY
EVIDENCE WE FEEL THAT FEDERAL
LAW DOES NOT DETER THE ACTIVITY
AND MAY EVEN ALLOW IT. THERE'S
LITTLE LEGITIMATE ROLE FOR TH
STATE TO DEEM A PRACTICE UNFAIR
UNDER STATE LAW AND PROHIBITED.
I DON'T THINK ONE CAN ARGUE
THAT COPYRIGHT LAWSUIT PROCEEDS
ALLSTATE EFFORT LEAST UNFAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES MR SUDDEN
QUOTING. GOOD PLACE CUT. PLEASE
PROCEDURE OUT OF CONDITIONS
MATT AS A AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC
POLICY FOR THIS COMMITTEE WITH
A CALIFORNIA SHOULD STEP UP AND
BRING THE EQUITY INTO THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
RESTAURANTS AND FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORMS. THANK YOU YOU
OUTLINED SOME PARAMETERS
MOMENTS AGO AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS HEARING. FOR THE LAND IS
IN WHICH YOU SUGGEST THIS
COMMITTEE LOOK AT BILLS IN THE
MIDST OF COVERED NINETEEN. WE
APPRECIATE THAT AND WE THINK
THIS BILL ALIGNS PERFECTLY WITH
THAT VISION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION WE
APPRECIATE THE HOLDING THIS
HEARING AND ALLOWING US THE
TEST BY THROUGH THESE REMOTE
MEANS. AND WE CERTAINLY THANK
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE ABOUT THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER CERTAIN-
AT THIS POINT LIKE TO TURN TO
ALL OTHER SUPPORTERS SAW
ONLINE. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF- YOUR ASSOCIATION AND
YOUR POSITION. AND IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO MAKE A
COMMENT AND SUPPORT AT THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN IF THERE IS ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
THAT'S ONE ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
HEARING NO ONE LET'S
TURNED HER ORTEZ ON SOME WE DO.
AND WE HAVE AMALIA AND MANY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE MILLION THE
MONEY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE A PART OF THE SELF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. AND ONE MOMENT FOR YOUR
PATIENT PLEASE WE DON'T HAVE A
FEELING CAN THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LONG RANGE
THE HOLY PLACE BY HAND. MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER COMMITTEE- MY NAME
IS MAUREEN MAHONEY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE GOAL OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERING IT- WE DO HOPE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO
INSURE THAT THE LEGISLATION
DOESN'T IN IMPORTANTLY
INTERFERE WITH CONSUMERS. ARE
THINKING BECAUSE REVIEWS ARE
OTHER GENERATED CONTENT- BUT
AGAIN THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
CONSIDERING LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU MUCH ANYONE ELSE. AND WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT.
THANKS IF THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
SO LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITION. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE MR ROBERT
CALLAGHAN FROM THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION OF TESTIFYING WE AT
THE FALL. AND ALSO- IS CORNY
JENSEN SO PLEASE GO AHEAD
MISTER CALLAHAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- ROBERT
CALLAGHAN WITH THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION AND- WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL AND PLAN FOR THE
PRIVACY RELATED REASONS THAT
WERE. NOT FULLY LAID OUT IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS. THE DATA
SHARING MANDATE- WE DO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR REMOVING THIS
LANGUAGE- THROUGH THE MEMBERS
ARE TAKING TODAY THAT SAD. BUT
WE'RE STILL WORKING THROUGH THE
IMPLICATIONS RAISED BY THE NEW
LANGUAGE OF THE EXPRESS WRITTEN
CONSENT REQUIREMENTS- AMONG THE
CONCERNS RAISED IN ALICE'S WERE
ALSO- DURING THE EXTENT TO
WHICH- IT MAY NOT NECESSARILY
LEAD TO. INTERRUPTIONS IN
SERVICE FOR THE MARRIED
RESTAURANTS TO DO BENEFIT FROM
BEING LISTED ON A TO DO EVERY
PLATFORM AND ACTUALLY DO WANT
TO BE ON THE PLATFORM SO- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND THE PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL. MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CALLAHAN LET'S NOT- NOW O TO
MS SO COURTNEY TENSE AND FROM
TECHNET. PLEASE GO AHEAD MR
ANSON. YOU MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
CORPS IN JENSEN ATTACK MATT AND
TECH MATT IS ALSO OPPOSED AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE AND GRANT
AND I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE INTERNET AT THE BEACH
AND- WE DO APPRECIATE THE
PRIVACY PROVISIONS BEING
REMOVED FROM THE BELL AND ARE
REVIEWING THE WORKABILITY AND
THE EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT
LANGUAGE. BUT YOU HAVE DONE
CONCERNS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS CAN FIND A PATH
FORWARD THAT WORKS FOR
RESTAURANTS AND FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORM. THE RELATIONSHIPS OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES HAVE WHAT
THEIR RESTAURANT PARTNERS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE NO BETTER
HIGHLIGHTED BY THE WORKER
COMPANIES HAVE DONE. FOR THE
INDUSTRY DURING THE COLD BUT
NINETEEN CRISIS AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THE BILL WILL BENEFIT
THE INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ADDITIONAL. IN THE- IN
ALL. TO THE BILL. AND IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL PLEASE AT ONE AND
ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT AFFECTS
COMMON. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SHARKS. YEAH. WE HAVE
A COMMENT FROM SAMANTHA CORBIN
PLEASE CLAN. WHAT THE COURT ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION I'D LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HER WORK
HE WOULD NEED AND THAT THEIR
CONCERNS RELATED TO PRIVACY IN
THE MEASURE WITH HER AMENDMENTS
TODAY WE DO HAVE SOME
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS ALREADY
ACCUMULATED BY COLLEAGUES.
OBVIOUSLY AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING ON THE ISSUES WITH
THE OFFERING JUDICIARY. THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU IF THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS PLEASE-
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. MR OBERNOLTE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THIS IS A- AN
INTERESTING BILL OBVIOUSLY KIND
OF A NEW SITUATION WITH A DATE
AMICK BETWEEN FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORMS AND RESTAURANTS. BUT
NOT A NEW ISSUE AT ALL I MEAN
WE HAVE A- HUNDRED YEARS OF
CASE LAW WHERE- MANUFACTURES OR
WHOLESALERS HAVE YOU KNOW WHICH
IS THE RATE OF THE RESTAURANT
IN THIS CASE HAVE DISPUTES WITH
DISTRIBUTORS OF PRODUCTS. AND
THE- FEDERAL LAW HAS HAS PRETTY
NARROWLY CONSTRAIN THE ABILITY
OF A MANUFACTURER WHOLESALER TO
PUT. RESTRICTIONS ON THE- THE
USE OF THEIR PRODUCTS BY PEOPLE
FURTHER DOWN THE VALUE CHAIN SO
I'D I'D START OUT WITH A LITTLE
BIT OF SKEPTICISM. I THINK THE
PRIVACY. IMPLICATIONS OF THE
BILL ARE VERY INTERESTING AND I
HAD TWO QUESTIONS RELATED
QUESTIONS LASSEN BOTH THE SAME
TIME AND BE INTERESTED TO HEAR
YOUR RESPONSE SO THE FIRST OF
THEM IS THAT- THE BILL AS
AMENDED. WE PROHIBITS A FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORM FROM USING
THE MENU OR THE LOCAL
RESTAURANT WITHOUT THEIR
PERMISSION. SO KIND OF TWO
DIFFERENT ISSUES IN MY OPINION
SO THE MENU- IS AN INTERESTING
CASE BECAUSE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S ALREADY BEING. PUT OUT
FOR PUBLIC CONSUMPTION BY THE
RESTAURANT ITSELF SO IT'S
ALREADY IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
PRIVATE INFORMATION OF THE
RESTAURANT- SO MY QUESTION IS
HOW IS THAT NOT FAIR USE
BECAUSE MIDDLE OF LARGE BODY OF
CASE LAW THAT SAYS THAT THAT.
THE GENERALLY THAT'S FAIR USE
WITH CAN YOU YOUR PUTTING YOU
REDISTRIBUTE SOMETHING THAT
ALREADY HAS BEEN PUT OUT IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN BY SOMEONE. AND
THEN RELATED QUESTION ON THE
LOGO. LOGO IS KIND OF A
DIFFERENT ISSUE THAT'S THAT'S
UNDER COPYRIGHT LAW WHICH IS
FEDERAL LAW SO- YOU KNOW
FEDERAL COPYRIGHT LAWS GOVERNS
THE USE OF THAT LOOK AT WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S FAIR USE NOT
WONDERING HOW. THAT FEDERAL
LAWS NOT PREEMPTIVE OF ANY KIND
OF A TEMPLATE THAT WE MAKE HERE
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO. RESTRICT
THE USE OF THE LOOK THOSE LONG.
SO THE FOR. FIRST OF ALL I
THINK THE WAY THAT YOU'RE
THINKING OF IT MOM IS- LIKE THE
MANUFACTURE TO THE DELIVERY YES
THIS I KIND OF A UNIQUE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PREPARED HOT FOOD SO
COULD BE THOUGHT IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT WAY WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE DELIVERY
DRIVER IN THE RESTAURANT IS A
DELIVERY COMPANY IS ACTUALLY
PURCHASING FOOD AND RESELLING
IT TO THE CUSTOMER. THAT I
THINK EVEN IN EXISTING LAW
COULD CREATE OTHER ISSUES WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SURVIVAL
FOOD- AND SO WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT A WIDGET OR OR AN ITEM
RIGHT IN THE SALE OF IT WE'RE
TALKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
PREPARED FOOD- AS FAR AS THE
MENU GOES THE PROBLEM WITH
HAVING AN INTERMEDIARY- SUCH AS
THE DELIVERY BERNIE. OUT AN
AGREEMENT IS WHEN THE
RESTAURANT NO LONGER USES THAT
MANUAL- THERE'S NO WAY FOR THE
RESTAURANT TO TELL THE CUSTOMER
THAT BECAUSE THE CUSTOMERS NOT
DIRECTLY CONTACTING THE
RESTAURANT IN THE RESTAURANT IS
NOT SOMETIMES EVEN KNOWING THAT
EIGHT DELIVERY COMPANY IS OUT
THERE- DEAN OLD BANYA. AS SO
CUSTOMER I SEE THIS HAVE NO
IDEA THAT THIS RESTAURANT HAS
NO RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
DELIVERY COMPANY BECAUSE ARE
YOU THERE YET GO FOR INSTANCE
IN THERE IS A- SHIP BETWEEN THE
TWO COMPANIES I MAY. HE WRAP
ALL. AND IN BECAUSE SOME OF
RESTAURANTS BUSINESS IS ALSO
DRIVEN BY THINGS LIKE YELP AND
THAT YOU KNOW CRITICISM I'M A
CUSTOMER I ORDER SOMETHING THAT
I ASSUME IS ON THE MENU BECAUSE
THAT'S A MAN YOU THAT HAS BEEN
GIVEN TO ME IT'S NOT I'M NOT
TOLD THAT WHEN I ORDER IT IN
FACT I'M NOT TOLD THAT TOOK
THREE HOURS LATER WHEN MY
DELIVERY DOESN'T COM AND THEN I
GO ON AND EIGHT NEGATIVE
COMMENT ON YELP AFFECTS THAT
BUSINESSES. BUSINESS EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH THIS ENTIRE DISSEMINATION
THIS IS HAPPENING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN SO I THINK WE'RE ENTERING
INTO INTO A NEW. TYPE OF- FAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICE GOING ON AND
SO I THINK TO LOOK AT IT AND
KIND OF THAT NARAL OLD
MANUFACTURE VERSES SELLER IT IS
A LITTLE LIMITED- AND THAT'S-
THE I THINK THE MAIN CREST. I
WOULD GO THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION SAYS THE
COPYRIGHT LAWS AREN'T WORKING.
AND SO WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY
WOULD BE- FEDERALLY PREEMPTED
BUT THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT
WORKING FOR THESE RESTAURANTS.
THANK YOU ARE SO THE IT IS TRUE
THAT THIS IS AN ENGINE
INTERESTING A NEW SITUATION BUT
TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
UNIQUE ELEMENTS. THAT ARE
BROUGHT. BY THE FACT THAT THIS
IS WHAT THE PROVISION OF FOOD I
THINK THOSE ARE MIGHT MIGHT BE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS ME
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW FOR LIKE
FAIR USE AND COPYRIGHT LAW. I
THINK THE ISSUES REALLY AREN'T
NEW ISSUES AND YOU KNOW FAIR
USE HAS DEALT WITH THIS ISSUE
BEFORE YOU BROUGHT UP THE ISSUE
OF. WHAT HAPPENS OF THE MENU
HAS CHANGED. AND THAT'S ALSO A
FAIR USE ISSUE BECAUSE I MEAN
WHAT IF I I'M A BLOGGER AND I
REPOST SOMETHING THAT THE NEW
YORK TIMES.I HAD AN ARTICLE
THIS MORNING AND SUBSEQUENTLY
THE NEW YORK TIMES. DISCOVERS
AN ACCURACY IN THE ARTICLE NAY
UPDATED AND I HAVEN'T UPDATED
MY BLOG IT'S EXACTLY THE SAME
SITUATION AND YET THAT. THAT'S
CONSIDERED FAIR USE IN AND JUST
TO DO THAT WE OFFER. A LOT OF
WORKING WITH THE- DOESN'T. THE
MATERIALITY OF WHETHER OR NOT
WE CAN PREEMPTED BY PASSING A
ROW SEAT VERSIONS SO I JUST
HAVE A BIG CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
I THINK. WHEN THE DUST SETTLES
WE'RE GOING TO DISCOVER THAT
THESE ARE ALL ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN LITIGATED ENDLESSLY BEFORE
AND WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY OF FITTING HAND. SOLUTIONS
TO THE YOU PROBLEM INTO WORK OF
WHAT'S BEFORE AND I'M NOT. WHAT
WE ARE HERE YOU KNOW RISE THAT.
BUT I ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORKING
OUT AND I'LL BE. BACK FOR.
THANK THE YOU MUCH EITHER AT
THIS KINDS QUESTIONS. BASIC I
TO GO. I'M QUESTION EITHER FOR
THE AUTHOR OR PERHAPS FOR THE-
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION- SO WHAT
ARE THE ACTUAL COUPLE QUESTIONS
AND WHAT'S THE ABILITY UNDER
EXISTING LAW FOR A RESTAURANT
THAT DOESN'T WANT THAT THESE
DELIVERY PLATFORMS- TO COME
INTO THAT REST ESTABLISHMENT TO
JUST SAY WE DON'T. ACCEPT
DELIVERIES FROM COMPANY X. Y.
Z. AND THEN RELATEDLY- IN CASES
WHERE RESTAURANTS HAVE REACHED
OUT TO THESE COMPANIES AND SAID
WE DON'T WANT YOU TO LIST US ON
YOUR PLATFORM WHAT IS THE
RESPONSE GENERALLY BEEN TO THE
AGREE OR THEY REFUSE. KILEY THE
MAP BUTTON WITH THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION- MISTER WILL NOT YEAR
QUESTIONS AS WELL- REALLY WHAT
WHAT THE ISSUE IS IT HERE AND
CERTAINLY NO MENUS TO THE
PREVIOUS QUESTION MENUS. ARE
OUT IN PUBLIC- ADMITS GONZALEZ
STATED. THE USE OF THESE
MATERIALS WITHOUT CONSENT TO
JEFF THAT THERE'S A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN OUR
RESTAURANTS AND THE- THIRD
PARTY ENTITIES WHICH IN MANY OF
THESE CASES IS NOT ACCURATE.
AND IT MATTERS FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS ONE OF THE REASONS IS
WE'RE SERVING PREPARED FOOD. WE
ARE REGULATED RIGHTFULLY SO BY
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT ABOUT
THE CONDITION THAT SUIT. IN
THESE CASES WE HAVE NO IDEA OF
THE CHAIN OF CUSTODY OF THE
FOOD AND SO IT BECOMES VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. COMMUNITY ALSO.
AT THE RELATED TO PAIR. FOOD
AND OUR NEED. TO KNOW AND WHO
IS THIS IT. WITHOUT CONSENT OF
OUR PRODUCTS ON THE WEB. WE
DON'T KNOW THAT. MR KILEY IT
TENDS TO BE A LARGER ISSUE WITH
THE SMALLER INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANT AND WE HAVE HEARD
REPEATEDLY FOR YEARS. WITH AN
UPTICK IN COMPLAINT LATELY THAT
THEY DO TRY TO SOLVE THIS ONE
ON ONE WITH THIRD PARTY ENTITY.
THIRD PARTY ENTITY USUALLY
RESPONSE WITH SOME SORT OF IT'S
A CLERICAL ERROR WILL FIX IT
AND THAT THAT THE GENERALLY
HAPPENS IN SO THE SMALLER
RESTAURANTS THAT DON'T HAVE THE
LEVERAGE. OF THE LARGER CHAIN
RESTAURANTS. HAVE LET THE BILL
OF THE SORT OF. YOU KNOW MUSCLE
THEIR WAY THROUGH. AND SO IT
ENDS UP BEING. THE CREW BUT THE
SMALLER INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS
HAVE JUMPED THROUGH. OP NOTE
THAT. DAMAGE TO THEIR BRAND.
AND QUESTIONABLE PRACTICES WITH
THEIR FOOD. I GUESS THE FLIP
SIDE OF THAT MIGHT. IT WOULD
BE. MORE LIKELY TO- AGREED TO
HAVE THEIR- INFORMATION ON
ESTABLISHED PLATFORM SO THAT
COULD LEAD TO HIGHER BARRIERS
TO ENTRY IN THE DELIVERY MARKET
DO YOU SEE THAT AS A PROBLEM.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT MISTER
KELLY I'M NOT TOTALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE QUESTION.
WELL I MEAN IF THIS PASSES AND
YOU HAVE TO GET EXPRESS
PERMISSION THEN IT SEEMS LIKELY
THAT RESTAURANTS WILL BE MORE
LIKELY TO GRANTED TECH
COMPANIES WE'VE ALL HEARD OF
LIKE A GROUNDHOG OR WHAT HAVE
YOU- SO THAT COULD BE A BARRIER
TO ENTRY FOR LESS ESTABLISH
DELIVERY COMPANIES WHO AREN'T
ABLE TO. I HAVE A WIDER
SELECTION AVAILABLE. I WOULD
ARGUE JUST THE OPPOSITE
ACTUALLY I'M SORRY- I WOULD ASK
YOU TO IT'S JUST THE OPPOSITE
THIS WILL. ACTUALLY ALLOW THE
MARKET TO WORK ACCORDINGLY
BECAUSE- THE BIG CARRIERS ARE
TAKING A LARGE PERCENTAGE. OF
THE OVERALL BILL FROM THESE
RESTAURANTS WHERE A SMALLER NEW
START UP COMPANY COULD COME IN
AND OFFER FAR LASSEN BECAUSE
IT'S A WRITTEN CONTRACT AND
THAT'S WELL ESTABLISHED BEFORE
HAND. IT PROVIDES OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE MARKET TO WORK. SO THAT
THAT'S IN CASES WHERE THERE
ACTUALLY AGREEING TO PAY THE
RESTAURANT RIGHT SO THERE IS BY
DEFINITION RT PERMISSIONS FROM
GRANT. WELL THAT THAT WHAT
HAPPENS IS RESTAURANTS GET PUT
IN POSITION SPECIALLY SMALL
RESTAURANTS OF STARTING OUT BE
LISTED WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT.
AND THEN THEIR CUSTOMERS BEING
RELIANT ON THESE- DELIVERY
PLATFORMS WITH EIGHTY AT IT AND
THEN THE DELIVERY PLATFORM
COMES TO THE RESTAURANT. IN
ALMOST NOT COURSE THE FASHION-
REQUIRES THE RESTAURANT TO BUY
IN. TO THEIR PERCENTAGE BEING
TAKEN OR TO TAKE THEIR
CUSTOMERS ELSEWHERE THIS IS
WHERE- UNFORTUNATELY KIND OF
THIS BIG BUSINESS HAS IT HAS
CORRUPTED ON THE ABILITY OF
SMALL RESTAURANTS TO HAVE THE
DECISION. SO IT STARTS OFF AS-
AT WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT AND
THEN THE- COMPANY I DON'T WANNA
NAY MANY OF THEM COME IN. AND
SAY YOU NEEDS NOW AGREE TO THIS
PERCENTAGE TO SIGNING UP FOR US
AND THIS IS A PERCENTAGE WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE. WE LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD BY SAYING THAT'S
UP FRONT IN THE BEGINNING DO
YOU WANT TO SIGN ON IT NOT IT
ALSO ALLOWS SMALL START UP
COMPANIES TO SAY WE'RE OFFERING
LESS IT ALSO ALLOWS THE
RESTAURANT TO MAKE AN EDUCATED
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER IT'S
CHEAPER. OR MAKES MORE SENSE
FOR THEIR OWN EMPLOYEES TO BE
DELIVERING- THAT FOOD AT SOME
RESTAURANT STILL STILL HAVE
BEEN IN THIS- AT PANDEMIC
ENVIRONMENT WHERE. A LOT OF
RESTAURANTS HAVE CHOSEN TO DO
THAT GOES INTO NOT. TO SIMPLY
ALLOW TAKE OUT RATHER THAN
DELIVERY AS A AS A WAY TO-
INSURE THAT THERE'S SOME SORT
OF QUALITY CONTROL. AND THAT
WAS OUR SENATOR DID U. S. C. IS
THERE AN ABILITY I JUST TO SAY
WE- DON'T WANT THESE DELIVERY
COMPANIES TO COME IN AND PICK
UP FOOD FROM A RESTAURANT APART
FROM WHETHER OR NOT THEIR
INFORMATION IS LISTED ON THE
PLATFORMS. YOUR MISTER KELLY I
THINK ANY RESTAURANT COULD DENY
SERVICE THAN IN ANY CONTACT-
THE ISSUE HERE IS. THAT YOU
KNOW THESE ORDERS THEY THEY
COME IN A- NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS. AND ALL MISS GONZALEZ IS
ASKING FOR. WHICH WE
APPRECIATE. IT SOME LEVEL OF
CONSENT FROM THE RESTAURANT. SO
THAT THE IMPLIED RELATIONSHIP
TO THE PUBLIC. IS TRUE OR- IN
MANY CASES WHICH MAKES THE
PRICE PEOPLE THERE ARE A LOT OF
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANT THAT
ACTUALLY DO NOT. WANT HARD TO
DELIVER IT THEIR PRODUCT MAY
NOT LEND ITSELF WELL TO TRAVEL
OR THEY MAY NOT JUST BE ABLE TO
DO THE LOGISTICS OF IT OR THERE
MAY BE A NUMBER ABOUT THE
RECENT SO. THERE SEEMS TO BE
DRIVING A CONVERSATION TO SOME
DEGREE THE PRESUMPTION THAT
RESTAURANT ONE OF THE LIST AND
IN MANY CASES THEY DON'T AND SO
WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING. FOR SOME
FORMAL PROCESS. REALLY LOW FARE
OF CONSENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH UP ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OKAY AND GO AHEAD.
JUST A BRIEF COMMENT I JUST
WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL YOU KNOW IT'S A
SINGLE ANECDOTE BUT IT HAPPENED
TO A SMALL RESTAURANT THAT I
LOVE. SIX OR SEAT RESTAURANT
SIX TABLE RESTAURANT THEY
COULDN'T HANDLE THE CAPACITY
WHEN THIS HAPPENED TO THEM AND
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
ON AND THEY COULDN'T SERVE
THEIR CLIENTELE IN THE WAY THEY
WANTED AND THEY COULDN'T GET
OUT OF IT. AND SO I THINK THIS
IS A REAL PROBLEM THAT HER
SMALL RESTAURANT SOMEWHERE IN A
TIME WHERE WE AS A BODY NEEDS
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO GET
RESTAURANTS BACK UP AND RUNNING
IN A WAY THAT IS WORK FOR THEM
AND WORK TO CAL. CAN THANK MUCH.
A MISTER GOING AT FIRST I MEAN
THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE ESPECIALLY IN
THESE TIMES BECAUSE- IN DURING
THIS COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS
CERTAINLY RESTAURANTS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED GREATLY- BEAN. ONLY
ABLE TO DO TAKE OUT AND
DELIVERY- HAS BEEN A HUGE
IMPACT TO THEM AND THEN MORE
MORE PEOPLE ARE RELYING ON THE
SERVICES- TO GET DELIVERIES YOU
KNOW DURING THIS TIME SO. YOU
KNOW THIS IS A HELPFUL TOOL OUT
THERE THAT IS THAT IS COME UP
IN SOCIETY IN THE MARKET. OF
ALLOWING THESE. DELIVERIES AND
I THINK IT HELPS YOU KNOW AND
IT HELPS RESTAURANTS AND IT'S
HELPS THE CONSUMER. BUT I MEAN
I'VE IN LISTENING TO THE
TESTIMONY HERE. IT IS NOW IN
QUESTION- AND I THINK SOME OF
THIS CAN BE DEALT WITH IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AS YOU AS
YOU SUGGEST BECAUSE WE GET INTO
SOME LEGAL ISSUES ABOUT
COPYRIGHT LAW AND- SUCH A THOSE
CAN BE HANDLED THERE- BUT IT IS
INTERESTING TO THINK ABOUT- THE
ON THE ONE HAND I THINK YOU
MIGHT SAY. WHO WHO WHO WHO WHO
WOULD NOT WANT FREE ADVERTISING
RIGHT- THAT THERE'S A COMPANY
OUT THERE IS GOING TO PUT YOUR
BUSINESS'S NAME OUT THERE AND
NOT CHARGE YOU FOR IT. IS NOT A
GOOD THING FOR A BUSINESS. YEAH
HOWEVER. AS BEEN POINT ON ON.
THIS TESTIMONY IS SORT OF SUEDE
MY- FEELINGS ON THIS IS OKAY
WHAT IF YOU'RE NOT PREPARED FOR
THOSE ORDERS RIGHT AND YOU AND
YOU HAVEN'T HAD. THAT TIME AND
THEN. SOMEBODY SUGGESTED WELL
YOU COULD JUST SAY HEY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO DEAL WITH YOU OKAY
BUT NOW THAT CUSTOMER DOESN'T
GET. THE PRODUCT THAT THEY
THOUGHT THEY WERE GETTING AND
THEY AND THEY WERE ASSUMING
THERE WAS SOME SORT OF
RELATIONSHIP WHO DOES THAT LOOK
BAD ON. IT LOOKS BAD ON THE
RESTAURANT. IT LOOKS BAD ON
THE- DELIVERY COMPANY TO. BUT
IT LOOKS BAD ON THE RESTAURANT.
AS A THEY DIDN'T FOLLOW
THROUGH- AND SO THAT AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY NOT SOMETHING THAT
THEY ASK FOR- AND- SO I THINK
THAT IS A- AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION AND- I'LL COME IN A
LITTLE BIT ON WHAT'S NOT BEFORE
US- BUT THAT. THE AUTHOR
STARTED OUT WITH THIS OKAY WHO-
WHO WHO'S- TUMORS ARE THESE.
AND I THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION FOR US I MEAN IT'S NOT
BEFORE US YET BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT. IS I
THINK IN A LOT OF CASES IF
YOU'RE IN YOUR HOME
JURISDICTION I MEAN IF YOU'RE
IN. YOUR YOUR PLACE OF
RESIDENCE YOU ALREADY HAVE
RESTAURANTS THAT YOU LIKE. AND
YOU'RE ALREADY A CUSTOMER OF
THAT RESTAURANT YOU MY ORDERS
TO THESE- THROUGH THESE
DELIVERIES TO GET THAT BUT TO
ME THAT FEELS A LOT MORE LIKE
YOU'RE ALREADY THEIR CUSTOMER-
AND SO IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT
BELONGS TO THE RESTAURANT-
WHERE IT STARTS MOVING OUTWARD
IS MAYBE. YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. IT WILL
THEN. DELIVERY COMPANIES GIVING
YOU A LOT OF CHOICES THAT YOU
CAN CHOOSE FROM MAYBE THE START
TO BECOME MORE OF THEIR
CUSTOMER AND IS THAT THEIR DATA
AS OPPOSED TO THE RESTAURANTS-
WHEN YOU GO WHEN YOU GO VISIT A
LOCATION WHEN I GO DOWN TO SAN
DIEGO. MAY FOR EXAMPLE AND I'M
LIKE HEY WHERE'S A GOOD
RESTAURANT I MIGHT USE ONE OF
THESE APPS. TWO HEY RECOMMENDED
ME A GOOD A GOOD PLACE TO GET.
SOME GOOD FOOD RIGHT. THEN IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S MORE LIKE HEY
THIS IS A SERVICE THEY ARE
PROVIDING A MUSEUM MORE THERE
SO IT IS. NO THERE IS SOME
INTERESTING QUESTIONS THAT WE
GOT TO DELVE INTO. AND AGAIN
THIS IS A USEFUL TOOL WE DON'T
WANT TO. UNDULY BURDEN IT. BUT
YOU KNOW IT WOULD SEEM THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE AT LEAST SOME
KIND OF. RELATIONSHIP
ABOLISHED. BETWEEN THE
RESTAURANT AND THE SERVICE
AHEAD OF TIME AND I THINK
THAT'S- I THINK THAT'S WHERE
THIS BILL IS HEADING SO. AND I
THINK WE NEED A WE DO ARE THERE
ARE LEGAL ISSUES ARE GOING
AFTER ADDRESS BUT I THINK THOSE
COULD BE ADDRESSED IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IF THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND HER TEAM FOR. THE
WORK THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS
BILL. AS WELL AS- THE AGREEMENT
TO REMOVE THE TOP PORTION OF
THE BILL. THAT DEALT WITH
PRIVACY WHICH PRESENTS SOME
PROBLEMS OF FOR THE COMMUNITY.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT AND- AND ALSO WANT
TO THANK ALL THE WHEN IT. IS
WHO TESTIFIED EARLIER. AND AS
WE KNOW AND WE HEARD EARLIER.
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY HAS REALLY
SUFFERED. A THE MOST IN A- SALE.
JOB LOSS IS A- YOU KNOW SINCE
THE I. SO ALL AT THE SAME. THE
USE OF THESE. DELIVERY
PLATFORMS HAVE SEEN. A DRAMATIC
INCREASE. AS PEOPLE CALTRAIN
PLACE OKAY. I'D REALLY HOPES TO
ENSURE THAT AN EQUITABLE AND
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
RELATIONSHIP. BETWEEN
RESTAURANTS AND DELIVERY
PLATFORMS. WHICH REALLY SEEN
CRITICAL FOR THE RECOVERY OF
THE- FOOD SERVICE INDUSTRY.
GOING TO PANDEMIC SO- WITH THE
AMENDMENT- THAT YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED TODAY HI WILL BE
SUPPORTED THE BILL. AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU. I WILL I JUST WANT
TO TOUCH BASE WITH. BUT YOU'RE
GALLAGHER SAID. IN A- THOUGHT
BUT I'VE BEEN. LOOKING AT THE
CENTER TIME THAT QUESTION OF
WHO IS THE CUSTOM IN WHO. WHO
SHOULD THAT THE CUSTOMER HAVE
THAT RELATIONSHIP WITH AND IT'S
COMPLICATED. AND I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS CRISIS IS GOING TO
MAKE IT LESS COMPLICATED.
BECAUSE I KEEP THINKING ABOUT-
THE SMALL RESTAURANTS THAT ARE
GOING TO SLOWLY COME OPEN UP
RIGHT MAYBE ONE OR TWO- SEATS
AVAILABLE THERE. TO WANT TO
BRING PEOPLE AND SO THAT THEY
CAN HIRE WAIT STAFF SO THEY CAN
HIRE BACK THEIR STOCK. THEY
COMMUNICATE WITH THE PEOPLE AT
HOME THAT HAVE BEEN ORDERING
THROUGH- AN APT. IF THEY'RE NO
LONGER IN COMMUNICATION WITH
THEIR OWN CUSTOMERS YOU KNOW-
IT IT'S A BERRIER ALMOST TWO.
OPENING FOR A LOT OF SO. STRONG
EARLY WE MAY OR MAY NOT GET TO
A RESOLUTION DOES ISSUES
BECAUSE OF THE PRIVACY CONCERNS
IT'S SOMETHING I'D LIKE TO GET
TO BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME
TIME. THAT'S WHY I'VE OFFERED-
TO PULL THAT PIECE OUT- TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL AS-
COMMITTEE STAFF IF IT IF IT
MOVES FORWARD- INTO THE SENATE.
AND THE WORK ON THE JUDICIARY
PEACE BUT I THINK THIS IS
SIMPLE AS WRITTEN AND THIS BILL
JUST SAYS THERE SHOULD BE A
CLEAR RELATIONSHIP- AS I THINK
ALL CONSUMERS BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS- AS- RESTAURANTS ARE
ASKING FOR- AND- IT'S NOT TOO
MUCH OF A BARRIER TO ASK. THESE
COMPANIES TO CREATE. I RELATE
WITH THESE WERE. BEFORE AVERAGE.
CAN BUY THEIR FOR OR OR CHIU
FROM THERE MAY WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUT. OF WHY I
THIS BILL IS GOING TO. OR IS
SET UP IT IS. HE SAID THE BILL
HAS BEEN AND SO DOWN MAN
SECRETARY WOULD YOU CALL WILL
FORM. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE IS FLOOR CHAO HI. KILEY
BAUER-KAHAN. BERMAN ON MEDINA I
CORREO. MULLIN GALLAGHER- WENT
ON. OBERNOLTE WICKS RIGHT. YOU
HAVEEIGHT VOTES- IT PASSES-
LITERAL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I
THINK DOCTOR WEBER IS SO
SUPPOSED TO BE NEXT LET'S WAIT
A COUPLE MINUTES TO SEE. IF SHE
IS GOING TO JOIN US SHORTLY.
I'M TOLD THAT SHE'S STILL IN
COMMITTEE ON- ONE OF THE BILLS.
INTO HERS. SO I THINK I A WILL
PROP- I THINK THAT'S A- THAT'S
A PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE- BILL A
CA FIVE. I WILL I WILL EXERCISE
MY PREROGATIVE SO IS THE CHAIR
TO GO TO MEMBERS IN THE
COMMITTEE AND I BELIEVE- MISTER
BERMAN THIS NEXT TO HE HAS A
BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT ELEVEN.
AND LET ME REITERATE FOR THOSE
WISHING TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION BY PHONE
I DO ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO
CALL AND NOW. AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
TESTIMONY JUST TO AVOID ANY
DELAYS THE PHONE NUMBER AGAIN
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. SO
WITH THAT YEAH WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ANYTIME YOU'RE READY
POLICE BEGAN THANK YOU MISTER
SUN COLLEAGUES LET ME BEGIN BY
SAYING I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS DEEMED DETAILED
OPENPAGES NINE AND IN THE
ANALYSIS. AB ELEVEN WOULD
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
AUTOMATIC RENEWAL LAW. BY
ENSURING THAT CONSUMERS CAN
SUBSCRIBE FOR GOODS AND
SERVICES ONLINE. THEY CAN
CANCEL ONLINE AND THAT CAN DO
SO WITHOUT DELAY OR HAVING TO
JUMP THROUGH HOOPS. IN ADDITION.
AB TWENTY IT'LL WOULD REQUIRE
BUSINESSES TO NOTIFY CONSUMERS
BEFORE A FREE GIFT TRIAL OR
PROMOTIONAL OR DISCOUNTED RATE
EXPIRES. IN RESPONSE TO THE
ECONOMIC RECESSION TRIGGERED BY
COVERED NINETEEN MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES ARE
SEARCHING FOR WAYS TO SAVE
MONEY SO THAT THEY CAN BUY FOOD
AND PAY RENT. ONE OF THE FIRST
IS THEY WILL TURN IT IS TO
CANCEL SUBSCRIPTION
SUBSCRIPTIONS FOR GOODS AND
SERVICES THAT THEY REALLY ARE
YOU NEVER USE. UNFORTUNATELY
MANY BUSINESSES USE A VARIETY
OF TACTICS TO MAKE CANCELLING
SUBSCRIPTIONS INCONVENIENT
CONFUSING AND TIME CONSUMING.
OR OTHERWISE DIFFICULT. JUST
RECENTLY A MEMBER OF MY STAFF
TRIED TO CANCEL HER NEW YORK
TIMES SUBSCRIPTION ONLINE WHICH
YOU SUBSCRIBE TO ONLINE AND THE
ONLY ONLINE CANCELLATION OFFICE
AND WHAT'S THE CHAT ONLINE WITH
A CUSTOMER REPRESENTATIVE.
HOWEVER NO REPRESENTATIVES WERE
AVAILABLE AT THAT TIME WHICH
WAS DURING NORMAL BUSINESS
HOURS. THEREFORE HER ONLY
OPTION FOR CANCER THE CALL OR
TEXT A CUSTOMER REPRESENTATIVE.
THIS EXPERIENCE IN OTHERS
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA LAW TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS AT A TIME
WHEN THE MORE AND MORE CAN NO
LONGER CAN AFFORD. THESE
SERVICES. DURING THE COUNTING
IT IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT THAT
CONSUMERS CAN EASILY CANCEL
SUBSCRIPTIONS THAT THEY MAY NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO AFFORD. IT IS
ALSO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
CONSUMERS HAVE THESE
PROTECTIONS GIVEN THE RECENT
EXPLOSION OF FREE TRIALS AND
PROMOTIONAL OFFERS BEING
OFFERED IN THE RESPONSE THE
COVERT NINETEEN. WITH ME TODAY
BY PHONE I HOPE THEY WERE
READY- ARE MET BALL FROM THE
HEAD OF CONSUMER PROTECTION IN
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. AND DANNY
CANDLE KAISER. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
BROUGH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
LET'S CENTER ALL OF OUR FIRST
WITNESS OUT. ARE YOU ONLINE.
THERE ARE SEVERAL OF YOU. AND
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
MAKE A COMMENT AND SUPPORT AT
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. LET'S GO TO
THE OTHER LET'S GO TO OUR MAIN
WITNESSES FIRST BEFORE WE GO TO
THE NEED TO- SUPPORTERS. SOBRE
MENTAL TRAUMA. MISTER BELL
TRIAL HI YOU ONLINE. HOW ABOUT
THE ANY CANDLE KAISER. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I
WILL GO FIRST. MY NAME AGAIN IS
DANIELLE CNADA CRIED THERE I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION. AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
REPORT AB TWENTY EIGHT ELEVEN
CLICK A STATEWIDE COALITION OF
LEGALLY PROVIDERS THAT STRIVE
TO ENSURE THAT ALL PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME OR
BACKGROUND OPPORTUNITIES UNDER
THE LAW. TO ACHIEVE THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL WE THINK TO ENSURE
THE ALL CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD AND
THEIR NEEDS RECOGNIZED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE YOU BRINGING
MEAL TO DIET DATE YOUR FITNESS
APPS MORE MY CONSUMER ARE SINCE
TO PRODUCT THE SERVICES ONLINE.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN IS
STATED IN RESPONSE TO THE ACT.
IN OF CO THAT NINETEEN MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE SEARCHING FOR
WAYS TO SAVE MONEY NOW. VERY
CHALLENGING HARD TO SPECIALLY
IMPORTANT BUT CONSUMERS HAVE A
CLEAR PATHWAY TO DISCONTINUING
SERVICES THAT THEY AND THEIR
FAMILIES NO LONGER NEED OR
CAN'T AFFORD. AND THE COALITION
THAT SERVES THE LEGAL AID NEEDS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
EVERY YEAR CLICK IS KEENLY
AWARE OF THE CURRENT RECESSION
THAT THE TAPE CONSUMER
PROTECTION. THAT PREVENT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS. I'M
FALLING FURTHER INTO DEBT AND
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. WE SUPPORT
THE AIM OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
ELEVEN. TO BOLSTER CONSUMER
PROTECTION BY ALLOWING
CONSUMERS TO CANCEL THE PRODUCT
WITH THE WITH OF ONLINE.
QUICKLY AND IN A MANNERTHAT
DOES NOT REQUIRE THE CONSUMER
TO MAKE PHONE CALLS THREE GAUGE
WITH ADDITIONAL THEY'LL PERSON.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUING SUPPORT ONLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE THE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IS MR MAT BELTRAN ALL.
BELTRAN MOLD ON THE LINE PLEASE.
I BELIEVE HE WAS CALLING IN BUT
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S GONE
THROUGH YET. ALL RIGHT IF YOU
ARE ON THE LINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ROLE AT
THIS TIME. WHEN WE COME BACK TO
HOME- LET'S GO TO ALL THE OTHER
SUPPORTERS. OF FOR THIS BILL.
AND IF YOU COULD IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. GIVE YOUR
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. AND IF THERE
IS ANYONE WHO WANTS TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN ORDER THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST
COMMENT AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM REBECCA HAMMER. MY THIRD
PLACE CLINTON. I ACTUALLY DO
NOT HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT
STUFF THANK YOU THE. ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE AT THE- ONE
MOMENT AND WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
FROM DANIELLE GOT TERRACE
PLEASE CLAYTON. JANUARY. CHAIR
OF THE BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE ONE MOMENT FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE A MOMENT IN SUPPORT AND
STEPHANIE MATTHEW PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KIDDING MELANIE IS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND THE COURT. THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN YOU YEAH
HELLO SO I HAVE NOT FELT TRAVEL
HOW THINGS MATT. WELCOME MISTER
BUSH TRUMP PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M-
HOW DOES FOR THE CONFUSION GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MATTHEW
BELTRAME A COMMON ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. I LIKE TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
EIGHT ONE ONE I SPEAK TODAY ON
BEHALF OF OUR ELECTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY. BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND I SERVED AS AN
ATTORNEY IN THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DA'S OFFICE FOR THE PAST
NINETEEN YEARS. ELEVEN OF WHICH
I'VE EXCLUSIVELY HANDLE CASES
INVOLVING A WHITE COLLAR CRIME
AND CONSUMER FRAUD MOST OF THEM
CIVIL ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION CASES
PROSECUTED BY MY OFFICE MOSTLY
INVOLVE COMPLAINT THE FALSE
ADVERTISING AND UNLAWFUL AND
FRAUDULENT BUSINESS PRACTICES.
THEY IMPLICATE COMPANIES LARGE
AND SMALL THAT YOU BUSINESS IN
OUR STATE AND THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. ON THE STATUTES THAT
FREQUENTLY ARISE IN THESE CASES
IS CALIFORNIA'S AUTOMATIC
RENEWAL LAW BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE SECTION
SEVENTEEN SIX OH TWO. AS YOU
KNOW THIS WAS AND REMAINS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION LEGISLATION.
ALTHOUGH AUTOMATIC RENEWAL
CONTRACT CAN BE A SOURCE OF
CONVENIENT FOR CUSTOMERS AND
BUSINESSES. THEY ARE ALSO IN MY
EXPERIENCE TRAPS FOR THE UNWARY
SOMETIMES RESULTING IN
CONSUMERS INCURRING MONTHS AND
YEARS OF ON NOTICED CREDIT CARD
CHARGES. THIS IS A PARTICULARLY
WORRISOME PROBLEM NOW IN THE
ERA OF CORONAVIRUS AND SHELTER
IN PLACE ORDERS. WERE MILLION
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS AND CAN
ILL AFFORD TO PAY FOR THINGS
THEY DON'T USE OR WANT. THE LAW
CURRENTLY REQUIRES COMPANIES
THAT WISH TO ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT WITH CONSUMERS TO MAKE
DISCLOSURES ENTERTAINED
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT. I HAVE
PERSONALLY HANDLE THE NUMBER OF
CIVIL CASES IN WHICH COMPANIES
WERE ALLEGEDTO HAVE VIOLATED
THE AUTOMATIC RENEWAL LAW
INCLUDING ACTIONS AGAINST LARGE
COMPANIES SUCH AS SKYPE AND
DROPBOX AN ACTIVITY BANDAGE. IN
MY DISTRICT ATTORNEY COLLEAGUES
AROUND THE STATE HAVE BROUGHT
ACTIONS AGAINST OTHER WELL
KNOWN COMPANIES SUCH AS THE
HARMONY AND STAMPS DOT COM TO
NAME. JUST A COUPLE. ALL OF
THESE CASES I JUST MENTION
RESULTED IN STIPULATED
JUDGMENT. WHICH REQUIRED THE
COMPANY IN QUESTION TO MAKE
CHANGES TO THEIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES. THROUGHOUT THE FALL
THE LETTER AND THE SPIRIT OF
THE AUTOMATIC RENEWAL LAW. EACH
CASE ALSO RESULTED IN FILL
PENALTIES AND POTENTIAL
CONSUMER RESTITUTION. THE
AUTOMATIC RENEWAL LAW HAS BEEN
A REAL ASSET THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. IT APPEARED TO ME
THAT OVER TIME. APPELLEE
COUNCIL BUSINESSES HAVE COME TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOLLOWING IT. THE AUTOMATIC
RENEWAL ARE CURRENTLY WRITTEN
HOWEVER IS NOT PERFECT. THERE
ARE SOME HOLD THAT REMAIN. FOR
EXAMPLE NOTHING IN THE CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES COMPANIES TO
NOTIFY CONSUMERS WHEN THEY'RE
ABOUT TO BE CHARGED EITHER AT
THE END OF A FREE TRIAL PERIOD
OR AT THE TIME OF RENEWAL. IN
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CONSUMER
TRANSACTIONS THESE DAYS ARE
COMPLETED ONLINE AND VIA EMAIL
COMMUNICATIONS. SUCH
NOTIFICATIONS WOULD BE
INEXPENSIVE AND EASY TO
ADMINISTER. ALSO ALTHOUGH THE
STATUTE IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
REQUIRES A COMPANY THAT OFFERS
AN AUTOMATIC RENEWAL CONTRACT
ONLINE. ALSO TO ALLOW
CANCELLATION ONLINE NOTHING
PREVENT THE COMPANY FOR MAKING
CANCELLATION TRICKY DIFFICULT
OR TIME CONSUMING. THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SUPPORT AB TWO EIGHT
ONE ONE BECAUSE IT STRENGTHENS
THIS IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAW BY HELPING TO
PLUG THE HOLES. FIRST IT
REQUIRES THAT A BUSINESS
NOTIFIED CUSTOMERS AT THE
CONCLUSION OF A FREE CREEK GIFT
OR FREE TRIAL PERIOD. BEFORE
HIS OR HER CREDIT CARD IS
CHARGED THE FULL AMOUNT TO LET
THEM KNOW HOW TO CANCEL. GIVING
KERN CONSUMERS SUCH NOTICE WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT THEY KNOW WHEN
AND HOW MUCH THEY WILL BE
CHARGED AS WELL TO PAINT A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
CANCELLATION PROCESS. PROCESS
SECOND THE BILL MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT CONSUMERS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO CANCEL AUTOMATIC RENEWAL
CONTRACT THAT WILL. WITHOUT
HAVING TO ENGAGE IN STEPS THAT
WILL IMPAIR OR RESTRICT THEIR
ABILITY TO DO SO. THIS IS NOT
MERELY AN ACADEMIC EXERCISE. IN
OUR INVESTIGATION. WE HAVE SEEN
MANY EXAMPLES OF BUSINESSES
FORCING CONSUMERS TO JUMP
THROUGH HOOPS. I MAKING THEM
COMPLETE SEVERAL ON NECESSARY
STEPS IN ORDER TO CANCEL THE
AUTOMATIC RENEWAL SERVICE.
THESE INCLUDE FORCING THEM TO
ENGAGE IN ONLINE CHAT WITH
CUSTOMER SERVICE REPS MAY TENTH
TO DISSUADE THEM FROM CANCELING.
HIDING A CANCELLATION HYPERLINK
IN A WEB PAGE THAT IS DIFFICULT
TO FIND ARE NOT INTUITIVE.
REQUIRING CONSUMERS TO TAKE A
SURVEY OR OTHERWISE PROVIDE A
REASON FOR CANCELLATION.
OFFERING NARROW WINDOWS OF TIME
IN WHICH CANCELLATION AS
POSSIBLE. AND REQUIRING TUMORS
TO GO TO MULTIPLE STEPS. TO
PROCESS THE CANCELLATION MY
COLLEAGUES REPORT HAVING SEEN
CASES THAT INVOLVE AS MANY AS
THIRTEEN SEPARATE STEPPED
INCLUDING MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS TO
PERSUADE THE CONSUMER TO REMAIN
WITH THE SERVER. THIS BILL WILL
RENDER THESE PRACTICES UNLAWFUL.
ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I LIKE TO
KNOW IF ANYONE ELSE'S SO ON THE
LINE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. IF
THERE IS ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
MAKE A COMMENT OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO TOM KEPT PARTY TO ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NOBODY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE- IS CORNY
JENSEN FROM TECHCONNECT IS ON
THE LINE AS WELL AS SHARP
MUHAMMAD FROM CAL CHAMBER. HI
YOU ON THE LINE. DIRECTOR CARY
ACT THAT THE COURT IN JENSEN
LIKE TECH THAT AND TAKE THAT IS
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY EIGHT ELEVEN AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN AND BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORED THAT
CAN INTENT OF THE BILL- BUT YOU
WORRY ABOUT THE WORKABILITY OF
MANY OF THE PROVISIONS. AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PACKED THAT
WORKED WITH SENATOR HERTZBERG
ON HIS AT THE THREE THIRTEEN
WHICH WENT INTO EFFECT JULY
FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN
TWO YEARS AGO- AND TECHNET
EVENTUALLY TOOK A NEUTRAL
POSITION ON THAT LANGUAGE
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT WOULD NOT
COVER BURDEN BUSINESS SAYS AND
WHAT ENSURE CONSUMERS WERE IN
POWER TO CANCEL SERVICES
EASILY. AB TWENTY EIGHT ELEVEN
WOULD BALAMAND THAT LANGUAGE
AND I'LL QUICKLY COVER TO
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE FIRST THE
BILL REQUIRES IMMEDIATE
CANCELLATION WE WANT TO ENSURE
IT WOULD NOT ALLOW CONSUMERS TO
BE ABLE TO BE USED FREE TRIAL
OR SUBSCRIPTION AGREEMENT THAT
ALLOW THEM TO TAKE ADVANTAGE.
ALL RIGHT. BUT HAVE A RIGHT
CANCEL. ALLOWING A CAN TO CAN'T
NUMBER OF THE TERM TO CREATE
GET CONCERNS FOR BUSINESS AND
WE THAT THE MORE PER. CLAIRE
THAT THE TAKE A FACT THAT THE
END OF THE BILLING CYCLE SECOND
THE BILL REQUIRED THE BUSINESS
TO ALLOW CONSUMER KIDS
TERMINATE AT WILL AND I FOUND
AGING AND ANY FURTHER THAT AS
THE LANGUAGE STAND CURRENTLY IT
IS UNCLEAR IF THE BUSINESS TO
BE ABLE TO REQUIRE A PMR TO
AUTHENTICATE THEMSELVES FOR
ALLOWING A CANCELLATION IT IS
OFTEN DIFFICULT IN THE MIND
CONTACT FOR BUSINESSES CAN
VERIFY THAT A PERSON IS INDEED
AUTHOR TO CANCEL THE
SUBSCRIPTION. AND SOMETIMES
BUSINESSES TO ASK NUMBER TO
FIND INTERNET OR VERIFIED BY
ANOTHER METHOD TO RESOLVE THE
CANCELLATION OUR CLASS.
ALTHOUGH THIS PLANE WOULD LIMIT
THE OF THE OF A COMPANY TO
ENGAGE DIRECT WTH THEIR
CUSTOMER. TO BE GIVEN IN OUR-
TO RESOLVE ISSUE OR DRAFT THE
CUSTOMERS NEED. OFTEN CONSUMERS
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS TYPE
OF DIALOGUE WITH THE BUSINESS
NEGOTIATE A BETTER PRICE OR
DIRECT THE STAR MAY HAVE WITH
THE SERVICE. NOT ALLOWING THE
ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN ANY
FURTHER STAT WE BELIEVE THIS
WOULD HAMSTRING BOTH BUSINESSES
AND CONSUMERS- AND WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE OFF
THEIR ON THESE ISSUES AND HELP
THE WILL BE ABLE TO DROP
PARKING CAN'T. CONCERNING
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF IT IS MISTER MOHAMMED
ON THE LINE. BUT I AM. ONE
MOMENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- WE ARE
ALSO RESPECTFULLY- OPPOSED TO
AB TWENTY ELEVEN OF COURSE WE
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
AND WE SUPPORT- THE AUTHOR'S
INTENTION TO PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY EMPOWER
CONSERVATORY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING AT THE
AUTHOR ON THESE ISSUES BUT IT
TURNS OUT THERE ARE SOME ISSUES
WITH THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL-
THAT WE BELIEVE COULD BENEFIT
FROM CLERK AGENT SO I WANTED TO
ADDRESS YOU. ISSUES WITH ALL
OUR FIRST I WANTED TO ADDRESS
THIS REQUIREMENT THE BILL
REQUIRES BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE
CONSUMERS WITH A NOTICE
EXPLAINING HOW TO CANCEL AN
AUTOMATIC RENEWAL OFFER
CONTINUOUS AUTHOR BUT THE
REQUIRED. NOTICE MUST BE
PROVIDED TO THE AT THE THREE
DAY THAT ABOUT SEVEN DAYS PRIOR
TO THE EXPIRATION OF THE ALL
WORK BUT IF INDIVIDUATION RUN
OFFERS LESS THAN THREE DAYS
LONG OF NOT REALLY BE POSSIBLE
TO OPERATE READING NOT AS AN
ADDITION TO THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL. MANY BILL. OFFICE BY ME.
SO THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
DOES. MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR.
AFTER SUBSCRIPTIONS BY MAIL TO
GO THOSE NOTICE. OUT AND HOW.
ME THOSE TIME DEADLINE AS-
GIVEN THE MAIL SYSTEM UNDER THE
CURRENT. AND UP INTO. GIVEN THE
KERN ECONOMIC SITUATION THE
COST OF OPERATION. IN THE- NO
WITHIN BURDEN FOR THE FIRST
BECAUSE REQUIRED THEM TO
CONNECT WE- AND PERSONNEL
TOWARDS ME. CHANGE TAKING. CALL
THANK. AND THOSE CONCERNS THINK
THAT THEY STILL IS. THAT NEW TO
BE. ADDRESSED AND THE LIGHT
THAT. WILL BE ON OUT OF MY
CHECKING POINT IS THAT. LINK
BUT REQUIREMENTS. THE LANGUAGE
WILL ALSO REQUIRE THERE TO BE A
DIRECT LINK BODY. TO CANCEL OUR
SUBSCRIPTION THEIR SERVICES
ONLINE NOW THE ISSUE HERE IS
THAT THE TECHNICAL REQUIREMENTS
TO BE A DIRECT. LINK BUTTON
RULED OUT THE POSSIBILITY FOR
ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF EMPOWERING
THE SAME. CONCEPTUAL
ALTERNATIVES ARE TECHNIQUE
DIRECT LINK ARE BOUGHT IN FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE CONCERN CHOICE
IN POWER BY. THE TALK SWITCH IN
AND OP OR BY SOME OTHER
CREATIVE INTO THE USER CAN.
THAT NOT TECH A LAY OR BY. BUT
ONE CAN ABOUT HOW THE THING AND
GOAL COULD ACHIEVED. BY VARIOUS
IMPOSSIBLE EVEN MORE. GAMES AND
THAT'S WHY BELIEVE THE LANGUAGE
HERE COULD. OP A LESS PER. BUT
ON THAT. AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE- FOLLOW THE WE DO FORWARD TO
WITH THE ON THE DISTRICT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
YES A PERSON YES CERTAINLY
ANYONE OF. PERFECT. IT'S I TRY.
OUTLINED SORRY BY THE TOO LEAN
WITNESSES AND- I APPRECIATE
MISTER BERMAN'S TIME THAT HE
HAS SPENT WITH US AND
DISCUSSING THE- BILL THANK YOU.
MUCH LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINE.
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS IN
AUTHORS ANYWAY BILL. RIGHT IF
THERE'S ANYONE THAT WANTS TO
MAKE A COMMENT OPPOSITION OF
DELTA THESE PAST ONE THAN THEIR
OWN ONE MOMENT DURING. OKAY WE
HAVE ON STEVE CARLSON.
CAROLINA'S OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD MR CARSON. MR CHAIR
MEMBERS BE CALLED HIM FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OF NATIONAL
ADVERTISERS- FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY ATTACK THAT AND
CHAMBER WE REMAIN OPPOSED I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT
AGE- FROM A BALANCE STANDPOINT
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE AT
THE IMPACT THEY CALLED IN A
PLAID BUT ON CONSUMERS BUT
COVERED HAD HAD A REMARKABLE
IMPACT ON ON COMPANIES AS WELL
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO ACHIEVE
THAT. I'M NOT HERE BALANCE HERE
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T
THINK WE'RE THERE YET ON A
TWENTY ELEVEN. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE. YEAH CATHERINE GUNTER
YOUR LINE OF. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE CATHARINE GUNTER WITH
THE ENTERTAINMENT SOFTWARE
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSING. TO TWENTY ELEVEN.
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE. OKAY
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT OKAY
RURAL ROAD MATCH DAYLAMI YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M ACTUALLY
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RUNOFF GAYLANI WOULD
NIELSEN MARK MURR ON BEHALF OF
THE INTERNATIONAL HEALTH
RACQUET SPORTS CLUB ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND
PRINT. THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
ONE MOMENT. HM YOUR REMINDED OF
ON. JIM YORK IF I HAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAN YOU WORK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION ARE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
ELEVEN RIGHT NOW FOR MANY OF
THE REASONS THAT- PREVIOUS-
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
EXPRESSED BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH MR BERMAN- OR
AND- AMENDMENTS THAT HOPEFULLY
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT. OKAY BUT HE
SAID GARCIA THE LINE IS OPEN.
HI LOOKING HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
OFTEN OPPOSITION CLEAR WHEN YOU
DON'T. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
NEXT PLEASE. TALIBAN. TO GET
GIVE OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. IN HERE THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE COULD HAVE. LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISTER
OBERNOLTE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- MISTER
BERMAN THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE I THINK YOU'RE RAISING A
NORMALLY I AM VERY SKEPTICAL OF
LEGISLATION THAT IT ATTEMPTS TO
INSERT ITSELF INTO THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A BUYER
AND A SELLER BUT I THINK THAT.
GOVERNMENT HAS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE TO FILL IN ENSURING THAT
FREE MARKETS FUNCTION AND EXIST
AND IN THIS CASE I THINK THAT
THE DEFINITION OF A FREE MARKET
IS YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
WILLING BUYER AND A WILLING
SELLER AND IF THE BUYER IS NOT
WILLING TO PAY THE PRICE OF THE
THAT RENEWAL SUBSCRIPTION
BECAUSE THEY ARE ON AWARE OF
IT. YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
THAT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED SO I MEAN
I SEE WE HAVE A OPPOSE
RECOMMENDATION ON MY ANALYSIS
HERE BUT I REALLY THINK THAT
YOU'RE RAISING AN ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH. BOB I
DO HOWEVER THINK THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS RAISED SOME GOOD
POINTS AND IN PARTICULAR IF
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS-
I THINK THAT THE POINT ABOUT-
VERY SHORT DESCRIPTIONS IT IS A
GOOD ONE IF YOU HAVE A ONE DAY
SUBSCRIPTION AND THERE'S THIS
IS DESCRIBE EITHER ONE AT A
TIME. I'LL BE DAY NOT IS NOT A
TO HAVE THAT. ARE I THINK THE A
GOOD CASE WAS MY RAISED ABOUT A
SOME REASONABLE REQUIRE
ESTABLISHED AND IT'S AN SUMER
THAT'S SUBSCRIPTION SO YOU KNOW
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL I WAS
A LAST MINUTE AMEND. BUT I
THINK IT NEEDS SOME TO AND TURN
OF THE RE STAFF THAT THE- BLAUT
CAKE YEAH. PROVIDE. THOSE I
HAD. TO CANCEL OF THE SERVICE.
ALSO TO THE CONCERNED JUST
HEARD ABOUT. ABOUT ALTERNATE
METHOD OF CANCELLATION FIRST IF
YOU DON'T HAVE AN ELECT.
RELATION WITH A CO. THAT'S
REALLY NOT ADDRESS THE BILL I
THINK THAT THOSE THINGS ARE-
ARE THINGS THAT REALLY NEED TO
BE. A FINISH UP AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD SO ARE THOSE
THINGS THAT THAT YOU WERE
PLANNING TO WORK ON WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS YES ABSOLUTELY.
THE COMMENTS IN THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED IN A REYES BY
THE OPPOSITION WITH EIGHT SAT
LAST FRIDAY- WITH I THINK
EVERYBODY WHO WHO WAITED IN. IN
OPPOSITION TODAY AND- TOTALLY
AGREE WITH SOME OF THEIR POINT.
AND ITS C. CONCERNED WITH SOME
OTHER POINTS- ON THINGS LIKE.
MORE ACNE TROLL OPTION FOR
CANCELING. OPEN THAT AS ONE
MAKE SURE THAT THE SOLUTION
ISN'T. DOESN'T HAVE LOOPHOLES
THAT ARE SO BIG YOU CAN DRIVE A
TRUCK THROUGH- IT HAS BEEN
DELICATELY BUT- ABSOLUTELY OPEN
TO HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND- KIND OF. STRIKE A BETTER
BALANCE OKAY WILL. BE WITH A
COMMITMENT I THINK I CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE. A IS THE BILL OVER
HERE AND THE. AFTER POLLUTION
ON THOSE WITH THE PARTICULARS
PROJECT THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF MEDINA GO AT
THE- THANK THE- FOR I THINK A
VERY. SENSE BILL I. THINK THAT
MANY TIMES SENIORS ESPECIALLY.
ARE OPEN TO. NOT REALIZING THAT
WHAT THEY HAVE- COMMITTED TO.
AND THEN AS I THINK ONE OF
YOUR- SPONSORS OF THE BILL
SAID- YEAR AFTER YEAR. PAYING
FOR SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
REALLY NOT USING AND NOT BEING
AWARE THAT THEIR PAIN THAT ON
THEIR- ON THEIR CREDIT CARD. SO
THANK YOU MUCH FOR BRING THIS
BILL FOR BRIDGES AT. THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY GO AHEAD PLEASE
HELLO MISTER BERMAN SO I YEAH I
LIKED- SENATOR HERTZBERG'S BILL
AND I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
BILLS WHILE AND- I THINK THAT-
YOU KNOW IT IS AN ANTI
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS TO ACCESS.
AND THIS IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
HOW POLICIES THAT ARE PRO
MARKET ARE NOT ALWAYS NEARLY
EMBRACE BY- INCUMBENT
BUSINESSES AND- SO I'M MAD AT.
PRETTY CONFIDENT GOING ALONG
WITH THE TODAY MY BROAD CONCERN
IS JUST THAT IF THIS BECOMES
SORT OF A- BASIS FOR MASS
LITIGATION AND YOU HAVE-
COMPANIES OR WEBSITES THAT ARE.
NOT TECHNICALLY COMPLYING WITH
EVERY- PART OF THE BILL THEN
SUDDENLY- THERE'S ANOTHER CLASS
ACTION NINE SO THAT IT CAN YOU
GIVE ME SOME ASSURANCE THERE
THAT MAYBE THEY'LL BE SOME SAFE
HARBORS ARE TO MAKE SURE THAT
DIDN'T MISS VIOLATIONS DON'T
RESULT IN HUGE LIABILITY. I CAN
SAY THAT THAT MY INTENT IS NOT
TO CREATE LAWSUITS- TO HAVE A
CHAT WITH YOU ABOUT DIFFERENT
WAYS YOU KNOW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
TO. CREATE YES THAT THE- EITHER
SAFE HARBORS ARE OR OTHER
IDEAS- BUT THAT'S DEFINITELY
NOT MY INTENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL COMMENTS MR
GALLAGHER AT PLEASE- WHAT ABOUT
THE ISSUE BROUGHT UP BY A
POSITION OF. IF FOR ALLOWING
CANCELLATION. IN THE MIDDLE OF
A CYCLE YOUR ALLOWING THAT TO
BASICALLY THIS AND AT THE END
OF THAT CYCLE IS THAT SOME YOUR
WORKI THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
DO AGREE WITH. SO WE'RE GONNA
MAKE THAT CHANGE AND WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE THAT
CHANGE WITH THAT WAS A NINE
TEN. IN IN DRAFTING THE INITIAL
LANGUAGE AND STUFF I DON'T WANT
TO. CREATE THAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR. CUSTOMERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS SO. I WANT TO THANK-
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL IN THIS IS A
VERY- CONSUMER FRIENDLY BUILT
AND- AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR AGREEING TO WORK ON
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT'S BEEN
RAISED I THINK SOME OF THEM-
WERE RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS AS
WELL I THINK ONE OF WHICH I
JUST WANNA. ARE SINGLE OUT IS
THE AUTHENTICATION PIECE I
THINK WE IS WOULD BE IMPORTANT
OUR FOR- BOTH SIDES TO
UNDERSTAND TO VERIFY THAT. THE
PERSON. PERSON DOING
CANCELLATIONS INDYCAR PERSON SO
YEAH SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
KNOW YOUR AGREEMENT YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK. OUR AND-
SO WITH THAT HI I THINK THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED SO WOULD YOU PLEASE.
CLOSE OUR- OF ROMA CLOSE. FREE
**** ALL THE COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE DUBLIN OR WITH THE
OPPONENTS AND- YOU KNOW AGREE
WITH A LOT OF THE ISSUES OF
RACE TODAY. THANK YOU WITH
THAT- MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR ME.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR
CHILD HI. KILEY THERE ARE CAN.
BERMAN HI. MEDINA CARILLO
MULLIN GALLAGHER. IRWIN
OBERNOLTE FIVE WICKS HI YOU
BILLS OUT CONGRATULATIONS. UP I
NOTICED SAID DR WEBER IS HERE
IN THE ROOM SO LET ME INVITE
DOCTOR WEAPON TO COME PRISON
COME UP AND PRESENT HER BUILT
AND AS A REMINDER FOR THOSE
WISHING TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION BY PHONE
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO CALL IN NOW
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS TESTIMONY. I
JUST TO AVOID DELAYS THE PHONE
NUMBER AGAIN IS. 877-692-8957
AND I WANT TO WELCOME BACK TO
WEBER TO OUR COMMUNITY AND SHE
HOUSE SO AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
THREE TWO PERCENT- SO ANYTIME
YOU'RE READY DOCTOR WEBER YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PREVENT AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY. OKAY THANK
YOU STAFFERS CALL FOR HELPING
NINE MY FELLOW. BOB PUTTING
BILL TOGETHER AND WORKING IN
RECENT TO BE PATIENT WITH HIM.
AND HOPEFULLY A LOT IF YOU
COULD IN OTHER SINGLE ALL OF
THIS MAKES THIS BILL SIXTY.
YEAH. MOVE THEIR OPPOSITION BUT
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT BANKS
AND CREDIT UNIONS ARE NOT THE
TARGET OF THIS LEGISLATION.
DEBT SETTLEMENT COMPANIES ARE
TARGETED AND EVERY TIME ARGUES
TARGETED ADVERTISING TO PREYON
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLING WITH
DEBT. THEY PROMISE CONSUMERS
THAT THEY WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE DEBT BY NEGOTIATING
WITH THE CREDITORS AND STOPPING
COLLECTION ACTIVITIES. HOWEVER
INSTEAD OF NEGOTIATING WITH
CREDITORS SOME COMPANIES SIMPLY
TAKE THE MONEY WHEN THE
CONSUMERS COMPLAIN THE DEBT
SETTLEMENT COMPANY DISAPPEARS
OUR CLAIMS THAT NO MONEY IS
LEFT DUE TO THEIR FEES. BEHIND
THESE FLY BY NIGHT COMPANIES
ARE PRO RAIDERS WHO COLLECT THE
MONEY FROM CONSUMERS TO PAY
CREDITORS BUT IN MANY CASES
FIND PRETEXT TO KEEP IT. THIS
POLICY SERVES ALL CALIFORNIANS
BUT WILL HAVE THE GREATEST
IMPACT ON PROTECTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
FAMILIES OF COLORED NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING FAMILIES SENIORS AND
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS LIVING ON
A FIXED INCOME. CONSUMERS ONE
ROLE IN DEBT SETTLEMENT A
SERVICES DO NOT UNDERSTAND THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE CREDIT
REPORT. THAT THEY CAN STILL AND
IN MANY CASES BE SOON FOR AN
ENROLLED- DEBT. AND SIX AND
THAT SUCCESSFUL DEBT SETTLEMENT
SERVICES REQUIRE AN AVERAGE OF
FOUR YEARS OF PARTICIPATION
BEFORE MOST OF THE IN ROLE DEBT
WILL BE SETTLED. WITH AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
AMERICANS FACING AN EMPLOYMENT
AS A RESULT OF COAL BUT
NINETEEN. WE ANTICIPATE A LARGE
RISE IN CONSUMER DEBT-
ESPECIALLY AS MANY CALIFORNIANS
ALREADY LIVE PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK. DURING THIS TIME THE
NEED TO HAUL DECEPTION IN DEBT
SETTLEMENT IS HEIGHTENED. THE
NORTH CAROLINA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS ISSUED A
WARNING THAT UNSCRUPULOUS DEBT
SETTLEMENT COMPANIES WILL PREY
ON UNEMPLOYED AND FINANCIALLY
STRUGGLING CONSUMERS. IN FACT
EVEN GOOGLE HAS RECOGNIZED THE
HARM CAUSED BY MISLEADING AND
DECEPTIVE BUT ADVERTISEMENT.
FROM DEBT SETTLEMENT COMPANIES
AND HAS IMPLEMENTED A POLICY OF
RESTRICTING ADS FROM
UNREGULATED DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES. AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
THREE WOULD PROVIDE A PATHWAY
FOR INJURES CONSUMERS TO
RECOVER THE MONEY TAKEN FROM
THEM. BY PREDATORY ENTITIES.
THIS BILL WILL HOLD THE PAYMENT
PROCESSING COMPANIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
MISLEADING PRACTICES. BY
EXPLICITLY STIPULATING IN LAW
THAT PRO RATE IS ARE INCLUDED
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
LEGAL REMEDIES ACT. AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY FORTY THREE
SPECIFIED THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DEBT SETTLEMENT LAW DOES APPLY.
TO ATTORNEYS AND LAW FIRMS.
THIS BILL IS STRUCTURED IN A
WAY THAT REQUIRED DISCLOSURES
OF GIVEN- TO GIVE CONSUMERS
FAIR PRACTICE. FOR NOTICE ABOUT
WHETHER A DEBT SETTLEMENT PLAN
IS RIGHT IS THE RIGHT OPTION
FOR THEM. AND PROHIBIT FALSE
AND MISLEADING STATEMENTS ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF DEBT SETTLEMENT
ON A CONSUMER DEBT. UGH TO
TESTIFY TODAY WITH ME ON PHONE
IS DANIELLE CANDLE KAISER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION ONE
OF THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND
CLEAR JOHNSON ROLE HAAS FROM UC
IRVINE'S CONSUMER LAW CLINIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- LET'S NOW
TURN TO THE WITNESSES SO AS
MISSION. MS KAISER OR MISS YES
GET OUT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DANIEL COUNTER
BECAUSE YOU'RE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION WE
ARE THE FUNCTIONS AND EIGHTY
TWO FOUR FOUR THREE. AGAIN
CLICK OF A COALITION OF MORE
THAN A DOZEN LEGALLY PROVIDERS
FROM AROUND THE STATE TO
COLLECTIVELY THIRTY THOUSAND
LOW INCOME CONSUMERS EVERY YEAR
AND IT'S MEMBERS WORK TOGETHER
TO ENSURE THAT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
OF THE PROTECTION OF CALIFORNIA
LAW. WE APPLAUD DR WEBBER'S
AUTHORSHIP OF AB TWO FOUR FOUR
THREE IN THE PROTECTIONS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE CONSUMERS. WE
ALSO THANK THE BANKERS AND THE
CREDIT UNION FOR THE TIME
THEY'VE TAKEN TO WORK WITH US
ON THIS BILL LANGUAGE. A DOCTOR
WEBER HAS STATED THE GOAL OF AB
TWO FOUR FOUR THREE IS TO AMEND
THE LRA TO CLEARLY DEFINE HOW
DEBT SETTLEMENT COMPANY SHOULD
OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA. AND TO
ENSURE THE CUTS THAT CONSUMERS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BRING AN
ACTION FOR DAMAGES VIOLATIONS
LAW. REGULATING THAT SETTLEMENT
PRACTICES HAVE OCCURRED. THANK
CREATING PART ABOUT CAN BE
PROBLEMATIC ESPECIALLY IN THE
STATUTE OF COMPRISES THE FEEL
ALRIGHT. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON LANGUAGE
RELATING TO COVERAGE. ENSURING
SURE THAT DEPOSITORY
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE NOT THE
CAUSE OF THE PROBLEM OR NOT
HELD LIABLE. BUT THAT PAYMENT
PROCESSORS BUT ARE DEEPLY
ENMESHED IN THE DEBT HELLO MY
EFFORTS ARE IDENTIFIED AND MADE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
I'M DOCTOR WEBER HAS STATED
WHILE GOOGLE HAS RESTRICTED
THAT PUBLIC COMPANIES
ADVERTISING WE'RE NOW SEEING
THE ARRIVAL. OF THE CODE
NINETEEN RELATED ACADEMIC
ECONOMIC RECESSION AND AN
INCREASE IN RADIO TV AND SOCIAL
MEDIA ADVERTISEMENTS BY
UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS. HILL
STRAIGHT TALK TO WEBBER'S
POINT. A FREQUENT FALSE
STATEMENT IN THEIR EYES IS
QUOTE HEY NOTHING AND CLEARED
THAT IT STARTLED. THAT
PARLIAMENT COMPANIES DO CHARGE
UP FRONT FEES OR THE SUBTLE ONE
SMALL THAT AND THEN BEGIN TO
TAKE ALL OF THEIR FEES. THEY
OFFERED TO STOP THE DEBT
COLLECTORS FROM CALLING BUT
THAT DOES NOT MAKE CLEAR THAT
THEY ENCOURAGE THE CUSTOMER TO
STOP PAYING ALL THAT. INDIRECT
ALL COMMUNICATION FROM THE
CREDITOR TO THE DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANY. THIS BUSINESS MODEL
LEAVES THE CONSUMER THINKING
THAT IT IT IS. EVERYTHING FINE
WELL IT WRECKS THE CONSUMER'S
CREDIT. AND ARE CAUGHT BY
SURPRISE REALLY CREDIBLE FILED
A LAWSUIT TO COLLECT. INITIALLY
THE COMPANY STRONGLY DISCOURAGE
CUSTOMERS FROM SEEKING REMEDIES
SO OFTEN WORKS VERY WELL. SUCH
A DEBT CONSOLIDATION AND THE
NEGOTIATING DOWN OF THE
CONSUMERS CURRENT THAT. THEY'RE
OUT CALL THESE FORMS OF DEBT
MANAGEMENT QUOTE CUMBERSOME AND
UNDESIRABLE. IN CLOSING WITH
THE RECESSION WE NOW FACE IT IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER TO
PROVIDE CLEAR AND COMPLETE
PROTECTION TO CONSUMERS WHO ARE
TRYING TO MANAGE THEIR FINANCES.
AB TWO FOUR FOUR THREE WILL GET
CALIFORNIANS THE PROTECTIONS
THAT THEY NOW NEED I HAVE
ALWAYS TO START WE URGE YOUR
AYE THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SHALL LET'S NOW TURN TO MISS
ROSA. A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS QUITE FRANKLY ROCKED BY AND
THE CLINICAL TEACHING FELLOW IN
THE CONSUMER LAW CLINIC AT UC
IRVINE AND PROVIDING TESTIMONY
TODAY IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY TWO
FOUR THREE THREE ON BEHALF OF
CLIENTS TO THE CLINIC AND ALL
QUIRK A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIAN LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS. OR THE XIN. I TO
JOINING YEAH I LIVE A LONG
LEGAL CONSUMER RIGHT TURN. MY
CLAIMS NEED ALL OF THEIR IN TO.
THEMSELVES AMERICA. THAT
SETTLEMENT COMPANIES THAT
TARGET LOW INCOME CONSUMERS DO
NOT HELP PEOPLE GET OUT OF
THAT. INSTEAD THEY PROMISED.
THE CARD HIGH. AND LOW PEOPLE
AND WITH MISLEADING ADVERTISING
THAT PROMISES UNOBTAINABLE FIX
AND FOR PEOPLE STRUGGLING WITH
THAT. IN THIS TIME THE MORE
THAN FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ARE OUT OF WORK THE TO THE CLUB
IN NINETEEN CRISIS. CREDIT CARD
BILLS ARE PILING NOT. PEOPLE
WHO ARE STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY
FALL PREY TO DAMPEN SOLUTION
I'M TOO GOOD TO BE TRUE I
PROMISE THERE'S BEEN
SCRUPULOUS. ABOUT COMPANIES.
THE PROMISED TO STOP ALL THE
COLLECTION ACTIVITY CHEAPER
DEFAULT. THAT CREDIT CARD DEBT.
I THE CONSUMER RIGHT I WORKED
WITH CAN TO YOU TO LEGAL. I IS
HELP WITH THE DEBT BECAUSE WALK
THE- BAFFLED BECAUSE THEY WERE
IN IN THE DEATH SADDAM PLAN PAY
MY- EVERY. THAT THEY THOUGHT
WILL GO TO I DON'T THAT AND
STUFF BUT- FROM TRYING TO
COLLECT. SOME OF MY LEGAL AID
COLLEAGUES REPORT THAT MORE
THAN. OF THE- TO COLLECTION
LONG DEFENDANTS COMING IN HELP.
OUR IN BOLD IN A AT SOME. OKAY
CONSUMERS SURPRISE TO LEARN
THAT THE DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES AREN'T SPENDING MONEY
TO THEIR CREDITORS AND THEN
INSTEAD THE- CARBURETOR. I
KEEPING LARGE AMOUNTS AND FEES
FOR CONSUMERS REMAIN AT RISK OF
BEING SUED AND THE CREDIT FOR
IT. THANK BECAUSE THEIR
ENCOURAGED TO DEFAULT ON ALL
DAY THAT. I REPRESENTED A
SENIOR CITIZEN PLANT LIVING IN
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING THE PAID
OVER SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS EVERY
MONTH. ONE IN 50% OF HER
MONTHLY INCOME COULD THAT
HURDLE THAT COMPANY FOR OVER
THREE YEARS. MY CLIENT WOULD GO
TO FOOD PANTRY BECAUSE THEIR
FOOD MONEY THE COUNTY THAT THAT
PART OF MY COMPANY. AND SHE IS
NOT ALONE CONSUMERS LIVING ON A
FIXED INCOME FROM SOCIAL
SECURITY SSI OR DISABILITY. AT.
YOUR HONOR I'M AND IT. TELL ME
SOMETHING I DON'T PARTICULARLY
AGREED THAT THE QUIRK PRO IT
AND ALL THAT AND HE FEET FROM
AND CON IS PROTECTED FROM THE
CO AT. THAT COMPANIES SOCIAL
FIVE AND WISH ON THE BUS STOP
THE FLYERS ON TELEPHONE POLES
IN DIRECT MAIL. AB TWO FOR
FORTY YEARS REQUIRE DISK TO THE
FOLDER PLAN POPULAR. REGARDING
DANGERS OF THAT PART AND THAT
PEOPLE GOV BENEFITS TO PROTECT
FROM WAIT FURNISHED. IT ALSO
SEEKS TO PROTECT NOT IN THE
SPEAKING. BUY ENSURING THAT
CONTRACTOR WRITTEN IN THE
LANGUAGE OF WHICH AND GOSH IT.
EIGHTY TWO FOUR FOUR THREE ADDS
TO THE TOOL KIT FOR CONSUMER
ADVOCATES I ENSURING WE CAN
HOLD THESE COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE BUT IN A PROMISES
TO OUR CLIENTS THAT THEY CAN'T
WAIT TO PROTECT LOW INCOME
INCOME CONSUMERS WE ARGUED
ABOUT I. AB TWO FOUR FOUR
THREE. THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH
I DID IT IN ADDITION SUPPORTER
OUT SORRY WITH THE PH<c.cyan>ERE</c>
IN THE ROOM SEE NONE LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINES. ANYONE HERE
WANTS TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLUS ONE
AND ZERO. AMANDA CORP IN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GO AHEAD PLEASE
WHAT HAPPENED THANK YOU FOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW CENTER
ALSO IN COURT WITHOUT THINKING
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE. ONE
MOMENT. OUR NEXT QUESTION
BECAUSE THE LINE A TEN GOOD
HERE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. DANIEL GOOD
CARE OF ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. EXPLAINS THE
CANADA ONE CAROL FOR SUPPORT.
ONE ZERO. AND THERE IS NO MARC
ALMOND. IN THE COMING LET'S GO
TO THE OPPOSITION SO STARTING
WITH THE- MELANIE CLEVERNESS
WITH DE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION. VIA THE TELEPHONE
AND ROBERT WILSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE.
WELCOME HI YOU JUST ARE YOU ON
THE LINE IN. I AM CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS I AM
MELANIE CLEE THAT BUT THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS WITH THAT
THE SHOW AND- APPLIED LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK ON THE PROPOSAL
AND THINK THE AUTHOR AND
MONSTER'S FOR THE DIALOGUE THAT
WE THE TABLETS THAT FAR. AND
FOR THEIR COMMITMENT TO RESOLVE
OUR ISSUES AND NOT INTACT
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTIONS NOR THE
DEPOSIT ACCOUNT BUT THEY ARE.
CALIFORNIA BANKS ARE IN THE
BUSINESS OF SERVING THEIR-
ACTUALLY WENT. STRAIGHT ARE
MEMBERS SUCCEED WHEN OUR- THINK
THE AND WE FOR ONE ARE
COMMUNITY STOPPER. I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW THAT OUR MEMBER BANKS-
ALWAYS ENCOURAGE CUSTOMERS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING HURT. TO
CONTACT THEIR CREDITOR DIRECTLY
TO WORK OUT ISSUES. HOWEVER WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN CONSUMER TURN ELSEWHERE TO
RESOLVE THEIR- VVA APPLIED THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORED. OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY THREE FOR
THEIR WORK TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
AGAINST UNLAWFUL AND
UNSCRUPULOUS THAT SETTLEMENT
PRACTICE SAYS UNFORTUNATELY WE
REMAIN IN AND OPPOSE THE MARKER
MENDED POSITION ON THE MEASURE
WE ARE WORKING THROUGH THE
INTERNET KEEP IMPLICATIONS OF
THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED IN THE
CANADIAN DOLLAR BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW THAT WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S EFFORT TO BRING
MARK WHERE HE- HELPING WITH
THAN WHAT IS CURRENTLY AND
CRANKS. I DON'T. THANK WHICH IS
AN IMPORTANT MATTER HOWEVER WE
ARE SO TRYING UNDERSTAND THE IS
PARAGRAPH IN TO ENSURE IT
DOESN'T CREATE AN A CONFLICT
HOP BY. IMPACTING DEPOSIT
ACCOUNT RELATIONSHIP OR BROADLY
CATEGORIZING THESE ENTITIES AS
UNDESIRABLE AND THEREFORE
UNABLE TO ACT THAT FINANCIAL
SERVICES. WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT
WE MAY CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE FARM THIRDS
TO TIGHTEN AND CLARIFY THE
INTENT IN THE IMPACT OF THE
MEASURE. AT THAT TIME BUT THE
DOCTOR THE MOMENT WHILE AN
IMPROVEMENT DO NOT FULLY
RESOLVED ARE CONCERNED IN THE
REMAIN IN A RESPECTFUL OPPOSE
I'M RECOMMENDED POSSESSION. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
DIALOGUE AND TO WORKING TOWARD
THE EVENTUAL REMOVAL. OF OUR
OPPOSITION. REMEMBER TRAINING
CAN. AND FOR THE OPERA. TO
TESTIFY IN THE AIR TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW GO TO THE ME
TO USE I START WITH THE ROOM
HERE I DON'T SEE AN IN. ONE
PERSON HELP MISTER WILSON GO AT.
MR ROBERT WILSON ARE YOU ON THE
LINE PLEASE. I GUESS WE COULD
COME BACK TO MR LISTEN OF LET'S
SUCK START WITH ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION. ON THE LINE PLEASE.
AND IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMEDIAN-
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE.
I WANT TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
THANK- DOCTOR WEBER OF FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL AS WE NOW
WILL REALLY LITERALLY MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS ARE LOSING THEIR
JOBS DURING THIS CRISIS IT'S IT
IS SO IMPORTANT AT THAT WE
PROTECT THE FINANCIALLY
VULNERABLE FOLKS FROM PLAN TO
TORY SCHEMES. THAT SAID IT IS
IMPORTANT TO US. PRECISELY
ALLOCATE LIABILITY TO ALL THE
BUSINESSES AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DECEIVING CONSUMERS
FOR PROFIT. AND WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ACCEPTED TODAY I AM
VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I THINK THE MEN AND START
THE RIGHT BALANCE- AND- I SEE
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED ALSO AT THIS TIME I
LIKED ARE STOCKED WITH FOOD TOO
CLOSE. JUST SIMPLY WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF AND YOU FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH THAT'S
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THOSE WHO HAVE OPPOSITION TO
SEE IF WE CAN READ SOME KIND OF
AGREEMENT THAT THERE. MIKE
AUTHOR MISSED US MEMBER. WHO'S
ALL WORKED ON THIS. AND THE
REALLY JUST SIMPLY SAY IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE WORK VERY
HARD TO PROTECT THOSE WHO ARE
MOST VULNERABLE. MANY ARE GOING
TO SUFFER ECONOMIC HARDSHIP AND
THE LAST THING THEY NEED IS TO
BE PREYED ON BY INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE NO INTENT OF REALLY
HELPING THEM. BUT HELPING
THEMSELVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK I
BELIEVE FOR TWENTY FOUR FORTY
THIRD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP
SEC I AM SECRETARY WHICH YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR SHALL I
SHALL I KILEY. KILEY KNOW OUR
QUE HAN HI OKAY HAND I BERMAN.
BERMAN I MEDINA AYE MEDINA I.
CARILLO. MULLIN. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO IRWIN HI- WHEN I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO WICKS
WICKS I. HI THE BILL IS OUT YOU
HAVE SIX GO TO LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN US EITHER THANK YOU ALL
THANK YOU THE REMAINING.
MEMBERS SO THAT BRINGS US TO.
AB TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR THAT'S
MISTER CALDERON STILL I
UNDERSTAND- MIST WAS GONNA
PRESENT ON HIS BEHALF SO IT
TIME YOU- ALREADY A MISTER WENT
AND AT THIS TIME I LIKE AGAIN
TO REITERATE- FOOT TO DOES SO
WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT OUR POSITION. FIVE I DO
IT CALLING NOW AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
TESTIMONY TO AVOID ANY DELAYS
THE PHONE NUMBER AGAIN IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO NINE
FIVE. SEVEN SO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ONE HI- SO ANYTIME
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I AM PRETENDING AB
TWO THOUSAND FOR TODAY THE HALF
OF THE SENATE NUMBER CALDERON.
IT DOESN'T. RIGHT USE USE UP
THIRD OF ALL CREDENTIALS FOR
THE PER OF. THE OF  COVE IT.
TEST AND PROVIDE A MINIMUM SO
THAT MUST BE MET. TO BE
CONSIDERED A VERIFIED
CREDENTIALS DURINGTHE CURRENT
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS ONE OF THE
MOST CRITICAL TOOLS OUR STATE
HAS AGAINST THE VIRUSES ARE YOU
TO TEST FOR THE DISEASE. AND
PERFORM CONTACT TRACING TO
UNDERSTAND IT SPREAD. GOVERNOR
NEWSOME HAS IDENTIFIED TESTING
AND CONTACT FACING IS ONE OF
THE SIX CORE INDICATORS. BOTTOM
FIGHT THE URGENT PERSON A
STATEWIDE ENGAGEMENT IN TESTING
AND TRACKING COMMUNITIES ARE
BEGINNING TO- ARE BECOMING
INCREASINGLY HESITANT TO ENGAGE
WITH THESE EFFORTS BECAUSE OF
PRIVACY CONCERNS WITH HOW THEIR
PERSONAL HEALTH DATA WILL BE
USED VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS
OFFER A PRIVATE AND SECURE WAY
TO PROVE AN INDIVIDUAL SCOLDED
NINETEEN TEST RESULTS WITHOUT
SACRIFICING THEIR PRIVACY THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW ISSUERS OF
COVERT NINETEEN OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN TEST TO UTILIZE
VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS YEAH
IMPLEMENTING A MINIMUM STANDARD
IT WOULD ENSURE THAT SUCH
CREDENTIALS ARE TRULY PROTECT
AND CALIFORNIA IS RIGHT TO PROP.
ALLOWING THEM TO TEST THE
CRUCIAL EFFORT TO CAN. VIRUS
AND ULTIMATELY REOPEN OUR
STATE. WITH ME TO TEST A FIVE.
A TODAY IS ALLEY MEDINA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BLOCKCHAIN ADVOCACY COALITION
AND DOCTOR RAJ GUPTA ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF ANESTHESIOLOGY AT
VANDERBILT UNIVERSITY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME- THIS
SO IF THE WITNESSES ARE ON THE
LINE YOU MAY BEGIN AS WELL. BUT
WHAT THIS IS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DOCTOR RAJ BUT- AND I'M
AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
ANESTHESIOLOGY AT VANDERBILT
UNIVERSITY MEDICAL CENTER.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALLED RUNS BILL TWO
ZERO AB TWO YEARS OR FOUR. THE
CROWN OF OUR SPEND AND FOR
SOCIETY INTO A PLACE THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN BEFORE AND WE WILL
NEED NEW TOOLS TO RETURN
SOCIETY TO A FUNCTIONING LEVEL.
WHILE STILL MAXIMIZING SAFETY
PRIVACY AND TRUST IN OUR
SYSTEM. IN OUR PRIOR WORLD IF
SOMEONE NEEDED TO PROVIDE A
VERIFIED. MEDICAL TESTS TO AN
EMPLOYER OR SCHOOL THEY WOULD
REQUEST THE DOCUMENTS FROM
THEIR DOCTOR'S OFFICE OR HEALTH
SYSTEM. THEN TAKE THE PAPER OR
ELECTRONIC DOCUMENT TO THE
PERSON WHO NEEDED IT. AND THAT
THEIR SUBSEQUENTLY HAVE THEM
VERIFY EVERYTHING BEFORE
COMPLETION. FOR EXAMPLE GETTING
VACCINATION RECORDS TO YOUR
CHILD'S SCHOOL BEFORE THE NEW
YEAR BEGAN. THIS COULD TAKE
DAYS AT BEST AND OFTEN WEEKS TO
COMPLETE. HOWEVER THIS- IS
UNACCEPTABLE BECAUSE THESE
INTERACTIONS THAT THIS WAS
ACCEPTABLE BEFORE BECAUSE THESE
INTERACTIONS WERE REPRESENTS
MOST OF US. IN THE KNOW THAT
THE TABLE ROOM. HELLO IN
TODAY'S WORLD WOULD BE CANNIBAL
TO YOU EXISTING PROCESS EVERY
TWO OF COURSE MIGHT NAY. THE
PERSON THEIR TESTING IN FOR
POKER OF TO THEIR EMPLOYER GOV
BUILDING A SCHOOL A HOSPITAL
SALON A GROCERY STORE A CONCERT
VENUE THE STADIUM OR ANY OTHER
NUMBER OF PLACES THAT HUMANS
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER. THIS
WOULD BE MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY
POSSIBLY HUNDREDS OF TIMES A
WEEK. CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
FRAMEWORK FOR TRANSMITTING AND
STORING THIS IMPORTANT HEALTH
DATA IT'S SIMPLY NOT SET UP TO
OPERATE AT THIS SCALE
SUFFICIENTLY. IN A VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIAL SYSTEM THE PERSON
ISSUING THE CREDENTIAL NEEDS TO
BE A TRUSTED ENTITY FOR EXAMPLE
A DOCTOR'S OFFICE OR A NURSE
PRACTITIONER. AND WE ALREADY
HAVE PROCESSES FOR IDENTIFYING
THESE PEOPLE INVALIDATING THAN.
THIS ISSUE OR IS GIVING THE
CREDENTIALS OF THE PERSON
THEMSELVES TO HOLD THIS GIVES
THE INDIVIDUAL TO CONTROL THEIR
OWN PERSONAL HEALTH INFORMATION
AND- NOW THAT PERSON HAS THE
ABILITY TO DISTRIBUTE THAT
INFORMATION. AND WEBER NEED
THAT IN A TRUSTED AND SECURE
WAY WITHOUT HAVING RETURNED
ISSUING ENTITIES THE TIME. ALSO
WITHOUT HAVING TO HAVE THE
RECIPIENT TAKE TIME AND WORK TO
CONFIRM THE VALIDITY OF THE
TEST EVERY TIME. THEY WOULD ALL
BE AUTOMATED. RIGHT NOW WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT TEST OR CATS
WILL BE THE MAGIC FORMULA TO
KEEP US SAFE FROM INFECTION OR
FROM INFECTING OTHERS. VIRAL
TESTING ANTIBODY TESTING
VACCINES OR COMBINATION. THAT
INFORMATION IS EVOLVING RAPIDLY
HOWEVER WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
CREATE A TRUSTED INFRASTRUCTURE
SYSTEM THAT IS EFFICIENT
SECURE. AND ADAPTABLE TO THIS
EVOLVING INFORMATION. THAT WAY
GOVERNMENT BODIES PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS DOCTORS AND
SCIENTISTS CAN CONTINUE TO MAKE
THE DECISION. THAT WE NEED
BASED ON THE TESTING FOR
SOCIETY AND THE PUBLIC CAN HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT WE HAVE A
RELIABLE WAY TO CONVEY THAT
INFORMATION. TO EVERYONE WHO
NEEDS IT. AB TWO ZERO ZERO FOR
AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN
ALLOWING THE UTILIZATION OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE ON. THE TEST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS. THAT WOULD BE
A COMMITTEE MEMBER. YES HI THIS
MEDINA. YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PUBLIC SERVICE TODAY I AM.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BLOCKING OUT OF THE COALITION
WE'RE OFFERING AB TALKING FOR
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WITH SO
MANY PEOPLE OUT OF WORK AND
BUSINESSES CLOSE AFFECT HER
LIFE AND COME TO A GRINDING
HALT. AND WE ALL WANT O GET
PEOPLE FAITHFULLY BACK TO A
NORMAL LIFE. HERE WE CAN START
TO ECONOMIC RECOVERY OF OUR
STATE. THIS IS WHY CAFFEINE IS
ONE OF THE SIX CORE INDICATOR
THE GOVERNOR HAS LEFT LIKE TO
REOPEN ECONOMY. IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE OFFER CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT METHOD OF STORING AND
SHE- RESULT. THEY GIVE THEM
CONTROL OF THEIR OWN THE ACT.
ITSELF IS ACTUALLY CAN YOU
THREE OVER THE ECONOMY AND
LUNCH DURING THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF PRIVACY FOR AND. WITH YOU
MAY. YEAH VERY ALLOW THE USE OF
THEIR CREDENTIAL THE NEW TO
CREATE MAINTAIN NINETEEN OR
OTHER. ALL A CLEAR FIVE THIS
AND- BECAUSE FULL RIGHT MINIMUM
STANDARDS DO YEAH. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WITH COMMITTEE AND
THE OPPOSITE. HE TO FLY OUT
THERE. INCREASE MOST FOR.
LANGUAGE THE PRICE POSSIBLE. I
KNOW HOW TO KEEP THE FAIRLY
ACOSTA BUT WOULD LOOK REALLY
THINK WE WOULD INTEGRATE CAN
HELP WITH HOW THAT. BUT THE
INDIVIDUAL PRACTICAL THE TELL
ME ABOUT THEIR DOCTOR TO GET
HAPPEN. IF WE NEED TO PRE THAT
THEY A CO NINETEEN CARPET
WHATEVER IT TAKES. UNDECLARED
WITH THE FAN. THEY COULD TAKE
PATH. TO THEIR DOCTOR AND HAVE
THE DOCTOR VERIFIED WITH ALL.
AT PROBABLY THE FOR A Q. R.
CODE. WHATEVER THEY WANT TO
SHARE OR CONFIRM THEIR CAPTORS.
STATUS IF THEY MIGHT GO BACK TO
WORK AND YOU TO TRANSFER THE
WORKPLACE. THEY CAN SHARE THE
INFORMATION THEY WANT. WE NEED
TO GET BENEFITS. MAKING SURE
THAT THE GOVERNMENT AGENCY THEY
WANT INTEREST ALONG. FOR A LOT
OF TALK ABOUT THAT. CASE
BLOCKING DOES NOT FOR MEDI DATA
REALLY NEED TO CONVENE
INFORMATION FRAUD PERMISSION IF
YOU'RE LIKE A DOCTOR OR NURSE
PRACTITIONER TO A PATIENT WE'RE
NOT DICTATING WITH CAPTAIN KIRK
ARE STANDARD COULD BE BACK ALL
RELIANT ON WHATEVER OUR HEALTH
AGENCIES NOT WHAT IF YOU COULD
SECURE WAY OF CONVEYING
INFORMATION AND EMPOWER
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE THEIR OWN
DATA NOT HAVING TO HEAR ABOUT
ALL HOPE IT WOULD. I WOULD
THINK THAT YET THAT MANY FEEL
YOU FOR THREE BEEN LOCKED IN
THE MORNING TO DISCUSS THEIR
CONCERNS OF ITSELF I REALLY
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOU
TOWARD A BETTER VERSION OF THAT.
AND I THINK. HAT THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TEST LET US GO TO AT THIS.
SO OF THE BILL. OF THE SITE
WITH THE RIVER HERE I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY STEPPING UP SO LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINES. IF YOU
SUPPORT THIS SO LEGISLATION. OF
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS
YOUR POSITION. AGAIN IF YOU TO
WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO COST. TO YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION. I BELIEVE WE HOW OF.
ONE INDIVIDUAL CEMENT THE
CORBIN. IN OPPOSITION ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. I AM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT MEDICAL ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION I'D LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHORSTOCKTON
SPONSORS FOR TAKING TIME TO
SPEAK WITH A DOCTOR AND CAN WE
DO SO REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE AS WRITTEN- AS WRITTEN
A. B. ZERO ZERO ZERO FOUR COULD
GET A BLANK CHECK TO ISSUERS OF
MEDICAL TESTS TO SHARE TOUCH
RESULT WITH. ANYONE WITH NO
MORE OF A CHECK THEM OUT AND
HAVE VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS OF
DEFINED. BY THE WORLD WIDE WEB
CONSORTIUM. IT'S UNCLEAR TO US
TYPICALLY JUST. IS TO
EXPLICITLY ALLOW FOR THE USE OF
VERIFIED CREDENTIALS. THEREFORE
IF THE LEGISLATURE TO DISREGARD
LIST YOU CREATE BACK TO IN THE
AREA IF YOU TAKE GREAT CARE NOT
TO CREATE PROBLEMATICALLY
PULLED THAT MAY HARM CONSUMERS.
CAN'T FOR INNOVATION OR
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFIT
CERTAIN BUSINESS MODEL OVER
OTHERS. I'VE WRITTEN THE BILL
LANGUAGE IT'S UNCLEAR AS TO
WITHOUT WHICH PRIVATE OR PUBLIC
ENTITIES WOULD BE COVERED AND
IN WHICH THE CONTENT THAT. AND
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO ASCERTAIN AFTER
FORGET IN THE LATE AT THAT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT. I KNOW
LIMITING THE SHARING TESTABLE
PRION FOR QUITE A RING THAT
SOMEONE TRYING TO ACCESS TEST
RESULTS VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS.
THE BILL CURRENTLY ALLOWED
ANYONE WITH A VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIAL TO GET ANYONE ELSE
TO TEST RESULT. WHAT THE BILL
FACT SHEET THE DRAFT THAT IT
MIGHT THE PHILIPPINE AUTOMATED
CONTRACT FREE THING WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT TO BE CORRECT AS
WRITTEN. THE AUTOMATED CONTACT
THREE THING IN THE LAST AT
LEAST THAT THAT IT'S ALREADY
BEEN FOUGHT FOR AND THE APPLE
GOOGLE API FACT. IS THAT
PROXIMITY OP USERS WILL REPORT
NO INFORMATION FROM THEIR PHONE
TWO ESSENTIAL TO THE TENT
EXCEPT IF THEY ARE CONFIRMED
I'VE INTERACTED WITH COALBED.
BUT PROXIMITY IDENTIFIERS THAT
THEIR PHONE USE THAT WILL THEN
TRANSMIT THAT DATA TO OTHERS.
EVEN IF THE BILL MAKES SOME
PEOPLE FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
SHARING THEIR TEST RESULTS. BUT
SHOULD HAVE NO BEARING
WHATSOEVER ON THEIR COMFORT
WHEN IT COMES TO DOWNLOADING
THINGS LIKE PROXIMITY APPS.
WHICH ARE ALSO NOT CURRENTLY
REQUIRED UNDER LAW TO LIMIT THE
SCOPE AND USE A DATA THAT THEY
COLLECT. MOREOVER IF MEASURE
WILL HAVE LITTLE RELEVANCE
WHATSOEVER TO TESTING WERE
UNABLE TO MEET THE DEMAND FOR
TAX IN THE FIRST PLACE. FINALLY
I'VE WRITTEN THE MEASURE
SPECIFIED A SINGULAR WAY BY AT
THE W. THREE V. PROTOCOLS FOR
TAX DEVELOPERS TO BUILD. THIS
LOCKED INTO PLACE SINGLE
STANDARD. BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES OVER TIME OFTEN RAPIDLY
BUT DRAFTING COULD CREATE
FIFTEEN CONNECTICUT POP ON AND
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES- IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. ONE ON THE LINE REPEAL
WITHOUT. YEP WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF. REBECCA CREAMER MALTER
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BACK AT KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU IN
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
OPERATOR AND- I'M SPEAKING WITH
US YESTERDAY HOWEVER WE DO
REMAIN. OPPOSED TO THAT STYLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. THERE WAS ONE THAT
WAS IN- POSITIVE THAT MISSED
THE OPPORTUNITY CHRIS ALLEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BROWN I'M
I'M THE FOUNDER. STRUCTURE
SOFTWARE DEVELOPMENT AND
RESEARCH BUT IN PARTICULAR FOR
THIS SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
BROADER INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS
W. THREE C. AND THE CREDENTIALS
COMMUNITY GROUP THEREFORE I AM
CARE- MY TAXES SHE COULD NOT
WATER SSL TLS THE BROADEST.
YEAH I HAVE INTERNET TRAFFIC.
LOBBYIST BY. ON THE NEW
SECURITY ARCHITECTURE BACK TO
TOP OFFICIALS IN DECENTRALIZED
AGAIN A. STANDARD WITH
WORLDWIDE WEB RESOURCE THE
SECOND IN LATE STAGES OF THEIR-
OUR FIVE YEAR. FOR MANY
QUESTIONS. I DON'T. SIR I DO
NOT HAVE RECOGNITION. SIR YOUR
LINE IS KIND OF RIGHT DO NOT
HAVE. SORRY I WALL. BE MORE
CLEAR- I DON'T HAVE
RESERVATIONS THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES OFFER A NUMBER OF
PRIVACY BY DESIGN AND ADDRESS
SECURITY ISSUES THAT LEGACY
CREDENTIALS AND IDENTITY
TECHNOLOGIES DO NOT
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
THE OLD OR THE CANADIAN
GOVERNMENT AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER USE NATIONS ARE COMMITTED
TO MOVING TOWARD THE SOLUTIONS
USING THESE. ARCHITECTURES MY
RESERVATIONS REGARDING THIS
BILL IS LESS ABOUT THE EFFICACY
OF THE TECHNOLOGY BUT THE
IMMATURITY UPPER BOTCHED
HEALTHCARE PRIVACY IN RISK
MODELS AND THE EXPECTED PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS IN REGARDS
FOR USE OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES-
ARM WHICH WERE NOT IN THE
ORIGINAL USE CASES TO FIND AND
STANDARDS. FOR INSTANCE I FEEL
THAT THE USE OF SCARAB BIBLE
CLEANS FOR COMMUNITY
CREDENTIALS REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
RISK ANALYSIS. LIKE THE- STAFF
I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE- THE
USE OF CREDENTIALS FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH- PERSPECTIVE- BUT
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGY
ITSELF. I DO BELIEVE THAT IF
THE STATE ASSEMBLY IS GOING TO
OPERATE SOME FORM OF
INVESTIGATION PROOF OF CONCEPT
OR IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW
PRIVACY PRESERVING HEALTHCARE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT VERIFIABLE
CLAIMS IN THE CENTRAL LIKE
IDENTIFIERS ARE THE STATUS
ARCHITECTURE AVAILABLE TODAY.
ALL RIGHT OF COURSE IMPLEMENTED
STILL NEED TO BE CAREFUL WITH
THE DETAILS IT IS STILL
POSSIBLE USE THESE. REYES
COMPROMISE THEIR INTENDED GOALS
FOR SECURITY AND PRIVACY. THAT
BEING SAID CONTINUE USE OF THE
EXTREMELY CRAP MAN IT LET IT BE
ARCHITECTURES FOR OUR IDENTITY
AND PERSONAL HEALTH INFORMATION
AND THE HEALTHCARE. DAY. I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT IN NEW. TO
ENABLE VERIFIABLE CLAIMS AS AN
INTERNATIONAL STANDARD TO BE
ABLE TO BE USED AGAIN ARE YOUR
OUR FUTURE WORK. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY ON THIS TOPIC LET
ME KNOW IF YOU NEED MORE
DETAILS ON THE TECHNICAL TOPICS
ABOUT. OTHER WAYS MY EX HE'S
CAN BE OF SERVICE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR. DISHES
ALL OPPONENT PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND YOUR POSITION. UP
I'M SORRY I. RIGHT ADDITIONAL
FOLKS ON THE LINE. AND IF
THERE'S ANYONE OUT LETTER
COMMON IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
WE HAVE KNOWN EACH YEAR. IF
THERE ARE NO FURTHER
INDIVIDUALS ONLINE IS BRING
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER OBERNOLTE
FOLLOWED BY THIS WEEK'S I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- SO I'M
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
IDEA OF USING A VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIALS AS A TOOL FOR
HEARING TEST RESULTS. I THOUGHT
THE OPPOSITION IS AN
INTERESTING COMMENT WHEN THE
CRITICISM WAS BROUGHT UP THAT
THERE PER IT MIGHT BE OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES THERE ALSO
APPROPRIATE FOR THIS BUT MY
REACH IT WAS THAT IT'S JUST
MERELY IF IT SAYS MAY. I HELP
CARE PROVIDER THIS TO SHARE
RESULT. NOT JUST THE LIMIT LIST
OF. THE USE A VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIALS SO I WANTED TO ASK
ABOUT THAT I MEAN IS YOUR- IS
YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF CURRENT
LAW. THAT THIS IS REQUIRED FOR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER TO SHIP TO-
I'M SORRY THAT THE TO CURRENT
LAW PER PROHIBITS HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER FROM- FROM SHARING
TEST RESULTS. USING VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIALS OR MAY HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER CURRENTLY DO THIS I'D
I WILL PROBABLY LET THE
ADVOCATES FOR THE BILL ANSWER
THAT BUT I THINK I MEAN THE WAY
THAT I READ. MISTER CALDERON
SPILL IS THAT THIS IS A ONE
TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN BE USED. OF
IN VERIFIABLE. OF CREDENTIALS
OR IF YOU'RE DOING CONTACT
TRACING OR IF YOU'RE DOING IT
IMMUNOLOGY IT IMMUNITY PASSPORT
SO. IT JUST IT JUST GIVES THE
ABILITY TO USE BLOCKCHAIN IS
ONE DATES THAT ONE WAY TO.
PRIVACY JOURNAL I UNDERSTAND
THAT MY QUESTION IS ABSENT THE
BILL. CAN A PROVIDER USE
VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS TO SHARE
TEST RESULT WITH THE PATIENT. I
THINK THAT'S UP TO- THAT'S UP
TO HEALTH CARE AGENCIES I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S NECESSARILY
BEEN DECIDED YET BUT- HOW ABOUT
THE ADVOCATES ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. SURE LET'S GO TO THE
WITNESS. RIGHT YEAH HAPPY TO
JUMP IN HERE AND THANK YOU FOR
REMEMBER A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
QUESTION- YEAH THERE'S NOTHING
YOU INCURRED FOR HITTING AT ALL
AFTER FOR USING THAT I
UNDERSTAND- THERE THE DOCTOR IN
WYOMING IS CURRENTLY USING THAT
CURRENTLY- WHAT THE BILL DOES
IS THAT IT IS NOT LISTED
STANDARD EIGHT YOU WOULD FEEL
COMFORTABLE. WITH A LOT. OKAY
THE- TO RESTATE THE OF THE BILL
IS IF A PROVIDER IS GOING TO
USE VERIFIABLE CREDENTIALS THIS
WILL ESTABLISH A FRAMEWORK FOR
DOING SO. FOR USING THAT AIM TO.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FROM OF THE
BILL. THIS WICKS GO AHEAD
PLEASE THANK YOU I EVER-
QUESTION AND A COMMENT- AND
IT'S A LITTLE BIT SIMILAR TO I
THINK MISTRAL NINETIES QUESTION
BUT SO WITH THIS BILL- ANYTHING
THAT IS CURRENTLY NOT PERMITTED
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW. HOW ABOUT
THE ADVOCATE CANCERS THAT. YEAH
NO IT WOULD NOT IT WOULD
CERTAINLY NOT PEOPLE EAT ANY
HALF HOUR HERE ARE THE AM I A
OR T. V. P. A STANDARD IT WOULD
NOT DOING ANYTHING ABOUT IT FOR
HER TO HELP ME A LOT IT IS
SIMPLY CLARIFYING. EXPECTED FOR
A CONVENE INFORMATION. AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF. YEAH OKAY AND
JUST A COMMENT IN A I KNOW. MR
ONES NOT THE AUTHOR I AND I'VE
SPOKEN WITH THE AUTHOR MISTER
CALDERON. I MEAN I SHARE SOME
OF THE PRIVACY CONCERNS BUT
I'LL GIVE THE ALL INTO
COURTESY AYE VOTE TODAY TO GET
OTHER COMMITTEE BUT IT'S MY
HOPE THAT. THE OTHER CAN WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO TRY TO
COME TO SOME SORT OF COMPROMISE
VERTICALLY IN THE PRIVACY. YEAH
AND IT. IS A- NOTE FROM MISTER
CALDERON. REAL THAT HE WILL
WORK WITH THAT YOU HAVE HALF AN
ACLU TO. ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. THAT'S GREAT THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF HIS IRWIN- FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION FOR MISTER
CALDERON- THIS BILL- HAS
SOMEWHAT BEEN A STRUGGLE FOR ME
I INITIALLY- BUT I THINK THE
AUTHOR HAS A VISION THAT COULD
HELP PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
MEDICAL TEST RESULTS IN A CHECK
THAT VISION. IS CHIEF IT COULD
BE A REAL BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS SAYS ECONOMY RE OPENS
UP I UNDERSTAND THAT THE BILL
NEEDS ADDITIONAL WORK BUT THE
SHOW OF HAVING KNOWLEDGE YOU TO
SECURELY HELP IN DECLINE IT
THERE I. STE THURSDAY. TO THIS
IS AND THE COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH. MY TEAM
AS WELL AS OUR STAKEHOLDERS IN
EXPERTS TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS- WITH THE BILL BEFORE
US AND FOR THAT REASON TODAY I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL- HAVING
SAID THAT I THINK WHEN. THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS BILL
TO- COME BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE
SO WILL HAVE A SECOND CHANCE TO
LOOK AT THE BILL AND- AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT- BUT A TIME IT
COMES BACK- WE WILL HAVE. SOME
THE SOME OF THESE. REYES IT
WOULD NOT THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED UP DO I HAVE A SECOND ON
THAT MOTION IT'S MOVED AND
SECONDED THAT MR WHEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR PRIVACY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT SO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS IS
ENDED CHAO HI SHALL I KILEY.
KILEY AYE OUR QUE HAN. OKAY
HAND I BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
MEDINA AYE MEDINA I CARILLO. I
MULLIN GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I
IRWIN HI- WHEN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I WICKS. WICKS HI THE
BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS SO
THAT BRINGS US TO AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTEEN THAT MISS IRWIN BELK
AND AGAIN IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION BY PHONE I DO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CALL IN NOW
AND- WHEN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF BEGIN SIR TESTIMONY- THIS IS
THE TIME FOR YOU TO- DIAL THAT
NUMBER THE NUMBER NUMBER AGAIN
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. NINE FIVE SEVEN AGAIN
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE.
FIVE SO WITH WHEN PLEASE
PROCEED A THANK YOU MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TELL US AB.
THREE ONE ONE SIX. IS A BILL
WHICH I AM A JOINT OFFERING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTEEN PROVIDES
CLARITY THAT MOBILITY DEVICE
INFORMATION IS COVERED UNDER
CURRENT PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS PRIVACY ACT OR
CAL ACT A AS IT RELATES TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COLLECTION OF
LOOK. FROM LAST YEAR REQUEST
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL LOOKING
TO THE SUBJECT MATTER OF THIS
BILL AS IT RELATES TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNOR PERMITTING OPERATIONS.
OUR RECORD WOULD REQUIRE REAL
TIME DATA SHARING AND THEY
CONCLUDED THAT PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS THAT COMPEL TRIP
DATA FROM MOBILITY DEVICES ARE
GOVERNED BY CAL ACT THAT.
REQUIRING EITHER THE USERS
CONSENT OR A COURT ORDER TO BE
COMPLIANT WITH THE LAW. GIVEN
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
DISPUTING THIS INTERPRETATION
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY MEANT TO
CLARIFY DID EXISTING LAW WHILE
PROVIDING A PASSWORD REASONABLE
AGGREGATE AND THE I. FIVE DATA
USE. FOR TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING. AS EFFORTS CONTINUE
TO USE DATA AND TECHNOLOGY TO
ADDRESS THIS CALL THAT NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE THAT
MISINTERPRETATION OF EXISTING
LAW. WHICH HARM THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
PERSIST. AS NOTED ON PAGE SEVEN
OF THE COMMITEE ANALYSIS I AM
HAPPY TO BE TAKING AMENDMENT TO
SUGGESTED. THAT IMPROVES THE
BILL'S REFERENCE TO CAL. I'M
PLEASE JOIN HERE TODAY BY PHONE
WITH THE ROBERT CALLAGHAN FROM
THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION AND
MAP THE CORBIN FROM. ELECTRONIC
FUN DOWN HERE. THANK GO TO A
WITNESSES MISTER CALLAHAN ON
THE LINE. I AM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROBERT
CALLAGHAN WITH HERE THIS ISSUE
SHE HAD NOT A PROUD TO BE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE ONE
SIX. THE BILL THAT WOULD SIMPLY
CLARIFY THAT Q. LOCATION AND
YOUR LOCATION RELATED DATA
GENERATED FROM THE OPERATION OF
MOBILITY DEVICES IS PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND SUBJECT TO
EXISTING PROTECTIONS AND STATE
LAW- NAY PLACES OF A WOMAN
MENTIONED ARE OPENING-
CALIFORNIA ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS PRIVACY ACT AS
WELL AS THE- RECENTLY ENACTED
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT. AS WAS DISCUSSED IN GREAT
DEPTH IN A SENATE PROMOTIONAL
HEARING- JUST THIS PAST
FEBRUARY THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL HAS NOW STATED
REPEATEDLY THAT THE HELD DURING
OF REAL TIME. SHE LOCATION THE
GOVERNMENT COVER CAL TECH. FOR
WHATEVER REPORTER BROTHER
PROCESS AB MINUTES WE ALSO
HEARD HEARING- INCREASING
IMPORT PUBLIC IRAN'S ISSUE
THERE TO NOT TO BE A- YOU CASE
FOR THE- NON AGGREGATED TRIP
DATA SHOWS THE MOVEMENTS OF
INDIVIDUALS IN NEAR REAL TIME
OUTSIDE OF AN URGENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT MATTER. THE REAL
TIME MONITORING OF MOBILITY
DEVICE TRIP DATA EVEN IF
INTENDED FOR LEGITIMATE USE
SUCH AS TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
PURPOSE. ADDS TO A REAL THREAT
OF GROWING GOVERNMENT
SURVEILLANCE ON THE MOVEMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS. NOW AGAIN WE'RE
NOT ARGUING- THROUGH THIS BILL
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES DO NOT HAVE
IMPORTANT USES FOR MOBILITY
DATA BECAUSE THEY CERTAINLY DO
YOU. AB THREE ONE SIX IS MY
COMPROMISED PROTECTION AND FROM
THERE ON WHAT ALSO ENSURING
PUBLIC IT HE'S SAYS. THERE ARE
DATED AND ANONYMIZE MOBILITY
DATA WHICH SHOWS THE TRAPPINGS
AND INSIGHTS NEEDED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING YEAH
THAT. USES FOR DEBT THE BILL TO
COME. BUT NONE OF WHICH- WILL
TRIP DAY AND IN EVERY WOULD
BETTER SERVED WITH TARGETED
AGGREGATED DATA WE AGREED THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS WANTED
STATES DEPLETED DOES NOT NEED
TO BE TIED TO AN INDIVIDUAL OR
VERGE TRIP. IN ORDER IS FOR THE
CITY'S INDEED AGGREGATED
ANONYMOUS DATA CAN PROVIDE
INSIGHT TO THE TRAVEL PATTERNS
CONGESTION AND USE GET THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE MADE. LOCATION
DATA IS DEEPLY PERSONAL
PERSONAL AND AMONG MOST PRIVACY
SENSITIVE FORMS DATA THAT
MERITS. CASE PROVIDED IS STILL.
LIKELY ASK COMMITTEE FOR I ON
AB THREE ONE ONCE THANK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT. DIRECTOR CHAIR
MEMBERS MET THE CORPORATE ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION I WOULD BE
AMENDMENT TAKEN TODAY AND
COMMITTEE AT THE Q. IN SUPPORT
OF THREE ONE ONE SIX WHICH AS
AMENDED WILL STRIKE THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN THE NEED TO
PROTECT INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY. AND
THE NEED FOR LOCAL AUTHORITIES
TO OBTAIN THE DATA THAT THEY
NEED FOR CITY PLANNING PUBLIC
THAT. I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHORS FOR DRESSING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND FOR THE
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF TIME THEY
SPENT DISCUSSING IT WITH US.
LOW AND REGIONAL PLANNING
AGENCIES AND JURISDICTIONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
INCREASINGLY DEMANDING ACCESS
TO NEW MOBILITY START AT THAT
AND DEVICES IN ORDER TO BETTER
PLAN. AND ENSURE THAT THE
STREETS WORK FOR ALL. THE ABOUT
THE GRIEF THAT PLANNING AGENCY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COLLECT SOME
DATA IN ORDER TO NSURE NEW
TRANSPORTATION DEBATE THAT ARE
DEEPLY DEEPLY. PATIENTLY
EQUITABLY AND SUSTAINABLY. BUT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE TO COLLECT.
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT WRITERS IN
ORDER TO DO SO. SO TWO THINGS
ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
INDIVIDUAL TRIP DATA IS
SENSITIVE LOCATION DATA THAT
PERTAIN TO MOVEMENT OF REAL
INDIVIDUAL AS SUCH SHE ALWAYS
BE OFF LIMITS FOR CITY OR
REGIONAL PLANNING PURPOSES.
LOCAL AUTHORITIES CAN AND
SHOULD WE USE AGGREGATED AND DE
IDENTIFIED TRICKY THAT TO IT
THEY'RE PLANNING CALL. MEASURE
TAKE A SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD
TO PROTECTING THE LOCATION
PRIVACY OF CALIFORNIA ACROSS
THE STATE WHO RELY ON SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICES. IT
APPROPRIATELY RECOGNIZED THAT
THE SENSITIVE NATURE OF
INDIVIDUAL TRIP DATA AND ENSURE
THAT LOCAL AUTHORITIES WILL
RECEIVE ONLY AGGREGATED NON
IDENTIFIABLE TRIP DATA. WE'VE
PROTECTION FOR CRITICAL BECAUSE
EVEN WITH NAME STRIPPED OUT
LOCATION INFORMATION
NOTORIOUSLY EASY TO LIKE THREE
I GOT. PARTICULARLY FOR HER IF
YOU OFFER. ESPECIALLY TRUE ONE
LOCAL FOR ME I. OVER TO. I TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN ON MOBILE
DATA. HUMAN ABILITY TRADERS ARE
HIGHLY UNIQUE RESEARCHERS FOUND
THAT ONLY FOR THE POINT WHERE
ENOUGH TO UNIQUELY IDENTIFY 95%
OF ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
INDIVIDUALS IN THE STUDY.
FINALLY UPDATED AND QUITE
IMPORTANTLY EIGHTY THREE ONE
ONE PERFECT CLARIFY HOW ACT
APPLIES TO INDIVIDUAL TRIP DATA
THAT HAS BEEN VALIDATED BY
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL. ON ITS
FACE THE LAW ALREADY CLEARLY
APPLIES TO TRIP DATA GENERATED
BY SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES
HOWEVER CLARIFICATION IS
NONETHELESS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
MULTIPLE CALIFORNIA FIT HAVE
TAKEN THE NOVEL PUT ON THAT THE
FIGHT HELLO BUT CLEAN MY-
DEFINITION. DOCU HOW DOES NOT
APPLY TO THEM. AB THREE ONE SIX
AND THE CLEAR SIGNAL TO THIRTY
THE OFFICE. ONE OF. PRIVATE AND
THEY'VE NEVER BUT THE KITCHEN
THAT THE ALL INTENDED HOW LEX
BUT APPLY INDIVIDUALTRIP JENNA
BY BUT DEVICE AND A COOK BY OF
THAT TWO THOUSAND MEASURE WE
HOPE HARD AGREE AS YOU MIGHT
THINK YOU. THANK YOU. OUR
SHOULD NO SIMPLE. IN PERSON I
DON'T SEE ANY LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. ANYBODY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL PLEASE SO. IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND IN THE
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS YOUR
POSITION. ONE MOMENT PLEASE OUR
OUR COMMON AGAIN IF YOU ARE AN-
FOR A BILL THESE AT ONE AND
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
COMIC%
COMES FROM ERIN AT EIGHT ONE
MOM. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
YOUR LINE OF OPEN. FOR A
COMMENT PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
I. JUSTIN HIGHER SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP. ARE YOU
SUPPORTER. YES SORRY- SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT A AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN QUESTION OR COMMENT. HELLO
YOUR NINE TO FIVE ON. HI FOR IN
JENSEN WITH TECH THAT- ALSO ON
THE COURT AT THIRTY THREE ONE
ONE SIX. THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
AND YOUR MIND ABOUT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN FOR COMMENT. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN ON. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NOW FOR NOW FOR THE LINE CAN
KILL A COMMA THANK YOU VERY
MUC LET'S NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALS ON THE LINE- MISS
ALL RIGHT SOUNDS FROM THE LA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION AS
WELL AS- MISTER CLOSE ART FROM
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA. ARE
YOU ON THE LINE SO. YES SO IT
AROUND CAN YOU HEAR ME YES AGO
HAD HIS RENTALS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HONORABLE LEGISLATORS AS
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST CITY TRANSPORTATION
DEPARTMENT MY FOCUS LIKE YOURS.
HAS BEEN ON MEETING CRITICAL
NEED- DURING THIS TIME- MY
EMPLOYEES ARE TRANSIT DRIVERS
AND- TRAFFIC OFFICERS AND THEY
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES AND THEY
ARE SOFT IT AND RIGHT. MIGHT
HERE WITH YOU TO GET AWAY FROM
OUR CRISIS WORK AND THE MEASURE
HOW SERIOUSLY I TAKE THIS BILL
AND HAVE SERIOUSLY WOULD AFFECT
CALIFORNIA CITY. IT WOULD
RESTRICT OUR ABILITY TO PROTECT
AND MANAGE THE STREETS AND
SIDEWALKS AND PROMOTE SAFETY
ACCESSIBILITY IN EQUITY AS
PRIVATE AND FOR PROFIT VEHICLE
OPERATE ON OUR STREETS AND
SIDEWALKS. TODAY AND
INCREASINGLY IN THE FUTURE
ACCESS TO RELIABLE ACCURATE AND
TIMELY DATA IS ESSENTIAL TO
THIS WORK. IT'S ONLY THE LAST
FEW YEARS BUT CITIES HAVE
GAINED INSIGHT INTO OUT OF IT
FOR THAT VEHICLE. USE OUR
PUBLIC STREET. FOR ARE WE
RELIED ON AGGREGATED. THAT
TURNED OUT TO BE GROWTH
MANIPULATED BY COMPANIES. THE
RESULT WAS INCREASING TRAFFIC
AND KERR CONGESTION ELEVATED CO
TWO EMISSIONS. GROWING PUBLIC
SAFETY CONCERNS REDUCE TRANSIT
YOUTH AND THE MISTREATMENT OF
WORKERS THAT REQUIRED THIS
BOBBY TO PASS. THE FIVE. THAT'S
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE WERE
PROMISED. THIS BILL FORTY TWO
AGAIN REAL COMPANIES AGGREGATED
DATA TO PROTECT BOOK AND-
SIMPLY WON'T WORK RELY AND
TIMELY IT WILL BE EVEN MORE
ESSENTIAL AT EVERYTHING HE
GRAPPLES WITH THE EFFECT OF
THIS PANDEMIC. AND HOW THEY
WILL SHAPE THE TRANSPORTATION
LANDSCAPE IMAGE WIDESPREAD
ECONOMIC DISRUPTION AND LAST X.
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. LET ME
BE CLEAR ABOUT DATA USE AND THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES WE COLLECT
AND PROTECT FROM DISCLOSURE
ONLY BASIC DATA ABOUT THE FOR
PROFIT COME. VEHICLE OPERATING
AND THE PLAY WE NOT COLLECT
PERSONAL INFORMATION ABOUT
WRITERS. IN FACT UBER AND JUMP
INFORMED ITS RIDERS ON ITS OWN
APT QUOTE. OF THE DAY WE CITIES
COLLECTED FROM YOUR PERSONAL
NOT DIVIDE. OR IF I YOU AFTER
THOUSAND CONSIDERS WERE DROPPED
ON OUR STREETS WE WANT TO PILOT
THAT BECAME THE LARGE IN THE
NAY PROVIDING NO LIVES FOR
INJURY BEFORE THAT AND THEN THE
CAT TO MANAGE THESE ALMOST
FORTY THOUSAND VEHICLES AFFECT.
WHY OR UNLOCKED THE COPY. US
AND THAT SANDERS LOCATION. THIS
SIMPLE REQUIREMENT US TO VERIFY
DATA INTEGRITY BY. THEN A DAY
AFTER THE SCOOTER IS USED THE
COMPANY SENT THE CITY TRIP DATA
NOT IN REAL TIME WE DON'T
COLLECT NAMES ADDRESSES CREDIT
INFORMATION OR ANY OTHER
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION. EVEN THOUGH THE
DATA RECEIVED BASIC WE KEEP IT
HIGHLY SECURE ENCRYPTED IF
SOMEBODY WERE ABLE TO LEGALLY
ACCESS ARE BROUGHT INCREASE
DATA. HACK OTHER SOURCES
INCLUDING OUTSIDE CITY OF LA
DATABASES TO COBBLE TOGETHER AN
INDIVIDUAL'S IDENTITY. AND FOR
THOSE WHO BELIEVE CITIES WITH
MISUSED DATA AFTER WHO SHOULD
STOP COLLECTING PARKING TICKET
REVENUES OF PROCESSING PERMIT.
FOR KERR DESIGNATIONS AND SPEED
HOW. PROPERTIES THAT WE MUCH
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION AND ASK FROM
ABILITY COMPANIES TODAY. THE
DATA WE COLLECTED NOT A TOOL
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT IT WOULD
ONLY BE ACCESSIBLE WITH A
SUBPOENA OR WARRANT THE DATA WE
HAVE A VALUE TO ONE FORCED THE
COMPANY'S EXTENSIVE DATA IS
WHAT IS USED CALL NOT OURS.
THIS DATA IS NOT AT ALL USEFUL
FOR CONTACT TRACING THE WIRES
THE FULL TRACK PATTERN THE
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL THROUGHOUT
THE DAY ACTIVE. ON THE PRODUCT
THE CASE STATE THE DOCTOR SAID
I RECEIVED FUNDAMENTAL
OBSERVING STATUS CHANGES TO THE
PUBLIC. YEAH BUT WHAT. BUT THAT
HAS NO I DO THEFT INFORMATION
AND CAN ONLY IN PUBLIC HEALTH
THE OFFICIALS SHORT TRIP. THAT
DIVIDE X. MADE AT LEAST TWENTY
HOURS A- THAT'S WHY COUNTRIES
THAT EMPLOYMENT CONTRACT
TRACING HIS COMMUNICATION
DEVICE DATA FROM MOBILE PHONES
NOT RENTED SCOOTER DATA. MARK
FOUNDER PERSONALLY OWNED
IDENTITY SPECIFIC KERRIGAN
POCKET TO PURSUE THROUGHOUT THE
DAY THE ARGUMENT USED BY
HEARING ITEM ARE BASED ON A-
AND- BY. SIGNIFICANT
TRANSFERRED POLICY. FOR
CONSIDERATION BY POLICY
COMMITTEE THAT DELIBERATE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. THE
TIMING OF THE LEGISLATION ALSO
UNDERMINE ONGOING WORK BY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND MULTIPLE STATE
AGENCY. FOR NEARLY TWO YEARS
WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT UP WITH
DATA FROM TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LAURA FRIEDMAN ABOUT AN A. B.
ELEVEN TWELVE. THIS BILL WOULD
CODIFY DATA DEFINITIONS THAT
ARE STILL BEING DISCUSSED.
WHAT'S WORSE IT EXPANDS THEM TO
TNC AN AV. FOR BOTH WHICH IS
THAT THE P. C. AND BMG. ARE
DEVELOPING REGULATIONS. MUCH
REMAINS TO BE LEARNED ABOUT
AUTOMATED VEHICLES OR DRONES
ARE OTHER YET TO BE A GRADUATE.
BUT YOU KNOW THEY HAVE. CON FOR
EMPLOYEE IN THIS AND- A THREE
ONCE WHAT PLACE REGULATORS ON
THE SIDELINES AGAIN. A
SPECTATOR TO INNOVATION RATHER
THAN PARTICIPANTS AND THAT. IF
PASSED THIS BILL WOULD YOUR
CITY'S ABILITY TO MANAGE THE
PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY REDUCING
THE AVAILABILITY OF
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS UNDER
YEARS OF DELIBERATION
REGULATORY DESIGN. AND
PREMATURELY RESTRICT EFFECTIVE
REGULATION OF FUTURE MODE. THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES THEREFORE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THE
NEXT SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION.
WELL HELLO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS. MY NAME IS KYLE
CODES ARE ON THE SENIOR
TRANSPORTATION PLANNER- THE
CITY SANTA MONICA AND I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS THE CITY'S STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A. B. THIRTY ONE
SIXTEEN AS IT WOULD UNDERMINE
OUR EXISTING SHARED MOBILITY
PILOT PROGRAM WHICH CURRENTLY
BEST SERVES THE INTEREST OF OUR
CITY AND ITS RESIDENTS THE
DATED ISSUE IN THE BILL IS NOT
CLOSER TO THE CITY TO
EFFECTIVELY REGULATE THE PUBLIC
RIGHT OF WAY. CITY NEED TOOLS
CAN MEET PUBLIC NEEDS AND
EXPECTATIONS. IN ITS CRRENT
FORM. AB THIRTY ONE SIXTEEN TO
SEVERELY LIMIT THESE TOOLS WE
ALSO BELIEVE IT IS PREMATURE
BILL AT THAT SITE AS CITY LIKE
ARE THERE STILL ARE PILOT
PROGRAM PHASE OF REGULATION AND
IS BILLS ALSO INTERCEDE
INTERCEDES AND ONGOING
DELIBERATIONS ON AB ELEVEN
TWELVE BROUGHT TO THE ASSEMBLY
BY. NUMBER FRIEDMAN- WHICH IS
ANOTHER BILL THE DEALING
DIRECTLY WITH THE SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE ISSUES. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AFTER THE
REGULAR THE LAUNCH OF SHEM
ABILITY TO BUY SANTA MONICA
RATHER THAN BANDIT DEVICES LIKE
MANY OTHER CITIES HAD DONE. WE
MOVE QUICKLY TO CREATE POWERFUL
REGULATIONS THAT ENABLE THE USE
OF THE VICES WHILE ADJUSTING
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC SAFETY
ACCEPTABILITY. AND EQUITY
CONCERNS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
TODAY ALL FOUR OF THE PERMITTED
OPERATORS IN SANTA MONICA HAVE
COMPLIED WITH THE DATA
REQUIREMENTS OF OUR PILOT
PROGRAM. THE DATA THAT THE
OPERATORS PROVIDE TO THE CITY
IS CRITICAL TO OUR FUNCTIONS AS
REGULATORS PLANNERS AND
MANAGERS OF THE PUBLIC RIGHT OF
WAY. DATA IS NOT IN REAL TIME
AND IT CONTAINS NO CONSUMER
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION. AS IT
IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTEEN WOULD FUNDAMENTALLY
REMOVE THE CITY'S ABILITY TO
MEANINGFULLY REGULATE CHAIRED
MOBILITY OPERATORS BY
PROHIBITING THE CITY FROM
COLLECTING TRIP DATA IT IS
VITAL THAT WE MONITOR AND FORCE
AND UNDERSTAND SURE MOBILITY
USE WITHIN THE CITY. THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE CITY LIKE MONICA
EITHER ALLOW THE INDUSTRY TO
SELF REGULATE OR BAN OPERATIONS
OF THESE TYPES OF SERVICES
ALTOGETHER. THIS IS THE CHOICE
WE SHOULD NOT BE FORCED TO
MAKE. OUR EXPERIENCE HAS TAUGHT
US THE BY WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SHARED
MOBILITY OPERATORS WE CAN
DEVELOP PROTOCOLS THAT WE
PROTECT CONSUMER PRIVACY WHILE
ENABLING US TO GET THE DATA WE
NEED TO EFFECTIVELY REGULATE
THE INDUSTRY USE OF THE PUBLIC
RIGHT OF WAY. AB THIRTY ONE SIX
IN UNDER THESE EFFORTS TO DATE
AND FOR THAT REASON THE CITY
SANTA MONICA IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB THIRTY ONE SIXTEEN
THANK. THANK YOU ARE THERE
OTHER SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY OUR
LOOKS THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK- MISTER ONE FOR
PRESENTING THE BILL I'M A PROUD
JOIN AUTHOR OF THE BILL- AND-
THE REASON WHY I THINK THIS
BILL. I THINK INDIVIDUAL
LOCALIZED ANNA AND LOCATION
DATA IS REALLY SENSITIVE AND
MUST BE PROTECTED AT ALL COSTS
AND I THINK THIS BILL STRIKES
THE RIGHT BALANCE OF- ALLOWING
ACCESS TO ANONYMIZE DATA WHILE
STILL SAFEGUARDING INSIDE IN A
FULL I DON'T IDENTIFY TRIPPED
OUT OF SO- LOOK. WORK WHEN FOR
THE DON'T HAVE. IS THERE. ARE
COMMON GO AHEAD. YEAH YEAH
RIGHT THE NUMBER OF THE. THE
OTHER AS A ONCE. THERE I WAS A
CHAIR. WE WERE. MAC I THANK YOU
SO MEMBER OR WENT INTRODUCING
THIS BILL- I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS- AS WE VOTE ON
STATEWIDE LAWS WE FIRST
REPRESENTED THE DISTRICTS THAT
WE COME FROM AND I REPRESENT
LAWCENTER AS THE LARGE SITTING
CALIFORNIA WITH ROBUST
TRANSPORTATION PLAN IN OUR AN
OLD ON THE PHONE FOR HER
TESTIMONY I HAVE CONCERNS WITH
WELL IN A FORM WHICH PUT CITIES
BUT- AND STUFF FOR. THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO WRITE. A REALLY AS
A MATTER OF TRUST AND ALLOWING
FOR PROFIT COMPANIES TO
AGGREGATE DATA BEFORE PROVIDING
IT TO THE REGULATORS PROVIDES
IN MY OPINION A CLEARANCE
CENTER. ELATION ACRONYM CAN
ASSIST UNTIL FOR BOTH
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE AND
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING BECAUSE
THESE DECISIONS ARE ONLY A
SMART THE DATA THAT THEY RELY
ON. DIRECT ACCESS TO DEVICE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION EQUIPS
REGULATORS WITH THE TOOLS TO
MANAGE THE RIGHT WAY. WHY
SHOULD WE PREVENT CITIES FROM
GETTING A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
DATA IT THIS ALLOWS THEM TO
VERIFY. THE ACCURACY AND
VALIDITY OF THE INFORMATION THE
COMPANIES ARE PROVIDING.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE I UNDERSTAND
THIS BILL AIMS TO GOVERN DATA
PRIVACY IT DIRECTLY ADDRESSES
STOCK WITH MOBILITY
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
AND OTHER FUTURE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION. IT SEEMS HERE
THAT THE IMPACTS OF THIS BILL
WOULD BE SUBSTANTIAL. PETITION
APARTMENT ACOSTA ST OF CALIPERS
LARGEST CITIES LOS ANGELES SAN
JOSE AND I'M FRANCISCO OUT OF
THE THESE ARE TOP THREE. OUT OF
FIVE. THE ALL IN OPPOSITION I'M
NOT SURE I'M CONVINCED THAT
THIS BILL QUALIFIES TO BE HEARD
THIS SESSION BASED ON THE
ARGUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN SET
TODAY BUT IF WE INSIST ON
MOVING FORWARD I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE THIS BILL HEARD IN
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AS
WELL FOR THE AND I WILL BE.
FROM THIS. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- ONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SIDE I'LL JUST
MAKE A COUPLE OF QUICK
STATEMENTS THIS IS- THIS WAS
REALLY AN ISSUE OF WHETHER CAL
LACK THE OF ALSO A RELATED TO
OTHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
BEYOND JUST OF POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE THIS IS-
NUMEROUS TIMES LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL HAS SAID THAT YES IT'S-
BLACK BUT IS A REAL TO OTHER
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. AND THERE
ARE THREE ONE YOU HAVE THAT IN
STATION THE CHIU AND THE FS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND AS MS
CORBIN MISTER CALLAHAN IS WICKS
SAID THE MOST SENSITIVE
INFORMATION THAT THERE IS OR
AMONG SENSITIVE INFORMATION
THAT THERE IS YOUR LOCATION
DATA FOR THIS IS TO SAY YOU
CANNOT TRACK AND IT WELL ON
CASE. AS THAT WOULD WITH
PATIENT AND NO PAYMENT IN JAIL.
YOU TRACK LOCATION DAY ALL THE
WAY TO SOMEBODY HOME SO I THINK
THIS- WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. AGAIN AND THEY WILL
HAVE ACCESS DE IDENTIFIED
INFORMATION AND AGGREGATE
INFORMATION THE ISSUE THAT MS
CARILLO BRINGS IT I THINK IS AN
ACCURATE ONE. YEAH I MEAN IS A
GOOD. TO MAKE SURE THAT. IT IS
ACCURATE. BUT BEING. TO PROVIDE.
A IN. THAT IS OF THAT IS ABLE
TO TRACK INDIVIDUAL- TRIP DATA
I THINK IS OF ANTI PRIVACY AND
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST STATES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY THERE ARE
TWO MORE PEOPLE ON THE PHONE. I
DO WE NEED THE- GO GET THEM ON.
I OKAY. ALL RIGHT SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION IS IT. I KNOW WOULD
BE THAT'S RIGHT FOR. IS THERE
ONE ARE YOU IN CONTACT WITH.
RIGHT. MAYBE WE- YEAH. HE WAS
ABOUT WERE THE- WITH THE U. POP.
ALRIGHT ALL. ALL RIGHT I'M TOLD
THAT THE- TWO REMAINING
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION ALREADY.
NOW I'M TOLD THAT THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO SPEAK AFTER ALL. THANK
YOU READY TO THAT. WE HAVE A
MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND AND
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. NOW
KILEY. AYE KILEY AYE BARRICADE
HAND. OKAY HAND I BERMAN. AND I
MEDINA- MEDINA I CARILLO.
MULLIN GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER HI-
WHEN I IRWIN HI OBERNOLTE. SIX
NINE SIX NINE. THE BILL IS OUT-
I THINK THAT THE ONLY REMAINING
BILLS ARE- THE CHAIRS SO- HE IS
ASSURED ME TO BE BACK SHORTLY
SO WE'LL JUST HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL THEN. WHAT WE DO. THE
MANAGEMENT ALL FIVE OF THEM OR
YOU KNOW AND SEE OF THE- AND
THEN- ACOSTA WITH REGARD. TO A
ARE THERE THE JUST BEINGS. MUCH
THAT I RIGHT. ALL. OKAY YEAH
THE- YEAH YEAH YEAH. THIS IS
NOT. I NOTICED COOL. WE HAVE
SOMETHING. AND WE'RE I. THAT
YEAH. YEAH YEAH. YEAH. YEAH.
YEAH. YEAH YEAH WELL OVER A
YEAR YEAH. RIGHT OR- YEAH.
RIGHT RIGHT OFF OUR. BUT IT'S A
LITTLE BIT. IT'S STILL. OR IS
SCHOOL AND ONE LOOKS DIFFERENT
TURNED INTO A WITNESS MICHAEL
BUT THERE IS.
BUYERS AN
EXPONENTIAL RATE FROM ASSISTING
SMARTPHONE USERS IN UNLOCKING
THEIR PHONES TO ITS USE IN
RETAIL STORES CASINOS CONCERTS
IN AIRPORTS F. R. T. SERVES THE
PURPOSE OF IDENTIFYING PEOPLE
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS. F.
FORTY ALSO PROVIDES LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH A TOOL TO
ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY AS
EVIDENCED BY ITS RECENT USE TO
IDENTIFY THIS IS THE KILLER IN
NEW ORLEANS CAPITAL BECAUSE
THAT MASS SHOOTING WERE DIE.
WHAT OTHER EFFORTS TO FIND
<c.green>HILDREN AND VICTIMS OF HUMAN</c>
TRAFFICKING. MOST RECENTLY
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE GLOBE
ARE TURNING KNOWLEDGE G. AN
EFFORT TO SAVE LIVES ADMITS.
THREAT POSED BY COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. FORTY IS NO EXCEPTION.
TECH COMPANIES IN THE UNITED
STATES ARE REPORTEDLY IN TALKS
WITH THE US GOVERNMENT TO USE
THE DATA A GATHERING AND DATA
LOOKING TOWARDS TO TRACK VIRUS
TRANSMISSION TREATMENTS
INCLUDING CLEAR VIEW THE I A
CONTROVERSY ALL COMPANY THAT
RECENTLY MADE HEADLINES FOR
ASSEMBLING A DATABASE OF MORE
THAN THREE BILLION. IS
COLLECTED THE INTERNET AND MADE
IT DATA AVAILABLE FORCE MEN ARE
AND PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS AROUND
THE COUNTRY. THE REPORT BY U.
S. NEWS HIGHLIGHTS THE USE OF
F. R. T. LIKE CLEAR VIEW A AYE
TO AND I QUOTE IDENTIFY ANYONE
WHO'S BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THE
INFECTED PERSON. SIMILAR TO HOW
TECH COMPANIES RESPONDED IN THE
U. S. AFTER NINE ELEVEN WITH
THE PASSING THE PATRIOTIC ACT
PAVING WAY TO MASS
SURVEILLANCE. AS WE HIT BUT AS
WE SIT HERE TODAY DO WE WANT TO
SIT IDLY BY AND LET THIS HAPPEN
AGAIN. WITHOUT DEMANDING A
TRADE CURRENCY ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT. LET'S THINK ABOUT IT.
AN OTHER EXAMPLE HOW BIOMETRIC
TECHNOLOGY IS IN EVOLVING
DURING THIS COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IS ITS USE AS A
SCREENING SYSTEM. IT WAS
RECENTLY REPORTED THAT A
SECURITY COMPANY WHOSE
TECHNOLOGY TO TEXT GUNS IS NOW
OFFERING A SCREEN SYSTEM
EQUIPPED WITH THERMAL CAMERAS.
TO DETECT FEVERS AND ALERT
SURROUNDING CUSTOMERS OF
SOMEONE POTENTIALLY CARRYING
CORONA VIRUS. A PRODUCT IT IS
PITCHING TO GROW RESTORE
HOSPITALS VOTING LOCATIONS IN
DEPLOYING AT GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AIRPORTS AND ALSO
FOUGHT OF FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
COMPANIES. WHICH DEFINITELY FOR
SEAT IS BECOMING A AN
ALTERNATIVE TO TECHNOLOGIES
THAT RELY ON TOUCH BISTRO
SENSORS. WHAT THIS SAYS TO ME
IS THAT FACIAL RECOGNITION
SYSTEMS ARE ALREADY IN USE AND
CONTINUOUSLY DEPLOYED. THEY'RE
ALSO CREDITED KERR- CREDIBLE
CONCERNS REGARDING THE ACCURACY
OF A FAR T. SYSTEMS ON SOME
RACIAL OR ETHNIC GROUPS AND
SEVERAL STUDIES HAVE UNCOVERED
BIASES IN FACE RECOGNITION
ALGORITHM. IN IN FACT THAT WAS
ONE OF THE TWENTY SIX
LEGISLATORS SO MISS IDENTIFY A
BY A. F. R. T. SYSTEM WITH A
MUG SHOT IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
ACT IS THAT WHILE I FOUR T. OFF
SOME BENEFITS TO SOCIETY ITS
USE ALSO COMES WITH SERIOUS
CHALLENGES THAT MERIT OUR
SCRUTINY. BECAUSE OF THESE
CONCERNS THE LEGISLATURE MUST
REGULATE THE COMPLETE USE OF F.
R. T. TO MINIMIZE AND YOU LOOK
AT THE PRICE CONSISTS. IS
CANCER AND- COMMUNITY. WE
RECENTLY HAD A HEARING IN
CALIFORNIA ON THE TOPIC AT THE
REQUEST OF SOME OF THE GROUPS
IN OPPOSITION- AND IT HERE TEN
OTHER STATES HAVE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD REGULATE
BAND OR STUDY FACIAL
RECOGNITION SYSTEMS ON MARCH
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY A
WASHINGTON STATE BECAME THE
FIRST STATE NATION TO REGULATE
COMPREHENSIVE. R. T. BY IN
AGENCIES. TIME HAS COME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ESTABLISH A
ROBUST FRT LAW THAT APPLIES
EQUALLY ACROSS THE BOARD IN ITS
USE BY BUSINESSES AS WELL AS-
PUBLIC ENTITIES AND STRIKES A
BALANCE BETWEEN ITS APPLICATION
AND HUMAN RIGHTS ARE AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY ONE INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY THEY OUGHT TO
ESTABLISH LIMITS ON THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY.
BY COMMERCIAL STATE AND LOCAL
PUBLIC ENTITIES WHILE
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
CONSUMERS RELATING TO
COLLECTION AND THE USE OF THEIR
IMAGE OR FACIAL COMPLETES. A
CIVIC LEADER. INDEPENDENT TEST
OF THOSE FACIAL RECOGNITION
SERVICES FOR ACCURACY AND
UNFAIR PERFORMANCE DIFFERENCES
ACROSS SUBPOPULATIONS OR
MEETING THE RELEVANT FACIAL
RECOGNITION VENDOR TELL US THAT%
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
STANDARDS AND TECHNOLOGY
PERFORMS. AND THAT IS THE NEXT
STANDARD THOUGH WHICH IS. WHAT
PEOPLE CALL THE GOLD STANDARD.
IT WOULD REQUIRE ALSO A
CONSPICUOUS IN CONTEXTUAL E.
APPROACH NOTICE WHEN DEPLOYING
FACIAL RECOGNITION SIR IN THE
PHYSICS. OPEN TO THE PUBLIC
THAT INCLUDE SPECIFIC ELEMENTS
AND CONSENT FROM THE INDIVIDUAL
BEFORE ENROLLING THEIR MH OR
FACIAL TEMPLATE WOULD LIMITED
EXCEPT- EXCEPTIONS FOR SCRUTINY
OR SAFETY PURPOSE. I TO THAT
SERIOUS CRIMINAL OFFENSE AND
REQUIRING PROPER BECAUSE AS
WELL. IT ALSO PROHIBITS DENYING
ACCESS OR SERVICE ON THE BASIS
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL HOUSE
EXERCISED THEIR RIGHT. TO
WITHHOLD CONSENT UNLESS IT IS
DIRECTLY NECESSARY FOR THE
PROVISION OF THE SERVICE. IT
ALSO REQUIRES A PROSSER SIR. OR
TO DISCRIMINATE UNDER FEDERAL
OR STATE LAW AGAINST AN
INDIVIDUAL OR GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS. IT ALSO REQUIRES
MEANINGFUL HUMAN REVIEW WHEN
USING A FACIAL RECOGNITION
SERVICE TO MAKE DECISIONS THAT
PRODUCED LEGAL AFFECTS. OR
SIMILARLY SIGNIFICANT EFFECTS
CONCERNING INDIVIDUALS WHICH
INCLUDE DENIAL OF CONSEQUENTIAL
SERVICES OR SUPPORTS SUCH AS
FINANCIAL AND LENDING SERVICES
HOUSING. INSURANCE EDUCATION
ENROLLMENT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND ACCESS TO
BASIC NECESSITIES OR THAT
IMPACTS CIVIL RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUALS IN FACT UNDER THE
NEW DEFINITION THE TRAIN
INDIVIDUALS DOING THE OVERSIGHT
WOULD ULTIMATELY BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAKING DECISIONS. BASED IN
WHOLE OR IN PART ON THE OUTPUT
OF THE FACIAL RECOGNITION
SERVICE IT ALSO GRANTS RIGHT TO
INDIVIDUALS TO FALL AS- ONE TO
CONFIRM WHETHER. THEY'RE MH
OFFICIAL TEMPLATE HUSBAND AND
ROLE IN THE FACIAL RECOGNITION
SERVICE. TO CORRECT OR
CHALLENGING DECISION TO ENROLL
THEIR IN IMAGE OR FACIAL
TEMPLATE OR SECURITY OR SAFETY
PURPOSE THREE TO HAVE THEIR IN
ROLLED IMAGE OF FACIAL TEMPLATE
THE LEADER. WITH LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS AND FOR TO WITHDRAW
CONSENT TO ENROLL THEIR IMAGE
OR FACIAL TEMPLATE IN OFFICIAL
RECOGNITION SERVICE. I FINALLY
THIS BILL IMPOSES ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS ON AGENCIES
DEFINED A STATE OR LOCAL PUBLIC
ENTITIES WHICH USE OR INTENT TO
DO BOB PROCURE OR USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION SERVICES FOR
EXAMPLE WOULD REQUIRE AS AN AGE
TO PRODUCE. AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT REGARDING THE USE OF DOT
SYSTEM AND ALSO TO COMMUNICATE
THAT REPORT TO THE PUBLIC AT
LEAST NINETY DAYS PRIOR TO
EMPLOYING THE SERVICE WHILE
ALLOWING FOR A REVIEW AND
COMMENT. FOR ANALYZING AND THE
RIVER. SO PERHAPS PROHIBITS THE
AGING FROM USING AN AGENCY FROM
YOU CHAU RECOGNITION SERVICE IN
QUE IN ON TO VETERANS UNLESS.
CERTAIN STRINGENT REQUIRE AND-
ARE MET RELATING TO A LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATION OF A
SERIOUS CRIMINAL OFFENSE AS
DEFINED IN LAW. OR FROM
GENERALLY APPLYING OFFICIAL
RECOGNITION SERVICE TO AN
INDIVIDUAL BASED ON THEIR
RELIGIOUS POLITICAL VIEW OR
ACTIVITIES BUT THIS PATIENT IN
A LAWFUL EVENT OR OTHER
PERCEIVED RACE ETHNICITY
CITIZENSHIP PLACE OF ORIGIN AGE
DISABILITY GENDER. IDENTITY
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR OTHER
CHARACTERISTICS PROTECTED BY
LAW INCLUDING TO CREATE A
RECORD OF AN INDIVIDUAL
EXERCISING THEIR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT. ALTHOUGH
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE DOES THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR TO
CONDUCT BY ANNUALLY AN
INDEPENDENT AUDIT OF STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES DEPLOYING FACIAL
RECOGNITION SERVICES. TO
EVALUATE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS- TITLE AND
FINALLY VIOLATIONS OF THIS-
BILL WOULD BE SUBJECT TO CIVIL
PENALTIES OF NO MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
FOR EACH VIOLATION WERE MORE
THAN SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED FOR
EACH INTENTIONAL VIOLATION OF
RECOVER ONLY IN AN ACTION
BROUGHT BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AS SPECIFIED. IN CLOSING US
OFFICIAL RECOGNITION SERVICES
INCREASING USED BY BUSINESSES
AND PUBLIC ENTITIES WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE DOING SO
WITH TRANSPARENT AND ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT. WOULD DOT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND- THANK YOU OUT WE
HAVE A SPEAKER IN SUPPORT ON
THE LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MY NAME IS ARION HARKINS
I AM THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY WITH MICROSOFT.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU IN
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. WE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
ONE. BUT IT WOULD IMPOSE MUCH
NEEDED REGULATION ON BOTH THE
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SECTORS USE
AND DEVELOPMENT OF FACE
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY. WE'VE
SEEN. RAPID ADVANCES IN
WIDESPREAD DEPLOYMENT IN YOU
THE BEST A RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY ALL AROUND US- IN
ACROSS SOCIETY OVER THE PAST
DECADE. IN THE TECHNOLOGY IS
PROVIDING A WIDE RANGE OF
BENEFITS ACROSS SOCIETY. BUT
IT'S ALSO LARGELY UNREGULATED
TODAY. THERE ARE IN EFFECT BUT
FEW IF ANY RULES IN PLACE.
GOVERNING IT DEVELOPMENT IN YOU
AND IT POSES. A THREAT TO
DEMOCRATIC FREEDOMS TO PRIVACY
AND CIVIL LIBERTIES. IT POSES
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT-
INACCURACIES BY CITIES IN
DISCRIMINATION. CONCERNS THAT
ARE HEIGHTENED FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND FOR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. OUR VIEW A CAN
RACE TO THE BOTTOM IN AN
UNREGULATED MARKET PLACE
BENEFITS NO ONE. ABOVE ALL FACE
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY SHOULD
NOT BE YOU CAN MASS
SURVEILLANCE OF THE POPULATION.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN
CALLING FOR LAWS TO REGULATE
PAYS A RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
IN THE SUMMER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. IN OUR VIEW AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY ONE WOULD REPRESENT A
SUBSTANTIAL STEP FORWARD IT
WOULD IT WOULD IMPOSE
RESTRICTIONS THAT DO NOT EXIST
IN LAW TODAY. IT WOULD REGULATE
THE PRIVATE SECTOR BY AMONG
OTHER THINGS ADDRESSING
CONCERNS OF BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION BY REQUIRING
COMPANIES TO BE TRANSPARENT.
BUT TAKEN TO TASK THEIR
TECHNOLOGIES FOR BY IT THE END
DISCRIMINATION BUT TO REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO ENABLE INDEPENDENT
THIRD PARTIES TO TEST TAKE OUT
THE TECHNOLOGY PROVIDE
DISCRIMINATION. BUT TO REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO TAKE ACTION TO
ADDRESS AN INACCURACY THERE BY
THE THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
IN THEIR TECHNOLOGY. IT WOULD
AND COMPANIES FROM IN ROLLING
CONSUMERS PERSONAL DATA IN A
FACE TO RECOGNITION SYSTEM
WITHOUT OBTAINING CONSENT- OR
IN SOME LIMITED. CIRCUMSTANCES
FOR SECURITY OR SAFETY
PURPOSES. IT WOULD BAN THE USE
OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
DECISIONS ABOUT- CONSUMER.
WITHOUT INSURANCE THE THIS IS
THE I MEAN THANK YOU YOU. BUT
ALSO IMPOSE MY NEEDED. ON THE
GOV YOU OF THE TECHNOLOGY. JUST
THE HIGHLIGHT A FEW IT WOULD
REQUIRE STRONG OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE
GOVERNMENT VIEWED THE PHASER
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY. BY
REQUIRING AMONG OTHER THINGS UP
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT-
BEFORE AGENCIES WOULD YOU THE
TECHNOLOGY IT WOULD REQUIRE
GREATER COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION. BEFORE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES DECIDE TO
PROCURE OR ADOPTED TECHNOLOGY
BY AMONG OTHER THINGS REQUIRED
PUBLIC NOTICE AND COMMENT
PERIODS BEFORE AGENCIES SECURE
THE TECHNOLOGY- IT WOULD SET AN
APPROPRIATELY HIGH BAR ON THE
USE OF THE TECHNOLOGY BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BUT BEING THAT YOU
USE FOR ONGOING SURVEILLANCE
UNLESS ONE FOURTH AND OBTAINED
A WARRANT FOR EXIGENT
CIRCUMSTANCES EXIST. IN FINAL
IT WOULD APPROPRIATELY BANNED
THE USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY- BOND POINT ON
CONSUMERS. BASED ON THEIR FIRST
AMENDMENT ACTIVITIES OR BASED
ON THEIR MEMBERSHIP IN A
PROTECTED CLASS. SO WE APPLAUD
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
EFFORT TO TACKLE THESE ISSUES-
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND FRANKLY ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. LAWMAKERS
ADVOCATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
GOVERNMENT AND INDUSTRY TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND MOVE
THE- LEGISLATION BOARD THANK
YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO TRY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER HARKINS OTHER OTHER
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT ON THE LINE.
I HEARING NO OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT WILL MOVE TO SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION- STARTING WITH
MISTER WARD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IS YOUR CHAIR
THIS VICE CHAIR. MY NAME IS
GRANT WARD THEM- IN HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY SIX ONE. I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF C. BUT SAM
YOU KNOW COUNTY SHERIFF'S
EMPLOYEE BENEFITS ASSOCIATION
ALSO SERVED AS THE- BOARD
APPOINTED PRESIDENT OF SCALE
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE LAW ENFORCEMENT I SIT
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS. OF
CC ONLY A THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION LAW ENFORCEMENT AS
WELL AS POOR I CAN THE PEACE
OFFICERS RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA- SO. IN MY OVER
TWENTY TWO YEARS AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER I'VE HAD
THE OPTION YOU WORK NUMEROUS
DIFFERENT ASSIGNMENTS AND ONE
OF THOSE ASSIGNMENTS WAS AS A
DETECTIVE IN CHARGE OF
RESEARCHING IN ASSESSING
BIOMETRIC TECHNOLOGIES. FOR SAM
YOU KNOW COUNTY IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. NOW THAT YOU KNOW WHO I
AM. I'D FIRST LIKE TO. POINT
OUT HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO DEBT
TO DEDICATE TIME AND RESOURCES
TO OPPOSE LEGISLATION IS
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT DURING THIS CURRENT
CRISIS. AT THE TIME WHEN OUR
FULL FOCUS IS ON IS ON THE
SHRINK OUR COMMUNITIES. AND IN
MY CASE MY MEMBERS ARE SAFE AND
LOOKED AFTER DURING THIS
PANDEMIC IT UPSETS ME TO KNOW
THE BILL'S LIKE THIS THAT
HINDER ABILITY TO DO OUR JOBS.
BILL BEING PUSHED FORWARD. WE
UNDERSTAND AND AGREE FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGIES SHOULD
BE REGULATED. ALL TECHNOLOGIES
SHOULD BE WATCHED OVER. AND
ENSURE OUR PERSONAL FREEDOMS
AND PRIVACY NGUYEN REASONABLY
EXPECTED IS PROTECTED. WE
SHOULD BE WORKING TOWARDS
SOLUTIONS. I WOULD LOVE TO GO
INTO DETAIL REGARDING ISSUES
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED IN AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE BUT FOR
THE PURPOSES THIS HEARING- I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT TO MAJOR FLAW.
THE EXTREME LIMITATION IS ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATORS.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THE TOOL TO
ONLY BE USED WHILE MESSI
GETTING SERIOUS FELONY CRIMES.
HOWEVER THE MOST COMMON TYPES
OF CRIMES THAT ARE- ACTUALLY
USEFUL PROVISION RECOGNITION
ARE COMPLETELY PROHIBITED. IT'S
CRIMES LIKE IDENTITY THEFT
CHECK FRAUD CREDIT CARD FRAUD
RETAIL THEFT AND BURGLARY THE
CONSISTENTLY HAVE USABLE FACIAL
RECOGNITION FROM SURVEILLANCE
VIDEO FOOTAGE AND IN THIS STATE
THOSE CRIMES ARE VERY RARELY
DEEMS SELLING. A MAJOR ISSUE TO
DO WITH MEN CHEATING A PURGE OF
IMAGE TEMPLATES MORE THAN THREE
YEARS OLD. THE IMAGES LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES USED TO
COMPARE AGAINST. THE PROBE
IMAGE ARE BOOKING PHOTOS THERE
ARE NO EXPECTATIONS TO PRIVACY
WHEN BOOKED INTO JAIL IN FACT
FINGERPRINTING AND
PHOTOGRAPHING. TIRED NEVER A
PERFECT TIME TO ENROLL A PERSON
INTO A DATABASE THEN LOOKING.
BY THE END OF THAT PROCESS- WE
KNOW EXACTLY WHO THAT PERSON IS
AND IF THE PERSON IS NEVER BEEN
ARRESTED BEFORE THE FIRST
PROCESS ENSURES THE SAME VISUAL
CAN BE AGAIN IDENTIFIED IN
FUTURE REGARDLESS OF WHAT NAME
OR INFORMATION THEY PROVIDE
SOME SUBSEQUENT CONTACTS ONE
FOR SOME. PERSON THIS FEATURE.
TO HELP PROVIDE IN GATED LEAVES
WHICH HOPEFULLY RESULT IN
SOLVING CRIMES IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE A POSITIVE
IDENTIFICATION. AS A CANDIDATE
LIST OF PEOPLE WITH SIMILAR A
SIMILAR FACIAL GEOMETRY. WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ACTUAL CASE SUMMARIES OR
ARRANGE A DEMONSTRATION OF HOW
LAW ENFORCEMENT USES THE TECH.
IS ACTUALLY FIVE IS ACTUALLY
USE OR DALY INVESTIGATIVE
PROCESS IT'S VASTLY DIFFERENT
THAN HOW HOLLYWOOD DEPICTS. SO
IN CONCLUSION WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT THIS COMMITTEE HOLD
OFF ON THAT MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD ALTHOUGH WE ADAMANTLY
OF BILLS CURRENTLY WRITTEN WE
DO BELIEVE IT CAN BE A MINUTE.
PUSHES IN INTENT AND- WE BET.
DO NOT SAID ONE OF ALONE FOR
TOOLS FIFTEEN YEARS WITH THAT
I'LL BE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS HOW WE ACTUALLY USE
THE TECHNOLOGY. YOU ANOTHER
DESIGNATED SPEAKER IN
OPPOSITION JOINING US BY PHONE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TO MEET
WITH MINE AND THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS COORDINATOR FOR THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS AND HAVE THE KOBE
AREA OFFICE. I'M SPEAKING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE COLD IN A P.
FIVE RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS AND
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY SIX. THE
MEMBER SHALL SURE. ALICIA THE
ONLY A TWENTY TWO SIXTY REMAIN
DANGER PERMISSIVE OFFICIAL
RECORD AND THE RED OF THE TOP
KELP PARTICULARLY TO EMIGRATE
FULL OF. FIFTY FIVE THE GROUP'S
OPPOSED BILL AND CONSIDER IT A
THREAT TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES PROMINENT
HEALTH EXPERTS ALSO OPPOSE THIS
BILL STATING THERE'S NO PUBLIC
HELPED APPLICATION. ACTUAL
WRECKING AND OF THE USHERED IN
BY THE BILL THIS BILL
LEGITIMIZES THE NON CONSENSUAL
USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION BY
COMPANIES AND GOVERNMENTS AND
THE CREATION OF FAITH DATABASES
BUT IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT HAS ALREADY SOUGHT
TO EXPLOIT ANOTHER STATE. CAN
STILL CREE LEGAL FIGHT FOR YOU
THING FISH RECOGNITION. NEED
AND DENY ESSENTIAL SERVICES
SUCH AS ACT TO EMPLOYMENT OR
CARE WE SHOULD NOT BE MAKING
CANNOT THANKS THE HARD. DISK.
HELP STATE OR OPPOSITION IT THE
BILL WELL PHAM HAVE BY THE
IMPACTED BY THE NINETY AND
OTHER PEOPLE IN THE AND OTHER
MARCH PEOPLE THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD NOT PASS LEGISLATION
THAT. THE NATIONAL HARSHER
ASIAN. AMERICAN MORE. REMEMBER
THE LONG LASTING THEIR CHOICES
MADE DURING TIMES OF CRISIS
AFTER NINE ELEVEN OUR
GOVERNMENT LEADERS CHAU TO
LEGITIMIZE SURVEILLANCE AND
DISCRIMINATION OVER CARE AND
COMMUNITY CREATING DAMAGE THAT
WOULD HELP RECOVERING FROM
TWENTY YEARS LATER. ASK YOU TO
AVOID REPEATING THAT HISTORY
WITH AB TWENTY ONE RESPECTFULLY
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
OF FIFTY FIVE THE BILL RIGHT-ORGANIZATIONS I ASKED THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU.
YOU ARE THERE OTHER SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE. OR HERE
I THINK WE'LL START WITH
SPEAKERS HERE AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE TO THAT TELEPHONE. HI KIM
STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU IN
RESPECTFUL BUT STRONG
OPPOSITION AND THEN WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF GROUPS WHO JOINED OUR
OPPOSITION BUT DIDN'T MAKE IT
TO THE ANALYSIS MAGLIS THOSE.
YOU MIGHT THINK. THE A. I. NOW
INSTITUTE COMMUNITY ADVOCATES
FOR JUST AND MORAL GOVERNANCE
THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER.
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CRIMINAL DEFENSE
LAWYERS. PARTNERSHIP FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF NEW AMERICANS
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE
PUBLIC ADVOCATES THE SAME CISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
SHOWING UP FOR RATE JUST SAN
DIEGO. THE L. G. B. T. Q.
CENTER LONG BEACH. S. DIEGO
COAT AND WE THE PEOPLE DIEGO
COUNTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DEAR LUCIEN HERE AT TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE THE-
YOU LABOR UNION THAT REPRESENTS
THE TEN THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
LAPD IN- AS WELL AS THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS WE- WILL
THE LA POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE
WAS SUPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
UNTIL WE REVIEWED THE MINUTES
THAT WERE CIRCULATED TO US BY
THE AUTHORS OFFICE WITH THANKS
FOR BEING ADDED ON THAT BUT IT.
THE BILL. THERE ARE CHANGES
THAT THAT ACTUALLY IMPACT DAY
TO DAY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OPERATIONS IN IN WAYS THAT ARE
PERHAPS PROBLEM NOT WILLING
STOOD FOR SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE I HAD TO BE HERE IN PERSON
TO SAY THAT WE'RE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. BUT
SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION- HERE WITH US- LET'S
NOW MOVED TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WHO HAVE- JOINED
THAT TELEPHONICALLY. AND OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
SPENCER HAD DONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON ED
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SPENCER
HOW CAN ALL BE OFF ALL.
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA THAT IS
A- STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- WE OFTEN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND I CAN
I JUST I REMIND EVERYONE WHO'S
ON THE LINE THAT- DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS AND FORTUNATELY
UNITS TO YOUR NAME- AND YOUR-
ORGANIZATION AND YOU'RE- ON THE
BILL. THANK COMMENTED FROM TODD
SNYDER GLAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HELLO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND- RESPECTED CHAIR-
MY NAME IS TODD SNYDER AND I
REPRESENT INDIVISIBLE SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB TWO TWO SIX ONE THANK YOU. I
NEXT COMMENT AT FROM TAMMY
KRASNER PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR
NEXT COMMON AS FROM ANNA
KRASNER PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ANNA KRASNER AND ON
BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE SAN
FRANCISCO I AM- STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
ONE. OUR NEXT COMMA AND FROM
LEYVA HOLLAND PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS LEAH HOLLAND AND
I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF BY
THE FUTURE WHICH IS THE DIGITAL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION WITH
MILLION MEMBERS NATIONWIDE AND
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY TWO TO ONE THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT COMMENT AS FOR
MARGARET BAKER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS MARGARET BAKER
I'M WITH SOUTH STATE PEOPLE
POWER INCENDIO COUNTY A GROUP
THAT PROMOTES SOCIAL JUSTICE BY
NONPARTISAN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
AND WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO
EIGHTY TWO TWO SIX ONE. I NEXT
COMMENT AS FROM FEES HALL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JEFF COLE- WITH TAQLID SAN
DIEGO. AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO A.
B. TWO TWO SIX ONE. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT COMMENT IF BROWN'S
LAMPA NAJI PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS I AM
IN A JEEP I'M A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH THE COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS BUT
THE GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA.
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
TWO TWO SIX ONE THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT COMMON IN FROM TâM
KINGSTON BECAUSE I HAD. MY NAME
IS TIM KINGSTON ON A MEMBER OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S RACIAL JUSTICE
COMMITTEE AND WE ARE VERY
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY ONE. I NEXT COMMENT
AND FROM SEMANTIC WEAPON PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE COURT ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND PRIVATE YOU'RE A
CLEARING HOUSE STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NEXT
COMMON AS FROM MY ASIAN HAIR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MADE TO HAYES I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MEDIA DEAFNESS WHICH
IS BASED OUT IN OAKLAND AND WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY ONE. AN EX COMMUNISTS
FROM GENOVEVA JONES RIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS A
JOKE RIGHT I AM THE LEGAL
DIRECTOR BUT CANNOT PARTNERSHIP
FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF NEW
AMERICAN BY AND ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE PROJECT A MORAL
GOVERNANCE. I AM. THE COALITION
WHICH THE TREND. AND
RESPONSIBLE OF SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGY SAN DIEGO COALITION.
WHICH IS A COALITION MADE UP OF
THIRTY COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING VARIOUS SEGMENTS
OF OUR COMMUNITY HERE IN SAN
DIEGO AND WE ALL STRONGLY
OPPOSE. TWENTY TWO SIX ONE
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A COMMENT ON
CURRENT APATHY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS ERIN APTIOM
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE IT FROM
DANIEL BECAUSE HERE THEY GO
AHEAD. JANUARY CARRIED ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY A LONG. AND WE
HAVE A COMMENT FROM VANESSA A
KILLING ME BY HAND. FIRST WITH
YOUR DEDUCTIBLE IF YOU SEVEN.
SACRAMENTO MOVE ON AND IF YOU
FEEL YOU BOARD OF SACRAMENTO
INSTRUCTORS A SHIP. ONE MOMENT
WHILE THE NUMBER THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE SHOW
KILL. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
PHYSICALLY SHALL GAIL CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND WE
OPPOSE AB TWO TWO SIX ONE THANK
YOU. AND THERE CLOCK ONE
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO EVERYONE WHO TOOK
THE TIME TO CALL IN AND WILL
NOW BRING IT BACK FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE WOMAN- WAY. THANK
YOU- I WANT TO- COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER A PLAN MORE CARE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK WHICH I
THINK IS OBVIOUSLY VERY VERY
CRITICAL. THIS IS A NEWER
TECHNOLOGY THAT THE DESPERATELY
NEEDS- REGULATION. BUT YOU KNOW
AS T'S WRITTEN WRITTEN TODAY I
DON'T THINK THIS FRAMEWORK
ADEQUATELY- PROTECTS CONSUMERS.
PROTECTS OUR CONSTITUENTS- AND
I PARTICULAR CONCERN ABOUT THE
RACIAL BIAS CONCERNS THAT EVEN
FLAG BY. OF THE OPPOSITION AND
HOW THIS BILL WILL IMPACT BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR- I THINK THERE'S TOO
MUCH LATITUDE THAT THE
COMPANIES ARE GIVEN USE- FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY WITHIN
THIS BILL- AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT. HOW COMPANIES WILL
DETERMINE PROBABLE COPS- AND
THIS GIVES THEM TOO MUCH FREE
REIGN AND SO I RESPECTFULLY.
WILL NOT SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT- MY HOPE MISTER CHAIR
THAT YOU CAN WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS. YOU
KNOW THE IT ARE ABLE. I THINK
STRENGTH IN THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION EASE OF THIS IDEA.
DIFFERENT THE BUT AND I. DID
MY- FOR THIS BILL I HAVE O.
OPPOSE IT TODAY. SOMEONE ORDERS
OVER. THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR SO- MISTER CHAIRMAN I
KNOW THIS IS AN AT THAT ISSUE
THAT YOU'RE VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT IT'S AN ISSUE THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS AND I THINK THE REASON
WHY IT'S SUCH A DIFFICULT
ISSUES THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
SOMETHING THAT- ISN'T
INHERENTLY SOMETHING THAT WE
KEEP PRIVATE. UNTIL WE ARE
THINK ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS OF
HAVING THAT INFORMATION SHARED
ON A MASS LEVEL SO YOU KNOW THE
FACT THAT I RECOGNIZE YOUR FACE
WILL BE SITTING HERE AND I CAN
TELL MY WIFE- TONIGHT I RAN
INTO CHECK OUT THE CAPITAL YOU
KNOW THAT'S NOT A PIECE OF
PRIVATE INFORMATION THAT I
REVEALED ABOUT YOU BUT I'M WE
EXPAND THAT TO BEING DONE
MILLIONS MILLIONS OF TIMES A
DAY- THROUGH AN AUTOMATED
PROCESS IT RAISES SOME VERY
TROUBLING ETHICAL CONCERNS SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHY WERE
GRAPPLING WITH THIS ISSUE.
HOWEVER I ALSO THINK IT'S WORTH
VISUAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
IS ENABLING SOME. SOME BEHAVIOR
THAT'S VERY BENEFICIAL TO ALL
OF US HERE IN SOCIETY. AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
ESTABLISH A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK THAT DOESN'T- DENY US
THE BENEFITS OF THAT. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL THAT YOU
PUT TOGETHER HERE IT SEEMS TO
ME IS NOT FOCUS SO MUCH ON. THE
POTENTIAL ABSES OF THE
TECHNOLOGY IS IT IS TRYING TO
CHECK ALL THE BOXES ABOUT WHAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO DO TO DEPLOY IT.
I THINK WE BE BETTER SERVED IF
WE JUST FOCUSED ON. THE PUT THE
POTENTIAL ABUSES AND PASSED
LEGISLATION TO CURBING THOSE.
INSTEAD OF- ATTEMPT STABLE.
WORK SPECIFICALLY BEEN ABOUT IN
A GIVEN OUR CURRENT SITUATION.
WITH RUN OF OUR- THAT THAT'S
POTENTIALLY BY. USE OF THE-
RIGHT THROUGH AND TRY WE'RE NOT
QUITE THERE YET BUT YOU CAN SEE
A TIME OF THE NOT SO DIFFERENT
JUST A FUTURE WHERE YOU COULD
USE. A PARTY TO TRACK AND
TRACE- SUSPECTED CASES- I KNOW
THAT I WOULD BE VERY INTERESTED
IN KNOWING OF GETTING AN
AUTOMATED REPORT THE TOLD ME.
IF I HAD THE NEXT CORONAVIRUS.
USE PAPER RECOGNITION HER. I
WANT. DOES YOUR BILL PROHIBITS
BEHAVIOR BECAUSE IT'S MY
READING OF A SEEMS SEEMS IT
DOES. ALL THE BILL ITSELF DOES
NOT REALLY- PROHIBIT DOT PER SE
OF I THINK- DE UM. ARCTIC DE
ARE YOUNGER DEFERRED TO- VIA MY
WITNESS ON THIS QUESTION AS
WELL BUT- YOU KNOW THE WAITED I
FORESEE IT IT DOES NOT- YOU
KNOW I COULD NOT FIND A
LANGUAGE- PERTAINING TO THAT
PARTICULAR- YOU KNOW USE BUT
BUT I DON'T THINK IT DOES I
MEAN I THINK WOULD DEPEND ON
THE SOURCE OF THE IMAGE THAT
YOU'RE USING FOR FEDERAL
RECOGNITION IF IT WAS A PROP
BUT SOURCE YEAH THEN I. WOULD
NEED TO DO I CAN. TO HAVE
GENERALIZED YOU KNOW IF THEY
DID HAVE THAT I WOULDN'T DO IT
WOULD BE AN ILLEGAL USE OF
CAUGHT GO HEAD TO HEAD YEAH YOU
PUBLIC COURSE DE. WE NEED SOME
KIND OF EVIDENCE FOR THE CRIME
YOU'VE WRITTEN. THE WAIT IT IS.
OUR IT IS THAT. YOU KNOW I.
PEOPLE COULD. USE IT FOR.
THAT'S UP A- IN THE PUBLIC. I
AND DOT. ANY GOV IN WEBSITES
ANY. A THAT'S OF A TO PUBLIC
AND IF YOU KNOW I THINK I'M
SOMETHING ABOUT THE CLEAR FEEL
A AYE PARTICULAR SITUATION
WHERE THEY WERE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING IMAGES THAT WERE NOT
ONLY IN THE PUBLIC BUT ALSO
OBTAINED ARE BY AND- TRANSFER
FROM AS A FACEBOOK. SO THE BILL
AT IS AS IS IT IS WRITTEN AUG
WILL ONLY ALLOW FOR THE
RETENTION OF INFORMATION THAT'S
UP IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN. SO
OBSOLETE SO THAT THAT IS YOU
KNOW HOW THAT IS WORKING. OKAY
SO YEAH IT'S MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE RAN RIGHT IF I MIGHT JUMP
IN THIS IS RIGHT HARKENS OF
MICROSOFT I DON'T BELIEVE THE
BILL WOULD. PROHIBIT THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
FOR THOSE SORT THE PURPOSES- IT
IT YOU KNOW. BUT ON THE ONE
HAND REQUIRE- CONSENT- IF A
PRIVATE SOURCES INTENDING TO
USE THE- TECHNOLOGY FOR THOSE
KINDS OF PURPOSES. ON THE OTHER
HAND- NOT UNLESS. A GOVERNMENT%
AGENCY IS ENGAGING AND- ONGOING
SURVEILLANCE THEY THEY WOULD
NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE ONE
FIREMAN. SO IT IT'S KIND OF
SPLIT HAIRS BUT- I THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT STATION THAT- THE
FACT THAT I HAVEN'T GIVEN MY
CONSENT UNTIL AFTER THE FACT
YOU KNOW WHERE I SAID OKAY I
WOULD LIKE I'M IN NOW
INTERESTED IN. HAVING YOU CAN
TRACE ME MEANS THAT GOTTA GO
BACK AND ANALYZE ALL OF THE
PLACES I MIGHT HAVE BEEN. AS A
POOR TO YOU KNOW FORWARD
PROCESS WHERE- WHERE YOU'RE
ANALYZING IT AS GO AND THEN I
SAY YES I LIKE TO OPEN THE
XPOSED ANYWAY LET'S MOVE OUR
FROM THAT BECAUSE I DON'T
BELIEVE THE POINT BUT READING
OF THE OF THAT THAT'S A PART.
BETTER USE THAT MY READING THE
BOOKS WITH A LAUGH YEAH THAT'S
WHAT I MEAN THEY'RE PROBABLY.
UNDER THE BENEFIT. IS WHERE.
NEW THEM. SINCE BUT NEVER
DEVELOP. WE'RE NOT. MISS IT OFF
IN OUR APPROACH TO REGULATING.
UP I HAVE A FALL QUESTION CARE
ABOUT. A FEDERAL LAW. THERE WAS
A CASE INTO. ELEVEN IN THE
SUPREME. WHERE IT WAS IT WAS A-
N. X. THAT. IT REGARD A RELATE
TO THE- OF IN. THAT WAS
COLLECTED BY A BUSINESS. AND
THE SUPREME COURT RULED IN THAT
CASE. THAT THAT INFORMATION WAS.
OF MAN RUSSIAN OF FREE SPEECH
COMMERCIAL FREE SPEECH. YEAH
ND I AM AND IT WAS A PRETTY
STARKLY WORDED DECISION AND I'M
WONDERING HOW. THIS WOULD NOT
BE FOUND TO BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
UNDER THAT DECISION BECAUSE
PRETTY CLEARLY. IT IS S. AS
REGARDS THE PART OF THE BILL
THAT PUTS RESTRICTIONS ON WHAT
BUSINESSES CAN DO WITH
INFORMATION IS GATHERED ON
THEIR PROMISED- PRETTY CLEARLY
THAT WOULD FALL UNDER. THAT
SAME CABIN INFORMATION NOT. I
MR AGAINST AN ACID QUESTION.
YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION I THINK YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THE STORE OVER
BECAUSE I AND THAT'S HEALTH
RATED KATE- AND FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS- I THINK AT BEST YOU
CAN SAY THAT THE IMPLICATIONS
OF THAT CASE ON. ANY LAW THAT-REGULATES. THE COLLECTION AND
USE OF DATA PRIVACY LAWS THAT
THIS LAW. IT IS DEBATABLE. I DO
NOT THINK THAT IT WOULD RENDER
THIS PLOT WAR BUT PRIVACY LAWS
MORE GENERALLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS. AMONG
OTHERS- JUSTICE KENNEDY IN THAT
CASE. NOTED THAT THEY WERE NOT-
RENDERING A DECISION AND- ADD
TO THE POTENTIAL CONFLICT
BETWEEN THE FIRST AMENDMENT-
AND PRIVATE LAWS IN THE PAST
THE TECH. LOGY TO- TO LACK
INFORMATION ABOUT PEOPLE. THERE
THAT NUMBER OTHER REASONS WHY I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT CASE
WOULD. INVALIDATE THE PRIVACY
LAWS OR- IN WITH WHICH WE CAN%
GO INTO IF WE HAD MORE TIME.
SURE YOU KNOW I WELL I THINK AT
THE VERY LEAST. WE'LL THIS LAW
WHAT IF IT PASSED FACED A
CONCERT JAIL. AND I HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE I
ACTUALLY THINK IT WOULD IT
WOULD BE OVERTURNED. I FOR THE
SAME REASONS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT DATA THAT'S
INHERENTLY PRIVATE WHEN I TALK
ABOUT SOMEONE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER WE TALK ABOUT SOMEONE'S
APPEARANCE WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT WE REVEAL TO EACH OTHER
EVERY DAY. SO I SOME. OF WAS
THERE. A BUT ONE WAY OR THE I
WOULDN'T YOU TO COULD WORKING
ON THIS IT'S ON SOMETHING THAT
I CAN SUPPORT. TODAY I THINK
IT'S AN INDICATION THAT YOU'VE
GOT DISAGREEMENT FROM THE THINK
YOU HAVEN'T GONE FAR ENOUGH.
COMPARED AT THE SAME TIME
YOU'VE GOT DISAGREEMENT THAT
THAT. FROM PEOPLE THAT THINK
YOU'VE GONE TOO FAR THAT MAYBE
MEANS THAT YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT
PATH- I JUST. I DON'T THINK IT
NOW THE TIME TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS WHEN THE PERIOD OF
REVIEW ON. THIS LEGISLATION HAS
BEEN SHORTS ALL BE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MUCH.
SOME WOMEN WHAT. THANK YOU MISS
FRAZIER- MISTER TEARS YOU KNOW
I'M A SUBSTITUTE MEMBER ON THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY AND I KNOW YOU
WORK EXTENSIVELY ON THIS ISSUE
SO I'M GOING TO VOTE TO MOVE
THE BILL FORWARD BUT- I WOULD
JUST CAUTION THAT GIVEN THE
LEVEL OF A- OPPOSITION. THE
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM WILL
BECOME LAW SO I KNOW YOU'LL
HAVE TO WORK- THIS ISSUE
EXTENSIVELY IT'S AN EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY THAT NEEDS- NEEDS
LAW HE'S REGULATIONS SO I.
APPLAUD YOU FOR ENGAGING. ISSUE
BUT I KNOW THAT- GIVEN THE
OPPOSITION- YOU'LL MOST
CERTAINLY HAVE TO A WORK AT. IN
A CONSIDERABLE WAY TO GET IT TO
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE BUT I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL. TODAY AT.
SOME MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- TO A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
ON SOME OF THE DETAILS IN THE
BILL- IT'S IS THAT WHEN THERE.
OFFICIAL TECHNOLOGY THERE WILL
BE IN COURT TO MEANINGFUL HUMAN
REVIEW. WHAT WHAT IS OUR
DEFINITION FOR WHAT MEANING FOR
HUMAN REVIEW IS WHAT WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN. OUR THAT MEANS IS
THAT ANY DECISIONS THAT WOULD
HI HOW THE LEGAL EFFECT ALL
WHEN THE TECHNOLOGY IS SO BEING
DEPLOYED. WOULD REQUIRE
SOMEBODY WHO'S TRAINED AND HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE THAT
DECISION. TO THAT THAT. YOU
KNOW THE AS FAR AS WHAT WHAT
WOULD THAT MEAN BY LEGAL EFFECT
OUT I THINK THAT'S A LIST OF
OTHER THINGS THAT I TALKED
ABOUT INCLUDING LENDING LAWS
FOR EXAMPLE SOMEBODY WANTS TO-
APPLY FOR A LOAN. HOUSING
INSURANCE EDUCATION YES AND
THAT. THE AND I DON'T MEAN IN
BUT SO DID MY QUESTION IS ON
THAT SIDE IT'S MORE THEY CAN
REVIEWS SITE RIGHT WHO IS IT
WHO. THIS YEAR THANK YOU TO BE.
PRIVATE COMPANY THAT YOU THE
FOR ARE. I MEAN WHO IS A LEFT
TO OUR ANY STATE. THAT GOING TO
BE A PLACE TO THE TERM WHAT
THAT REVIEW MEANS BIG.
MEANINGFUL THAN I AM BEHOLDER
RIGHT AFTER. WELL THE YOU KNOW%
THE LAW SAYS THAT YOU KNOW ANY
DECISION REGARDING GET OUT OF
THE ITEMS THAT I MENTIONED
WOULD HAVE TO BE READ REVIEW BY
A HUMAN BEING WE'VE BEEN TRYING
AS TO WHO'S GONNA. GEN THEN NOT
COMPANY WOULD HAVE TO MAKE THAT
THE SELF. YEAH SOME MISTER
CHAIRED BY THIS I'M SORRY IF I
MIGHT THIS IS RYAN HARKENED
AGAIN- I THINK YOU KNOW THAT
THAT IS A DEFINED TERM IN THE
BILL. AND IT DOES PROVIDE AS AS
MISTER CHAIR OF NOTED THAT THAT
THE IN AN INDIVIDUAL MUST BE
TRAINED AND IT ALSO MUST BE
SOMEONE WHO IS ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING THE
DECISION. SO IT AS BEST WE READ
THAT ANYWAY EIGHT- I THINK THAT
THE CLEAR INTENT IT IS THE
INDICATE THAT YOU CAN'T JUST BE
A LOW LEVEL EMPLOYEE WHO SIMPLY
PUSHING A BUTTON OR OR MOVING
PAPERS ACROSS HER DESK IT HAS
TO BE SOMEONE. WITH AUTHORITY
WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION TO
RENDER THE DECISION AND SOMEONE
FRANKLYWHO CAN CHANGE THE
DECISION- YOU KNOW IT MAY BE
THAT THERE IS THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL. THE FLUSH OUT WHAT
THAT IS- BUT WE THINK THAT THE
CURRENT DEFINITION THE BILL IT
IS A GOOD START- IN WOULD START
TO. YOU KNOW PUT SOME
RESTRICTIONS AROUND AN AREA
WHERE THERE REALLY AREN'T
RESTRICTIONS TODAY. THANK THANK
YOU AND I GUESS YEAH MY CONCERN
IS THAT. IT THE MOTIVATIONS
BEHIND THAT HUMAN REVIEW THAT
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT
AND SO YOU KNOW HE JUST LEAVE
IT TO THAT COMPANY. YOU KNOW IF
THE COMPANY IS TELLING THAT
PERSON HIGH LEVEL LOW LEVEL MID
LEVEL WHATEVER TRAIN NOT
TRAINED. YEAH DID TO IMPROVE
USES THAT SHOULDN'T BE APPROVED
THEN YOU HAVE A PROBLEM- AND SO
I DO THINK THAT THIS IS AN AREA
THAT THAT NEED MORE DEFINITION.
THE BILL SHOULD THERE BE SOME
BASE SO FOR. WHAT IN BECAUSE-
NECESSARY FOR THE PROVISION OF
THAT SERVICE. MEANS AND THIS IS
KIND OF THE SAME ISSUE- WHERE
YOU KNOW HE IS A PROBLEMATIC TO
JUST LEAVE TO EACH BUSINESS. TO
DECIDE WHAT IS. CAN QUOTE
DIRECTLY NECESSARY FOR THE
PROVISION OF THAT SERVICE. OR
MAYBE THERE'S MORE DEFINITION
THE BILL THAT THAT THAT I
MISSED ALREADY. I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO IS- ONE OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE-
CURRENTLY HAVE UNDER. I
BELIEVE- SECTION THREE TEN E.
ONE OR THEREABOUTS AND- MAYBE
MAYBE THE BEST WAY TO TOOL-
RESPONSE YOUR QUESTION IS- IT
BY USING AN X. AN EXAMPLE FOR
EXAMPLE- FOR EXAMPLE YOU HOW-
SOMEBODY USING AND HOW. THAT
WOULD. POSSIBLY CAPTURE THE
IMAGE OF THE LAYER- SO THE
LEVEL OF- CONSENT. IS REQUIRE
AND THE BILL IN SUCH A WAY THAT
GIVE GIVE THE GAME ITSELF IF
THE APPLICATION ITSELF WHAT A
REQUIRES. THE PERSON'S IMAGE TO
BE CAPTURED AND THAT IS THE
THAT IS THE CONSENT THAT DOES
REQUIRE NOW HOW HOWEVER IF THAT
PICTURE OF THE OF THAT IMAGE
HAS TO BE USED FOR SOMETHING
ELSE. OF THE ADULT SO. CONSENT
WOULD BE NEEDED AS WELL NOW.
THE ARE BUT IF YOU KNOW THE
FACT THAT THE PERSON GIVES
CONSENT FIRST TIME DOESN'T MEAN
THAT YOU KNOW IF I CAN COULD BE
FOR FURTHER DISSEMINATED TO A
THIRD PERSON. SO IF THAT
HAPPENS IN A SEPARATE TENTS AND
WE REQUIRE. JOHN GOTCHA AN AID
AGAIN THE KIND OF SOMEONE A
LAST QUESTION MY CONCERN IS
JUST. ANY BODY CAN JUSTIFY
REASON TO USE ANYTHING- AND SO
IF THERE ARE NO STANDARDS THERE
FOR HOUSTON PERMISSIVE USES. OF
THE YOU KNOW SOMETHING LIKE.
DIRECTLY NECESSARY FOR THE
VERSION OF THAT SERVICE IS SO
VERY THAT THAT YEAH YOU CAN
PROBABLY JUSTIFY ANY. DECISION
YOU KNOW BASED ON ON THAT KIND
OF A DESCRIPTION SO I THINK
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY
TIGHTENED UP- AND THEN IT YOU
KNOW I AGREE WITH THE CONCERNS
AROUND- YOU KNOW. THIS
TECHNOLOGY NOT BEING USED FOR
NOT REINFORCING BIAS HE'S
AROUND RACE AND GENDER AND AGE-
SO I GUESS YEAH CAN YOU TELL ME
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN PLACE
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE USE OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY ISN'T BIASED
BASED ON- YOU KNOW THOSE
FACTORS CHAIR I THINK THERE'S
SEVERAL LEVELS OF PROTECTION IN
THAT REGARD FIRST OF ALL OF THE
LAW REQUIRES THE OF TESTING TO
BE DONE THE TESTING HAS TO BE
INDEPENDENT ARE. A WELL. MAKE
SURE THAT OF. DE OF SUB GROUPS
AND NOT BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST. OF YEAH WE ALSO
PROVIDED THE THIS STANDARD AS
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER. SO NOW
PERSON- USING THE TECHNOLOGY
WOULD HAVE. TO BASICALLY
SUPPLIED THE WHAT THEY CALLED
IN ON. THE API WHICH QUALITY
APPLICATION PROGRAMMING
INTERFACE. FOR AN INDEPENDENT
PARTY TO VERIFY TO TELL US. AND
IF THEY- IF THE TEST ACTUALLY
COMPLIES WITH THE NEW STANDARD
AND THERE OKAY. NOW ARE THAT'S
ONE LEVEL OF SAFEGUARD THAT'S
ON THE ON THE TESTING PART. NOW
THE OTHER PART IS THAT. ON THE
ENROLLMENT HE'S YOU KNOW BEFORE
THE IMAGES- AND ROLLED INTO A
DATABASE THAT A CONSENT YOU
KNOW CONSENT WILL BE NEEDED AS
WELL. SO THAT'S A SECOND. NOW
THE PIECES THAT. WHEN IT COMES
pTO SURVEILLANCE- EXAMPLE OF.
YEAH THAT BE ALLOWED UNDER
LIMITED SIR. THAT IS IF IT'S A
SIN CRIME. AND ALSO IF THERE'S
A WARRANT REQUIREMENT. BONTA AS
WELL AS SET UP YOU KNOW THERE
THERE'S ALSO THE- YOU KNOW THE
PROVISION THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
DISCRIMINATION ON THE FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW. YEAH OKAY. I.
I'M GONNA VERY BEGRUDGINGLY
SUPPORT THIS TODAY TO GIVE YOU
MORE TIME TO WORK ON A LOT OF
THESE DETAILS WE GOT A LOT OF
THIS VERY LATE AND DIDN'T HAVE
A TON OF TIME TO WHAT YOU KNOW
TO WORK WITH MY STAFF AND
PERSONALLY REVIEW THINGS THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT AREA WHERE
THERE'S MINIMAL REGULATION
EXISTING NOW AND SO I DO THINK
SOMETHING NEEDS TO HAPPEN- I
THINK A LOT OF THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED. BY BY
GROUPS ALL OF THE SPECTRUM-
YEAH THERE ARE SOME VALID
CONCERNS THERE- AND SO ON I NO
ONE'S. AND RESPECT YOU IN THE
KNOW THAT YOU. YOU'RE WORK.
WITH THESE ORGANIZATIONS I
DON'T THINK THE ANSWER IS BEING
THE TECHNOLOGY AND I DON'T
THINK THE ANSWER IS NOTHING.
AND SO WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
SOMETHING- BUT YOU KNOW THE GUY
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE I THINK TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT. WHAT THAT SWEET SPOT IS.
OF EXPRESSED SOME OF MY- EARNS.
THE OBVIOUS RESERVE. THE RIGHT
TO. CHANGE THAT DECISION BASED
ON HOW THIS GOAL PROGRESSES-
BUT- I'LL BE WILLING TO GIVE
YOU A- I COURTESY I'VE TODAY TO
LET YOU KEEP WORKING ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I THANK YOU. A
SOMEONE OR ONE. I THINK OF THAT
WAS LIFELONG DAY CREATE NEW OF
WORKING ON THE RIGHT OR.
TECHNOLOGY WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
PRETTY EARLY. A LOT YEAR OR.
LIKE THAT PRIVATE. AND RIGHT I
HAVE BEEN SPEAKING. WHAT THEY-
AND- RIGHT OR- THAT. WHILE I DO
WANT TO SAY SOME THE RECENT AND
THEN- ONE MORE. I CERTAINLY.
FIVE AND OF YEAH WE WOULDN'T I
THINK ONE LAW. FOR OKAY
PROBABILITY YEAH OVERSIGHT BUT-
SORRY. WE WANT WE WANT LAUNCH
TO A PRO OKAY AND BUT WE ALSO
DO NOT WANT TO HAMPER THEIR
ABILITY TO SOLVE CRIMES AND SO
I HOPE THAT YOU AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD AND WORK WITH ALL THE-
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL THAT
YOU TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT THE-
FOR VICTIMS OF CRIMES. TO FOR
THE POLICE NOT TO HAVE CERTAIN
TOOLS I THINK. IS REALLY
INAPPROPRIATE AND SO- I'VE I
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS ON THE FLOOR AND
ALL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
THANK YOU. SOMEONE CREEL. THANK
YOU TEST TEST THIS WORKING OKAY.
THANK YOU- FIRST- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
VERY SENSITIVE MATTER AS A YOUR
EFFORT AND ALSO AN ENGAGING ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS- WE KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE WAY
WHEN IT COMES TO A LOT OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY- AND IN DOING SO WAS
ALSO. EMBRACE THIS EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY IN THE REFORMS THAT
GO ALONG SIDE OF THAT THOUGH I
UNDERSTAND THE FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERN REGARDING. YOUR LADY TO
TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE I WANT TO
REMIND AND NOT GLOSS OVER
SOMETHING THAT USE THAT YOU
STATED WHEN YOU FIRST- BEGAN
YOUR COMMENTS AND REMIND THIS
COMMITTEE THOSE THAT ARE
WATCHING- OR LISTENING. THAT
YOU YOURSELF AS YOU STATED HAVE
BEEN WRONGFULLY A RECOGNIZED BY
THIS KIND OF TECHNOLOGY YOU ARE
A LEADER WITHIN YOUR API
COMMUNITY IN THE CHINESE UNIT.
YOUR LEADER AMONG PEOPLE OF
COLOR WHICH IS IMPACT THE MOST
US WITH IN BY THE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION MY TRUCK. YOU CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE DONE THE
WORK NEFF. TO ENSURE THAT
YOU'RE MOVING GOOD POLICY
FORWARD THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND CIVIL
RIGHTS GROUP BOTH IN
OPPOSITION. LEADS ME TO BELIEVE
ALSO THAT YOU'VE REACHED A
MIDDLE GROUND WHERE NO ONE'S
HAPPY- AND WE KNOW HERE THAT
OFTEN TIMES. THAT'S THE RIGHT
PLACE TO BE IN TERMS OF WHAT
DETERMINES TO BE GOOD POLICY IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO FIND. A
MIDDLE GROUND SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR YOUR BILL TODAY
I ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO THIS MY
FIRST DAY ON THIS COMMITTEE. SO
THIS IS THE BEEN INCREDIBLY AND
LIGHTNING. AND ALSO TO SEE THE
WAY THAT YOU HAVE MANAGE THE
BILLS BEFORE IT BEFORE HAND.
AND THI INCREDIBLY IMPACTFUL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT COULD
REALLY SET THE TONE FOR THE
STATE AND THE REST OF THE
NATION WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY. AND FACIAL
RECOGNITION SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER- AT CHAO
AND I- I I'LL JUST SAY YOU KNOW
A COUPLE YEARS AGO WE WORK
TOGETHER ON A RESOLUTION THAT
WAS SORT OF A FIRST ATTEMPT TO
COME UP WITH A SET OF
PRINCIPLES. ARE RELATED TO
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WHICH
IS IN THE PROCESS OF.
TRANSFORMING OUR WORLD AN
EXTRAORDINARY AND REALLY
UNIMAGINABLE WAYS. AND I WANT
THE PRINCIPLES OF THAT
RESOLUTION PASSES COMMITTEE
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE- WAS HAVING AN ONGOING
DIALOGUE WITH- POLICYMAKERS
AROUND. A MERGING TECHNOLOGIES
SO THAT WE COULD- ASSURE THAT
THE BENEFITS ARE REALIZED AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND IS WIDELY
SPREAD AS POSSIBLE SO THAT WE
COULD. GET RISKS ARE INHERENT
IN THE TECHNOLOGY AND ALSO SO
THAT WE COULD- MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A BACKLASH AGAINST NEW
TECHNOLOGIES- THAT'LL ONLY
ENTERS PROGRESS. ICE THIS BILL.
RE BRINGING SOME OF THOSE TO
THE FORE. AND OUT OF FACE. AND
TECHNOLOGISTS VERY BEGINNING OF
THE TECHNOLOGIES WERE WILL BE
HAVING- THESE DEBATES. AND I
THINK THAT. THE BALANCE YOUR
STRIKING HERE. YOU KNOW IS
OBVIOUSLY FAR FROM PERFECT BUT
IS HEADING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION SO- I AM. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT. THE BILL TODAY I'LL
JUST MENTION A FEW- ISSUES THAT
OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED AS WELL I
THINK THE LAW ENFORCEMENT ISSUE
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED- I THINK
THAT THAT. THE IDEA OF CONSENT-
REALLY NEEDS TO BE FLESHED OUT
A LITTLE BIT MORE AND ON THE
GETS OLD ONLY GONNA BE WORKABLE
FOR CONSUMERS TO HAVE TO GIVE
AN INDIVIDUALIZED CONSENT TO
EACH ESTABLISHMENT. AND WE'RE
GONNA NEED I THINK A BETTER
SOLUTION THERE AND THEN MORE
BROADLY. THE QUESTION OF HOW
THIS RELATES TO. LOCAL
ORDINANCES OR REGULATIONS OTHER
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT I THINK
NEEDS TO BE THOUGHT THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT MORE MAYBE THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES WHERE WE WANT TO
HAVE. A STATE WHAT SORT OF
ISLAM THAT'LL JURY OTHER STATES
SIX. THEIR AREAS WE WANT TO
HAVE UNIFORMS STAND AND IT'S
NOT ENTIRELY TO ME WHETHER THE-
JUST THAT WOULD THAT THOSE BE
IN MIND IS FORWARD. AND I AM
NOT PETER MOVED. BECAUSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH EL
MEMBERS UP FOR FALL IMMEDIATELY
ME. EXCEL THE AMENDMENTS-
TODAY- AND ALSO I WANT TO RELAY
A MESSAGE FROM THE LA COUNTY
REGIONAL IDENTIFICATION SYSTEM
OF THAT HAS BEEN CONVEYED TO ME
EARLIER ON IT SAYS OUR OFFICE
AS AN INITIAL POSITIVE VIEW OF
THE BILL- FROM THE LA COUNTY HI
DE IDENTIFICATIONSYSTEM JUST
FOR IT TO. COMMITTEES
INFORMATION SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO CLOSE-
SO I LIKE TO CLOSE TODAY'S
DISCUSSION WITH A LITTLE
HISTORICAL CONTACTS. UP IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE ON THEN SENATOR
DEBORAH BOWL AND AUTHOR SP ONE
SIXTY NINE. A BILL THAT
INTENDED TO RESTRICT THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE
PERSONAL PRIVACY AND THE
SECURITY OF THE COLLECTED DATA.
THAT BILL IS REFLECTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY ANALYSIS AT
THE TIME. WOULD HAVE PROHIBITED
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES FROM AMONG
OTHER THINGS COLLECTING OR
USING BIOMETRIC. INFORMATION
OBTAINED FROM A USER FISH
CONDITION TECHNOLOGY. IT
ACCEPTED LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WHEN ACTING PURSUANT
TO A WARRANT. AND AUTHORIZE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION WITH SPECIFIC
INFORMATION WITHOUT WHO NEED
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION FOR
PURPOSES OF THE PROSECUTION OR
DEFENSE OF A CRIMINAL CASE. A
FURTHER THE MEASURE WOULD HAVE
PERMITTED PRIVATE ENTITIES TO
USE FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IN SITUATIONS WHERE
A CONSUMER INITIATES A
TRANSACTION AND THAT CONSUMER
CONSENT TO THE USE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. IN ALL OTHER CASES
BUSINESSES COULD HOW. COULD
ONLY COLLECT BIOMETRIC
IDENTIFIER INFORMATION AND
ATTEMPT TO IDENTIFY AND USING
FACIAL RECOGNITION WHEN IT IS
REASONABLY NECESSARY TO MAKE
PUBLIC SAFETY. OR TO PROTECT
AGAINST A VOTE OF LAW AND WHEN
SINCE AS PER TO AND CAN SPEAK
NOTED THAT THE FROM IS
COLLECTED. FINAL BILL ALL
RESTRICTED THE IN BUSINESSES
MAY SELL OR SHARE INFORMATION
AND INTO TO BE. WHETHER Y.
SECURE UNDER ACCESS. OF FINALLY
IT ALSO THE MEASURE AND POSE
VARYING CIVIL- PENALTIES. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WERE GROUPS
LIKE THE ACLU AND THE PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARING HOUSE TODAY
SOME OF THESE GROUPS CALL MY
BILL MISGUIDED AND DANGEROUS-
WHICH IS ALSO AN IMPEDIMENT
FORCED TO RETURN TO A SAFE AND
FREE SOCIETY. I'M LAST YEAR
WHEN I AUTHOR A. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE WHICH WOULD SIMPLY
REQUIRED BUSINESS TO DISCLOSE
WHEN THEY'RE USING FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY SIMILAR
TO SB ONE SIXTY NINE THE ACLU
AND THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE ALSO POSTED. IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE ACLU ROLE
IN SUPPORT OF THAT BILL SB ONE
SIXTY NINE AND A QUOTE HERE. WE
ARE ENTERING AN ERROR WITH
TECHNOLOGY IS OUTPACING I'LL
BASIC PRIVACY RIGHTS. FURTHER
BETWEEN HIGH TECH COMPANIES AND
THE GOVERNMENT THERE IS A HUGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO BE MADE. AND
A HUGE AMOUNT OF PRIVACY TO BE
LOST. A GOVERNMENT LESS
EXERCISE SOME CONTROL OVER
THERE THE RAPIDLY DE DEVELOPING
USE OF- SOPHISTICATED FACE
IDENTIFICATION SYSTEMS BEFORE
BECOME A SOCIETY UNDER CONSTANT
SURVEILLANCE. IT HAS BEEN
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS SINCE THAT
LEGISLATION FAILED PASSAGE
DESPITE HAVING THE SUPPORT OF
SOME OF THE VERY SAME GROUPS
THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION BY BILL
TODAY. AND I WILL NOTE THAT SB
ONE SIXTY NINE WAS PRE NINE
ELEVEN AND THAT SINCE THEN SOME
OF THESE GROUPS HAVE
REPOSITIONED THEIR STANCE. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT INCOME IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE CURRENT
STANCE AB ONE SIXTY NINE
PROHIBIT THE USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION BY GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES. HOWEVER THE
OPPOSITION ADMITS TODAY AND
THEIR LETTER. TO THIS BILL AND
I QUOTE THAT EIGHT ICE IS
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF STATE AND
PRIVATE FACIAL RECOGNITION
SYSTEMS THE TARGET IMMIGRANTS
POLICE HAVE USED IT TO TARGET
PEOPLE OF COLOR GOVERNMENTS ARE
USING IT TO A PRESS RELIGIOUS
MINORITIES AND DISCOURAGE FREE
EXPRESSION. THIS MEANS THAT THE
INTEGRATION OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY OUR
EVERYDAY LIVES HAS PERSISTED
OVER A SPAN OF TWENTY YEARS BY
BOTH PRIVATE AND GOVERNMENT
ACTORS. LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA
TOOK AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
ADDRESS THE USE OF F. R. T. AND
LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE BODY
ONE CAMERAS WITH A THREE YEAR
MORATORIUM. SO WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THREE YEARS IF WE DO
NOTHING HERE TODAY. IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY AS WAS THE
CASE ALMOST TWENTY YEARS AGO IT
WILL BECOME INCREASINGLY
COSTLY. AND DIFFICULT TO
IMPLEMENT THESE REGULATIONS
SINCE MORE ENTITIES WILL HAVE
DEVELOPED FRT INFRASTRUCTURES
WITHOUT CONSIDERATION FOR THESE
COMMENTS FOR THESE LIMITS. DO
WE WANT TO WAIT ANOTHER TWENTY
YEARS UNTIL IT IS TOO LATE ONLY
TO LOOK BACK TO THIS DAY IS A
TIME. WHERE WE COULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING TO CONTROL THE FATE
OF OUR FUTURE AS IT RELATES TO
THE TECHNOLOGY. I'M NOT WILLING
TO WAIT AND WE CAN ACT NOW TO
FINISH THE WORK. THAT'S THE WE
STARTED WITH THE SP ONE SIX
NINE AND WE CAN DO IT
COLLECTIVELY SO WITHOUT I ASK
FOR YOUR IBM. MOTION IS IT DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS MONTHS
AFTER IT WAS CALLED. I THINK WE
HAVE A SECOND FROM SOMEONE
CARILLO. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAO HI CHAO AYE KILEY AYE
KILEY AYE OUR QUE HAN. THERE
CAN NO BERMAN. BERMAN I MEDINA.
MEDINA I CARILLO CREEL I MULLIN.
MULLIN I GALLAGHER. IRWIN FIVE
IRWIN I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO
WICKS NOW WORKS NOW. THE BILL
IS OUT WE HAVE A SECOND BILL
FROM MR CHOW AT THIS IS A BE
TWO THREE TWO ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS CHAIR AND I HOPE
THIS WILL BE A LITTLE EASIER
FOR BOTH OF YOU. AB TWENTY
THREE TO WOULD REQUIRE THAT
CONTRACTORS DOING BUSINESS WITH
A STATE AGENCY TO MAINTAIN
CYBER INSURANCE. IF THE
CONTRACTOR RECEIVES OR HOUSE
ACCESS TO RECORDS CONTAINING
PERSONAL INFORMATION. THE
CONTRACTING STATE AGENCY WOULD
DETERMINE THE LEVEL OF CYBER
INSURANCE SUFFICIENT TO COVER
LOSSES RESULTING FROM A CYBER
SECURITY BREACH. IN RECENT
YEARS SO WE HAVE SEEN CYBER
ATTACKS AND DATA BREACHES SO
SKYROCKETED. MANY OF US HAVE
HEARD OF THE HACKING INCIDENT
ON THE OFFICE OF PERSONNEL
MANAGEMENT OPM IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHERE THE SENSITIVE
INFORMATION. OF TWENTY ONE
MILLION AMERICANS WAS EXPOSED.
THESE PEOPLE WERE AWAITING
THEIR BACKGROUND CHECKS. SINCE
THE COVER NINETEENTH ENDEMIC
HIT TE CYBERATTACKS INCREASE
OVER SIX HUNDRED PERCENT.
HOSPITALS WERE HIT BY
RANSOMWARE ATTACKS AND BREACHES
AFFECTING TE LAB TESTING OF
THE VIRUS. BY LIKING- STAFF
FROM DATA INPUT PATIENT
INFORMATION. DRUG DOSAGE HAVING
BEEN STOLEN AND DELAY IN
PROVIDING. CRITICAL CARE EVEN
LEADING TO DOUBTS. STATE
AGENCIES ARE JUST AS VULNERABLE
FOR EXAMPLE WITHIN THE LAST TWO
THREE YEARS CYBER CRIMINALS
ALSO HIT ON THE CALIFORNIA MEN
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE. PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT- OF- FISH AND
WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE-
AND ALSO SOME OF THE YOU SEE
AND CAL STATE CAMPUSES AND-
LIKE BAKER BILL A BILL BECAUSE
IT. ARE OUR- SORRY. THE LIST
GOES ON. THESE IT IT REACHES
ALL DESIGNED TO DISRUPT AN
ORGAN BILL AND THEY COME IN
FORMS LIKE MAILLET A RANSOM
DENIAL O SERVICE WITH
OBJECTIVES TO COMPROMISE THEIR
NETWORKS AND SENSITIVE DATA
THEY COULD ALSO IMPACT A
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURES SUCH
AS ALL PUBLIC RATE HOSPITALS
NOT TO MENTION THE FINANCIAL
EXPOSURE THAT THEY CREATE CYBER
INSURANCE SO WILL HELP ADDRESS
THE INCREASING NUMBER OF CYBER
ATTACKS BY HELPING AN
ORGANIZATION TO MITIGATE RISKS-
EXPO BY OFFSETTING COST
INVOLVED. WITH THE RECOVERY
AFTER A SIDE OF REACH THE
AVERAGE COST OF AN ATTACK IS
ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CYBER INSURANCE WOULD ALSO HELP
TO ONE INCENTIVIZE AN
ORGANIZATION TO BILL ROBUST.
CYBER SECURITY SYSTEM AND ALSO
TO ENCOURAGE BEST PRACTICES SO
WITHIN AN ORGANIZATION IT'S IN
FACT ESTIMATED THAT 60% OF THE
SMALL BUSINESSES GO OUT OF
BUSINESS WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF A
CYBER ATTACK. IN CALIFORNIA AT
LEAST 25% OF THE ANNUAL
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTING DOLLARS
IS BEING PAID. TO CERTIFY SMALL
BUSINESSES A CYBER INSURANCE
CAN HELP PROTECT CONSTITUENTS
AND TAXPAYERS WHO RELY ON SALL
BUSINESSES SERVICES. IN
ADDITION STATE AGENCIES HAVE A
DUTY TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. PERSONAL INFORMATION
UNDER THE INFORMATION PRACTICES
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
OR IPA. THE ACT EVEN ALLOWS FOR
CIVIL ACTION OF DAMAGES TO BE
FILED AGAINST A GOVERNMENT
AGENCY WHICH IS AN EX. ALEX
EXCEPTION TO THE GOVERNMENT
IMMUNITY THAT NORMALLY PROTECTS
A GOVERNMENT ENTITY FROM TORT
CLAIMS. ALL OF THIS MAKES IT
IMPERATIVE FOR A CONTRACTORS
DOING BUSINESS WITH THE STATE
WHAT. ALL PERSONAL INFORMATION
TO CARRY SO SURE IS SO I
RESPECT AS YOUR- OF PORT IN
I'VE- THANK GOD WE HAVE ANY. IN
SUPPORT HERE WITH US IN THE
ROOM. HOW ABOUT- WITH US BY
PHONE. YOU HAVE A COMMENT AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY TWO. SURE NO
SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT WE DO HAVE
TWO SPEAKERS DESIGNATED IN
OPPOSITION WHO I BELIEVE ARE
BOTH WITH US BY PHONE. I WILL
NOT START WITH MS CURTIS. FROM
THE FROM CLEARLY. WE CAN. GREAT
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY DURING THESE TRYING
TIMES AND PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY MY
NAME'S LAURA CURTIS AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF COMP HERE THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE AND
MISTER OF STAFF AND HIS
ANALYSIS AND THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO DISCUSS THE BILL WITH OUR
COALITION HOWEVER WE ARE HERE
AT. THE EIGHTY TWENTY THREE ONE
THE MEMBER OF OUR ORGANIZATION
HAVE A MUTUAL GOAL OF ENSURING
PRIVACY IN PROTECTING SENSITIVE
DATA HOWEVER THE PROPOSED
STATEWIDE TYPE INSURANCE
MANDATE AS DEFINED WILL ONLY
DRIVE UP THE COST A STATE
AGENCY CONTRACT AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY WOULD CREATE ADDITIONAL
AND UNNECESSARY FINANCIAL
BURDENS ON ORGANIZATIONS
CONTRACTING STATE AGENCY THERE
ARE MEN OF PAPER INSURANCE
SHOULD BE NEGOTIATED IF NEEDED
DURING THE REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL
PROCESS RATHER THAN THEY DID
MANAGE. YOUR TECHNOLOGY BUT-
ALL APPROACH WHICH AND-
TECHNICAL LOOKS. THAT THE PRO
GETS IN A- THAT. PROCURED AND
SO. AND DETERMINE THE-
INSURANCE NEEDS FOR PARTICULAR
ARE HE- BASED ON A RELEASED
REALISTIC AND NECESSARY COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS. THAT TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT IF AND WHAT LEVELS
OF CYBER INSURANCE ARE CALLED
FOR IN LIGHT OF THE SENSITIVITY
OF THE INFORMATION BALK. OTHER
AVAILABLE CURRENT POLICIES THAT
MAKE COVER LOSSES AND EXPLODED
ARREST AMONG OTHER FACTORS WE
CURRENTLY SEE NO BARRIERS TO
THE ABILITY OF STATE AGENCIES
TO REQUEST I BRING TRYING TO
WHEN AND WHERE THEY DEEM
APPROPRIATE. IN FACT
CONTRACTORS TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO KERRY INSURANCE
LOST COVERAGE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE INCREASINGLY
DEMANDING IT CONTRACTORS CARRY
HIGHER LOST COVERAGE. WE ARE
GOING TO AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
EIGHT ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
BURDEN CONTRACTORS WHICH WILL.
OF ENTRY FOR NEWER OR SMALLER
COMPANIES TO MAYBE. THIS IS.
BECAUSE IS LIKE TO SEE TO
BETTER RESULTING IN HIGHER.
ACOSTA THIS. IN CLOSING WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT STATE MANDATES
A CRACKED UP UNDER SECOND. AND
IT FEELS TO CREATE A BETTER
OUTCOME FOR THE PARTIES
INVOLVED ESPECIALLY THE- FOR
THIS REASON AND WE ARE- TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALISPELL. BUT
IF THIS BILL WERE TO MOVE
FORWARD WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIS STAFF AND- THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THAT.
MEASURE THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. WE APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU ALSO SPEAKING OUT IN
OPPOSITION IS MISTER MUHAMMAD.
THIS WHAT MUHAMMAD CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE CAN HEAR ME
CORRECTLY. YES WE CAN. WELL
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO BE
HEARD HERE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WE APPRECIATE YOU
ALL BEING HERE AND- THANK YOU
TO THE STAFF AND COMMITTEE OF
COURSE WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENTION- THE GO TO THE PRO
BUT IT'S OUT THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES WITH THE LANGUAGE- THE
READ CONCERNS PARTICULARLY FOR
SMALL. SO I WANT DRUG BE MADE
TODAY FIRST EXCUSE ME FIRST
BILL LANGUAGE IS UNCLEAR IT
REGARDS TO SEVERAL DIFFERENT
PORTIONS OF THAT ARE THE BILL
WOULD FOR EXAMPLE BENEFIT FROM
BUYING WHETHER BIT HIS WITH
STAYING CARP WHICH ARE RECALL
TO A POINT A DUPLICATE.
SEPARATE POLICIES FOR A
DUPLICATE COUNTRY COVERAGE FOR
CONTRACTOR THAT MIGHT BE
REQUIRED. WE CAN REQUIRE TO
PURCHASING. COULD BE TIED TO
WHAT THE CON ITSELF AND BY
RECEIVE PERSON FROM. BUT THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL DOES NOT
EXACTLY ADDRESS THIS- AN
ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO BELIEVE
THE BILL INTENDS TO BE
PERSPECTIVE ONLY. AND WE WOULD
HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR WOULD
CONSIDER ADDING EXPRESS
LANGUAGE TO MAKE THAT CLEAR.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
CONTRACTORS SECURITY CYBER
INSURANCE SUFFICIENT TO COVER
ALL LOSSES RESULTING FROM
POTENTIAL UNLAWFUL ACCESS TO OR
DISCLOSURE OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION- THIS LANGUAGES
ARE. PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE OF THE
TERM ALL LOSSES COULD INCLUDE
WATER THEY'RE NOT IS ALSO THE
CONTRACTORS BREACH OF THE
AGREEMENT. AND THE TERM
POTENTIAL UNLAWFUL ACT SIR
DISCLOSURE IS NOT TAILORED BY
ANY MEASURABLE HARM- THIRDLY
RELATES TO THE AMOUNT. BRIDGE
COVERAGE THE BILLSTATES THAT
IT SHALL BE IN AN AMOUNT
DETERMINED BY THE CONTRACTING
AGENCY. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS LANGUAGE HERE COULD BE. IT
FROM GARDEN. WE SHOULD THE
AMOUNT OF COVERAGE REQUIRE BY
STATE AGENCIES IT'S A ALL
RELATED TO THE OF DAY. OR THE
SENSE OF THE DATA OR EVEN THE
SIZE OF THE CONTRACT AND IN
THAT SAME BEING WE DO BELIEVE
THAT INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS ARE
BEST ADDRESSED DURING THE RP
PROFITS BUT BECAUSE- STATE
MANDATES DRIVE UP. OUR BARRIERS
OF ENTRY FOR BUSINESSES WANT TO
COMPETE FOR THE CONTRACT AND
THAT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT AFTER. BY
LIMITING COMPETITION AND
ULTIMATELY DRIVING UP COST
TAXPAYERS LOOK FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
POSE AND WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON
THESE ISSUES. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR LET ME TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
ARE THERE OTHER SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM OR
ON THE TELEPHONE. WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR COMMENT.
HI THIS IS COURTNEY JENSEN
WEDTECH MATT- ALSO IN
OPPOSITION AND ECHO THE
COMMENTS- YEAH AND THAT
CALIFORNIA PROPERTY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT HEARING NO OTHER
SPEAKERS IN UP. IT WAS THERE
ANOTHER SPEAKER OPPOSITION I'M
SORRY. NOW THERE'S ONE UP OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU LET'S TAKE
IT BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES SOMEONE ON THE-
YOU KNOW I THINK THERE IS ALL
OF A LOT OF POTENTIAL WITH
CYBER- INSURANCE AND THIS IS
BEEN A DISCUSSION THAT WE'VE
HAD AT AND CSL AT- YOU KNOW
WITH WITH LEGISLATORS THAT ARE
WORKING ON CYBER ISSUES OF OVER
THE LAST YEAR. UNFORTUNATELY
THE CONSENSUS IS THAT THE MID
THE INDUSTRY IS JUST NOT MATURE
ENOUGH TO GET THAT THERE'S NO
REAL CONSISTENCY AND THE
COVERAGE AND OF THAN WE DID
HEAR ANECDOTALLY THAT A LOT OF
THESE- CYBER INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE ACTUALLY OF THAT
WHEN A COMPANY AT IS THE OR
GOVERNMENT HAS A RANSOM WHERE
IT ACT. THAT OF THEIR JUST
SETTLING AND PAYING OFF THE
RANSOMWARE AND AT AS YOU KNOW
THAT'S EXTREMELY BAD POLICY FOR
ESPECIALLY GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
BECAUSE IT JUST ENCOURAGES THE-
PACKERS TO CONTINUOUS SO I KNOW
VENTURE DO THE THAT CYBER
INSURANCE IS THAT THAT IS THAT.
IT'S GOING TO MATURE I JUST
DON'T THINK IT'S A RIGHT NOW
AND I THINK THIS COULD BE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE SO- I'M GONNA
BE LAYING ON BILL TODAY.
SOMEONE WILL ROOMS IN. THANK
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR UP MR
CHOW WANTED TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO A REACTS TO A
CAL CHAMBERS QUESTION ABOUT THE
METHODOLOGY BY WHICH A-
CONTRACTING AGENCY WOULD GO
ABOUT CALCULATING THE AMOUNT OF
REQUIRED INSURANCE GIVEN THE
BROAD LANGUAGE OF THE BILL THAT
SAYS. A SUFFICIENT TO COVER ALL
LOSSES RESULTING FROM POTENTIAL
UNLAWFUL ACCESS. HI YES OF AT
THIS POINT WE DON'T WANT THE
LANGUAGE TO BE TOO PRESCRIPTIVE
AND I THINK- IT IS PRUDENT FOR
US TO ALLOW THAT DECISION TO BE
MADE- AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- AT
THIS AGENCY LEVEL- SO THAT
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT'S- WHAT
INFORMATION IS BEING COVER
WHAT- BUT THE CALL YOU KNOW
THE- POLICY OUGHT TO BE SO- I
THINK THAT- THE DECISION IS TO
ALLOW THE AGENCIES TO THIS
QUESTION- TO DETERMINE EXACTLY
HOW MUCH ARE THE POLICY OUGHT
TO BE AND ALSO WHAT INFORMATION
IS BEING COVER- OF HEAVY SAID
THAT I THINK. D. ARE YOU KNOW
WE'RE DEFINITELY FLEXIBLE AND
OPEN TO- TAKING A LANGUAGE- ARE
GOING FORWARD I KNOW THAT- YOU
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A CURFEW
OTHER ISSUES HAVE BEEN RAISED
THOUGHT WHICH I DEEM TO BE R.
M. AS- AND- NOT BEING. AS FOR
AS THE- THIS WILL I THINK WE
CAN ALSO TAKE DOES WELL BECAUSE
SOME TO NOT REALLY DEAL WITH
PERSONAL INFORMATION IT'S A
LIBRARY OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT-
AND ALSO THE- TO PUT IT IF
NATURE OF- LET'S SEE. WHAT'S
REQUIRED UNDER THIS LAW AND
EXISTING POLICIES SO I
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT. FULL TO
PAY EXTRA REDUNDANT POLICY OF-
SO I THINK THAT CAN BE- THAT
CAN BE MODIFIED AS WELL- AS
WELL AS THE OTHER OTHER ISSUES
THAT DOESN'T BEEN BROUGHT UP-
SO YEAH SO I TOTALLY.
UNDERSTAND IT AND THE CONCERN
RAISED AND- UNFORTUNATELY WE
DON'T HAVE TIME TO REALLY LOOK
INTO THE ISSUE. ALL WHEN THIS
ISSUE SURFACE SO I COULD JUST
HAVE A COUPLE DAYS AGO. SO YOU
KNOW THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT I'LL
BE VERY HAPPY TO LOOK LOOK INTO
AND ALSO TRY TO FIX THANK YOU I
SHARE THAT CONCERN WITH THE
BROADNESS OF THE LANGUAGE
BECAUSE- A JUST PLAIN READING
OF THE BILL WHEN IT SAYS.
SUFFICIENT TO COVER ALL LOSSES
WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU SHOULD
TAKE AN EXTREME VIEW POINT OF.
THE VERY MAXIMUM OF THE
POTENTIAL LOSS WHEREAS OTHER
CUT FORMS OF INSURANCE THAT'S
NOT THE WAY THAT IT'S DONE. AT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE REQUIRES DRIVERS TO
HAVE LIABILITY INTO. BUT I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE WERE A
COUPLE COVER. ATTENTION AND SO
MAYBE YOU COULD SUBSTITUTE.
SAYS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT IT
IT AS YOU SAY. GIVING THE
CONTRACTING AGENCY THE ABILITY
TO DETERMINE A REASONABLE
AMOUNT BUT NOT PRESCRIBING THEM
TO HAVE TO COVER THE MAXIMUM
AMOUNT. I'LL QUESTION ABOUT
COMPANIES ABILITY TO SELF
INSURE BECAUSE TYPICALLY WHEN
WE IMPOSE A REQUIREMENT ON
COMPANIES WE DO ALLOW THEM. TO
CERTIFY THAT THEY HAVE THE
ASSETS NECESSARY. TO COVER A
LOSS AND IF THAT'S THE CASE BUT
WE DON'T REQUIRE THEM TO BUY A
COMMERCIAL PRODUCT. AND I
DIDN'T SEE THAT- THAT KIND OF
LANGUAGE IN YOUR BILL AND I WAS
WONDERING WHAT YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT IT. YEAH HI- I'M FAMILIAR
WITH THAT ALSO BECAUSE WHEN I
SERVED ON A LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD
I. WE DID EXACTLY THAT WE SELF
INSURED AND TO A CERTAIN LIMIT
AND ANYTHING BEYOND THAT WOULD
BE COVERED BY IT YOU KNOW I
POLICY. SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE ALSO LOOK INTO AYE AYE
I THINK- WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE. TO SEE LET'S SEE. I
INDUSTRY FIRST OR- ANYBODY.
NOBODY HAS ACT COME UP WITH ANY
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT THIS BILL
UNTIL RECENTLY SO. SO THIS IS
SOMETHING AND OTHER EVERY THAT
WE ARE VERY HAPPY TO LOOK INTO
AS WELL. I'VE SELF INSURANCE
AND OTHER OTHER POTENTIAL HERE
IS THAT WE SHOULD TOUCH ON.
pTHAT WOULD STILL ACCOMPLISH
YOUR PURPOSE BECAUSE- IF YOU'RE
INTENDING TO MAKE SURE THAT
COMPANIES CAN SURVIVE. AND ALSO
THE CLAIMS GET PAID IF YOU HAVE
A FAIRY FINANCIALLY HEALTHY
COMPANY THAT'S WILLING TO MAKE
THAT- THAT KIND OF
DEMONSTRATION I THINK THAT
THAT- YOU KNOW THAT. THERE
WOULD STILL ACCOMPLISH WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE. I
GOTCHA THANK YOU. MR CHAO WOULD
YOU I LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND- YOU KNOW ONCE AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE FOR. GIVING SO MUCH
INFORMATION WITHIN SYSTEM SO
YOU KNOW SUCH A SUCH A SHORT
TIME PERIOD SO. BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION AND I
WANT TO APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY
THAT. YEAH DURING THE RECESS
AND- I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. WITHOUT A-
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. I
BELIEVE WE NEED A MùT. ON A
SECOND. BUT A SEPARATE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHILD BY CHILD
HI KILEY. KILEY KNOW OUR CAN.
BERMAN HELLO. MEDINA MEDINA I
CARILLO. CREEL I'M MULLIN
MULLIN AYE GALLAGHER. IRWIN
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO WICKS
WICKS. IT'S. ALL AT THE BILL
WAS ON CALL- I'M GONNA HAND THE
GAVEL BACK TO- CHAIR- CHAO AND
WE CAN PROCEED TO. THIS THANK
YOU.
THERE ARE. LIKE WILDLIFE
THERE'S VOMITING WHAT IF
ANYTHING LINE. YEAH THEY GOT
OVER THERE ANYWAY. RATHER YEAH
YEAH. WE DON'T. DON'T AFTER W.
BOB. YEAH. THIS I DON'T I DON'T
WANT TO TOUCH THE MIKE. HOW QUE
OF. I COULD JUST CALL IT OUT I
THINK I'LL. SO LOOK AT THIS
TIME LET'S. TWO THE ADD ONS I
STARTING WITH- TWO THOUSAND
FOUR CALDERON PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MULLIN THANK.
MULLIN NINE. HAS NINE VOTES
OKAY NEXT WE HAVE- AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY THREE WEBER. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR CARILLO.
CORREO HI MULLIN. MULLIN HI.
NEXT WE HAVE TWENTY THREE
TWENTY CHILD. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR MULLIN. MULLIN HI. NEXT
WE HAVE- AB THIRTY ONE SIXTEEN
IRWIN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MOTION IS TO PASS
MULLIN- MULLIN AYE. YEAH YEAH.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
DESERVE ONE. THIRTY ONE SIXTEEN
IRWIN. THIRTY ONE SIXTEEN IRWIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. OUR
HI CHAO I. CORREO. HI MULLIN I
HAVE. I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO.
NEXT WE HAVE AB TWENTY EIGHT
ELEVEN BERMAN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
I THINK HAVE
EVERYONE VOTING ON BERMAN ALL
RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY NINE THAT'S- GONZALEZ
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE I THINK I HAVE
EVERYONE ON THEMSELVES OKAY XFR
ONLY WE HAVE AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY ONE CHILD PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SECOND SALAS
THIS ONE IS CHILD AT THE LAST
ONE WAS GONZALEZ TWENTY ONE
FORTY NINE. I ADD ON OKAY I'M
GONNA COME CHECK THAT YOU GUYS
ARE JUST A MOMENT. YEAH AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND WE HAVE
GALLAGHER. YOU HAVE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I. THAT HAS EIGHT
THAT IS OKAY SO WE- COMING DOWN.
I'VE TO START. THE LAST ONE
BEING AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY.
THE LAST ONE WAS AB TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AND WE HAVE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOW. FIVE VOTES. WE
GOT EVERYBODY. OKAY DEAF BILL
FAILS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EVERYONE. THANK GOD. KEVIN YEAH.
RIGHT RIGHT. YOUR. YEAH I.
RIGHT.
AND WE GET YEAH OKAY SO
WE ARE YEAH. TURN.